Nice!
Oh, Twitch hat wieder nicht gecheckt, dass das Video on ist.
Exzellent.
Not alone.
Painschamp.
Auf Twitch.
Mach mal an.
Ah, jetzt.
Jetzt wird es an.
Exquisite.
Stripes007 schon am Start.
Heißt, Subbox gecampt oder was?
Wobei, wie nennt man das auf Twitch?
Auf YouTube ist es Subbox.
Wie ist es denn? Notification Box.
Wie ist es denn auf Twitch?
Ich bin seit 8 Uhr
schon auf Twitch.
Ich bin seit 8 Uhr schon auf, ja.
Wegen der Zeitumstellung, das stimmt.
Ich hab's gar nicht gecheckt, dass es heute Nacht war.
Ich hab auf die Uhr geguckt, heute Morgen, als ich im Bad war.
Und da hab ich festgestellt, es ist wie 8.10 Uhr.
Hä, wie 8.10 Uhr? Ich hab jetzt 9.
Klar.
Also ich stehe ja nicht wirklich nach Uhrzeit auf am Wochenende.
So wie sie...
Ich hab erst dann später auf die Uhr geguckt.
Ich stehe ja auch unter der Woche nicht wirklich nach Uhrzeit auf.
Ich wache immer auf von allein.
Also ich glaube, ich bin die letzten...
Also ich...
Okay, mal übertrieben.
Die letzten 15 Jahre
vielleicht eine Handvoll Mal
durch irgendwelche anderen Sachen
geweckt worden, als dass ich
von allein aufgewacht bin.
Also ich wache immer von allein auf.
Also egal, ob ich jetzt irgendwie
5.45 Uhr aufstehen muss oder ob ich jetzt irgendwie
bis, frag mich nicht, 7.30 Uhr, 8.30 Uhr
pennen kann. Ich hab das irgendwie
im Hinterkopf, wann ich aufstehen muss.
Ich stelle noch nicht mal meinen Wecker.
Ich gucke ja recht viele so
Home Automation Videos auf
auf YouTube und
eines der Hauptbestandteile dieser Videos
ist Leute, die sich irgendwelche Wecker einstellen
und
dann machen, wie komm ich einfacher
aus dem Bett mit irgendwelchen
Lightstrips, die angehen und sowas.
Brauche ich alles nicht.
Habe ich echt Glück. Also ich wache immer von allein auf.
Discord Notification...
Ach stimmt, wir haben ja im Discord
wir haben ja im Discord
Stream Notification.
Da habe ich ja schon gar nicht mehr dran gedacht.
So, was will denn YouTube, dass wir heute gucken?
Was...
Was übrigens ein cooler Trend ist auf YouTube,
der mir tatsächlich gefällt,
na, ich bin ja immer viel am Meckern
über YouTube,
dass, aber da kann YouTube nichts für.
Und vielleicht doch, vielleicht, vielleicht ist der YouTube Algorithmus mittlerweile so,
dass das ganz gut gefördert wird.
Es gibt immer mehr Leute, die so komplette Kurse auf YouTube hochladen.
Sei es jetzt irgendwie so ein Linux Beginner Kurs, irgendein C-Sharp Kurs,
irgendein Arduino Kurs, irgendein Web Development Kurs.
Es gibt total viele komplette Kurse mittlerweile, die teilweise irgendwie
fünf, sechs, sieben, acht Stunden lang gehen insgesamt auf YouTube kostenlos.
Finde ich echt ziemlich cool.
Finde ich ziemlich gut und qualitativ sind die meistens gar nicht so übel.
Zumindest das, was ich gesehen habe bisher.
Also ich gucke ja so.
Ich gucke jetzt nicht allzu viele acht Stunden Kurse.
Kommt nicht so oft vor.
Sniper vs. Tank.
Das kennen wir schon.
Was machen Sie hier?
Terminating Cat5 Cable.
Ein Krimp Wettbewerb.
Was ist denn mit denen los?
Bin ich froh, dass ich so eine Kacke nicht mehr machen muss.
Ich meine, ich weiß, wie es geht.
Und ich habe hier letztens sogar mal mich wieder dran.
Gewagt.
Aber Kabel von Hand machen ist wirklich der allerletzte Müll.
Da bin ich.
Da bin ich froh, dass ich das nicht machen muss.
Muss übrigens gerade mal nebenbei gucken,
ob ich den Heizlüfter im Bad ausgemacht habe.
Aber das Schöne ist, das kann ich ja dank der geflashten Steckdosen
jetzt total einfach sehen.
Exzellent.
Funktioniert.
Wann kommt das Video mit den Servern?
Oh, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Ob ich. Ja.
Doch, das muss ich machen.
Die Audioqualität sagt, aber ich muss mal gucken.
Ich muss mal gucken.
Vielleicht.
Also ich bin ja wirklich ernsthaft am überlegen,
ob ich den Weihnachtskalender dieses Jahr mache.
Ich habe mir schon viele Sachen aufgeschrieben.
Ich habe so ungefähr gerade so 12, 13 verschiedene Sachen,
die man machen könnte.
Die Sache bei mir ist ja erst mal.
Ich brauche erst mal die Ideen, die mich dann motivieren,
dass ich es mache. So, mal gucken.
Vielleicht macht er noch das Server Video.
Schreibe ich mir, schreibe ich mir gleich noch mal rein.
Litschak 1 978.
11 Monate. Das ist ja eins vor.
Aktuell ist es.
Aktuell ist es erst erst.
Aber in einem Monat ist es.
Die Leute sind auch richtig beknackt.
Ich habe jetzt Ankündigungen gesehen von von Sony auf Twitter
und hier auf auf YouTube haben sie Zeug gepostet.
Und immer wenn Sony jetzt was postet.
Zur PS5 kommen die Leute gleich an.
Dad Game Shit Console Xbox Betto.
Jetzt haben die den ganzen Tag nichts anderes zu tun.
Och Kobol Stream.
Hör mal auf da habe ich noch gar nicht mal dran gedacht.
Alter Kobol Stream das muss ich an Weihnachten machen.
Weihnachten lerne ich Kobol.
Ja, ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns mal eine Runde.
Wir gucken uns mal eine Runde Battlefield an.
Ich gebe YouTube eine Chance, noch was vorzuschlagen, was spannend ist.
Äh Phipps. Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
So.
Dieser 60 Euro Medium Gamer Pizzeria, oh Gott, das sieht ja aus wie von 2005, ja.
Nein, YouTube schlägt uns nichts Gescheites vor.
Ach komm, einem einmal Schlösser knacken, das gucke ich mir immer gerne an.
Chat, ich muss euch mal was fragen.
Ja, wir haben doch hier bestimmt, was ist das denn?
Full Quad SATA Headphone, oh, das ist ja mal huge sinnlos.
Warum soll man denn sowas?
Okay, Moment, warum, warum, warum, warum soll ich sowas bauen?
Das ist ja schon eine komplette Zweckentfremdung der Hardware quasi.
Einen Quad SATA NAS mit einem Raspberry Pi zu bauen, das ist ja...
Ich meine, es geht, aber es geht viel, was nicht unbedingt sonderlich sinnvoll ist.
Kennst du Money Boy Trap House Kitchen? Ja, habe ich sogar letztens...
Oh, wir haben 69 Zuschauer, exzellent.
Habe ich sogar letztens geguckt, eine Runde.
Ich überlege gerade, was hat er denn gemacht?
Äh, äh, Chicken Wings, glaube ich.
Habe ich letztens, letztens, ich glaube, Chicken Wings waren es.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich, das geht, das geht an mir vorbei, warum das die Leute so geil finden.
Ich meine, das ist weder eine gute Kochshow, noch ist es irgendwie lustig,
noch kann ich diesem auf, auf ultra krass Gangster Hip Hop Man machen, da irgendwie was abgewinnen.
Also, das kann man sich einmal angucken, aber sonderlich, also, warum das?
Crispy Wings, genau, so, also, warum das jetzt so geil ankommt, verstehe ich nicht,
aber da bin ich wahrscheinlich zu boomer für, dass ich das verstehe nicht.
Windows Fan Tested Linux Laptop.
Okay, das können wir uns mal angucken.
Was ist das hier?
S-Clap?
Ach, der Scheiß, oh je.
Ach, der Kram.
Oh, nee, das muss jetzt nicht sein.
Sowas, das ist, das ist so ein typisches Twitch-Ding, was auch nicht so gut ist.
Das ist so ein typisches Twitch-Ding, was auch nicht so gut ist.
Das ist so ein typisches Twitch-Ding, was auch keiner versteht.
Ähm, jetzt, wo wir gerade beim Thema Twitch sind, ihr habt das bestimmt alle mit diesen Copyright-Geschichten mitbekommen, oder?
Das ist so unglaublich bescheuert.
Casey, 6,84 Monate, danke schön.
Exquisite Subscription.
Also, es geht ja gerade so wieder die Angst um auf Twitch, deswegen haben Leute wieder ihre, ihre Worts gelöscht.
Zum Beispiel hier, wenn man bei Dance Gaming guckt auf Twitch, Video Worts, dann stellt man fest, dass der, ah, Moment, äh, ich will eigentlich nichts.
Dass der kaum, äh.
Worts am Start hat.
Sonst hatte der Worts.
So.
Und das liegt daran, weil die gerade extrem umtriebig sind, wieder was Copyright-Geschichten auf Twitch angeht.
So, was natürlich heißt, dass man, äh, auch keine Games mehr streamen kann mit Musik drinnen.
Also, ich meine, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Mixgedudel im Hintergrund wird noch gehen, da wird wahrscheinlich keiner großartig jetzt irgendwelche Rechte drauf haben, aber, ähm, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel GTA spielst,
gucken wir mal, ob's da, mal gucken.
Gucken wir mal, ob das schon irgendwelche Mainstream-Dinger aufgegriffen haben.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja.
Ja, ja, genau.
Hier sind sie alle, sind sie alle schon am Rumspermen.
So, also sprich, GTA spielen ist nicht mehr, Spiele mit Zwischensequenzen mit Musik ist nicht mehr.
So, und der Witz ist ja dabei, dass ich, also, also, okay, erstens muss man sagen, ich weiß, warum die jetzt anfangen.
Weil Twitch durch diese ganze, und da ist tatsächlich mal Corona dran schuld, meiner Ansicht nach zumindest.
Twitch ist gerade in der Corona-Krise.
In der Corona-Zeit jetzt vom Mainstream fast schon zum Ultra-Mainstream geworden.
Und die, dass jetzt so die ganzen, ähm, Anwälte und, äh, Stonks-Manager jetzt nicht gerade so bei neuen Medien sich gut auskennen, ist ja, glaub ich, allen klar.
Das heißt, die haben bisher von Twitch gar nichts großartig mitgekriegt und ging, ging Twitch, ging, ging ein bisschen an denen vorbei.
Und jetzt in der Corona-Zeit, weil Twitch halt so richtig, richtig beliebt wieder geworden ist.
Ich mein, die, die View-Zeiten überall gehen ja durch die Decke, ne.
Außer, außer bei der Overwatch-League.
Aber, da sind die, da sind die paar Blizzard selbst dran schuld.
Aber ansonsten gehen die View-Zeiten ja komplett durch die Decke überall.
Das heißt, Twitch ist jetzt auch in den Fokus gerückt von irgendwelchen Anwälten und Stonks-Managern.
Und das schiebe ich tatsächlich auf Corona, dass das klar zu ist.
So, äh, ja, da sag ich gleich was zu Splinter-X.
Ne, ne, Splixer, nicht Splinter, Splixer.
Ähm, so.
Und dadurch kommen die jetzt halt alle hier auf Twitch.
Und jetzt übertreiben sie es halt total.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es halt total, dass, ähm, die ersten sind System irgendwie implementieren wollen,
dass Live-Streams ausgeschaltet, dass du quasi live die Streams scannst nach Copyright-Music und Takedown kannst.
Und dass du die Worts scannen kannst und striken und takedown kannst, so.
Das Problem bei der ganzen Geschichte ist nur, dass, ähm, die, die Lage, was du jetzt machen kannst, so wie der absolut unklar ist.
Also du musst halt einfach nur...
...hoffen, du machst nix, was zum Beispiel Disney anpisst.
Weil wenn du Disney anpisst, dann hast du wahrscheinlich gleich 80 Anwälte am Arsch, wenn du nicht irgendwas machst.
Die haben zwar, äh, schöne, bunte, niedliche Sachen, aber...
...so eben, eben, eben, die, die Anwälte sind nicht schön bunt und niedlich bei Disney, garantiert nicht.
So.
Und, äh, oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen.
Mittlerweile kannst du eigentlich fast sagen, du musst aufpassen, dass du Disney nicht anpisst, weil irgendwie 90% gefühlt mittlerweile Disney in irgendeiner Art und Weise ist.
So, und, äh, das Problem ist...
...das Problem dabei ist jetzt, dass du halt erstens keine Ahnung genau hast, was du machen kannst, was du nicht machen kannst.
Also, du, du, du, wirklich?
Man würde ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, zum Beispiel, irgend, zum Beispiel sowas hier.
Ja?
Würde man eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass man sowas hier spielen darf.
Das ist ein Cover mit einem extra Text, selbst gespielter Musik, aber halt was nachgespielt.
Das ist Grauzone.
Soweit sind wir schon.
Sowas ist Grauzone.
Also normalerweise würde man sagen, ja, es ist gar kein...
Hallo? Musik?
Es ist, das ist gar kein Problem.
Also, man kann...
...man kann...
...man kann natürlich was Nachgespieltes, Nachgesungenes mit anderem Text bringen.
Ähm, aber...
...du kannst das...
Äh, Kleines Gummis glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Also, er schreibt, das macht Twitch auch wegen ihrem eigenen Musikprogramm.
Die, die, also, wenn Twitch das forcieren würde, wären die ja selbst schön doof.
Die, die das forcieren, ist die rechte Verwertungsindustrie.
Noch nicht mal unbedingt die ganzen Künstler, aber die rechte Verwertungsindustrie ist da ganz, ganz hinterher.
Twitch, wenn Twitch das selbst forcieren würde...
...das wäre ja blöd.
Die wollen doch nicht selbst ihre eigenen Leute verkraulen oder, oder vertreiben oder dafür sorgen, dass die vielleicht Sachen nicht überspielen können, die Leute anziehen.
Das, das wäre ja total beknackt.
Das macht das, das kann, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass das an Twitch liegt.
Das liegt an Content-Verwertungs, äh, sagen wir mal Mafia, ähm, die das Ganze machen.
So, und was jetzt auch, was ich, was ich aber halt nicht verstehe, ist, vielleicht erinnert sich noch der ein oder andere dran, ähm, Twitch hat auch viele Möglichkeiten mit Amazon Music.
Ich finde es total cool, dass Twitch gerade so etwas klappt, dass man administriert mit Amazon Music nicht die, nicht die Lizenz haben, sie weiter zu geben an Streamer.
Hätten die das würden sie das machen.
Hä? Was geht bei YouTube nicht.
Bei YouTube, YouTube ist doch schon jahrelang viel restriktiver als Twitch, was äh, Copyright-Sachen angeht.
Twitch war eine, war lange Zeit, du konntest mehr oder weniger machen was du willst, solange du es nicht total übertrieben hast und irgendwelche ähm, ähm, rein Musik äh, Words gemacht hast und sowas.
Aber YouTube ist schon, ist, viel restriktiv.
Jahrelang.
YouTube gibt es ja schon eine Weile, restriktiver als Twitch, was Copyright angeht.
Und auf YouTube wurdest du schon früher gestrikt, wenn du 10 Sekunden das Falsche drin hattest.
So, und das, also was ich aber nicht ganz verstehe ist, was da unterm Strich bei rauskommen soll.
Vielleicht erinnert sich die ein oder andere Leute noch dran, als die gleichen Medien-Stonks-Anwalt-Management-Mischmasch
vor so 2005, 2000 rum gesagt haben, so als Napster auch am angesagt war und später Audio Galaxy und was es da nicht alles gab.
Kauft CDs. Die haben damals gesagt, kauft CDs.
Wer sich Sachen im Internet illegal runterlädt, ist böse. Ganz, ganz schlimm.
Vielleicht kennt jeder noch die, Moment, vielleicht finde ich die Werbung jetzt.
Vielleicht kennt ihr das noch.
Äh, Papa Raubkopier...
Ja, hier, das da. Vielleicht kennt das noch jemand, vielleicht kennt das noch jemand.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Alter, halt's Maul. Ich hasse, ich hasse Kinder, die rumschreien. Das ist so schlimm.
Das eigentlich, eigentliche kommt jetzt ja.
Raubkopierer werden mit beschädigten Fähren freiheitsentzündet.
So, und jetzt muss man mal vorstellen, diesen Shit, diesen Kack, musste man sich geben, genauso wie es Netzwürfel schreibt, wenn man legal diesen Kram abonniert hat.
Ich meine, das ist schon hart.
Hat er, hat er Kram, ja.
So, und das sind die gleichen Stonkstypen, die jetzt an Twitch am Start sind, die hinter sowas stecken.
So, und früher haben sie erzählt, so nach dem Motto, ja, kauft euch CDs und uns entgehen ja Millionen, Milliarden, Billiarden, was weiß ich.
Wir haben ja eh schon so wenig Geld durch illegale Sachen.
Und was damals der Fall war, die Leute haben gesagt, fickt euch.
Die haben nämlich keine CDs gekauft.
Und die Leute haben sich damals auch nicht einreden lassen, kauft euch CDs.
Weil CDs in der damaligen Zeit schon damals nicht mehr zeitgemäß waren.
Also, wenn die Leute die Auswahl haben, ich will Musik haben.
So, sie können daheim vorm Rechner sitzen bleiben und im Internet nach einer Musik suchen, runterladen, anhören, gut ist.
Oder sie müssen in den Laden dort vielleicht noch was Probe hören, dann eine teure CD kaufen, dann wieder zurück und dann...
Also was machen die Leute?
Es geht da gar nicht so sehr ums Geld.
Es geht darum, was ist eigentlich...
Einfacher.
Und natürlich haben die Leute damals gesagt, Internet, einfach runterladen.
Es gab ja keine offiziellen Angebote.
Und was die sich damals auch schon unglaublich schön gerechnet haben ist, dass jeder, der illegal etwas downloadet oder illegal was Probe hört...
Ich nenn's ja lieber Probe hören.
Das ist genauso wie, dass es keine Raubkopien sind, sondern Sicherheitskopien, ne?
08max7, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub, huge.
Big Brain Subscription.
So, und dann haben die ja gesagt, der vergeht...
Entgeht ihnen pro downgeloadeter Song, entgeht ihnen quasi ein Verkauf.
Was natürlich Schwachsinn ist.
Blödsinn.
Das ist da vollkommen an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Aber warum haben das die Leute damals gemacht?
Weil das absolut nicht mehr zeitgemäß war.
Die Leute wollten keine CD kaufen.
Die wollten auch nicht ins Geschäft gehen und sich dann noch anhören müssen, wenn sie was legal erworben haben.
Die sind Raubkopierer und kommen in den Knast.
Mal ganz davon aus...
Genau, was Felix Splitter sagt, ist auch vollkommen richtig.
Das Wort Raubkopien trifft's eh nicht, weil es ist noch nicht mal Diebstahl.
Das ist sogar rechtlich tatsächlich wirklich so.
Also es ist kein Diebstahl.
Weil Diebstahl bedeutet immer, dass irgendwie einer was hat, das wird geklaut und ist danach weg und bei wem anders.
Das ist ja bei Raubkopien nicht so.
Also weder...
Es ist weder Raub, noch Diebstahl, noch sonst was.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was es genau ist.
Wahrscheinlich umgehend von Kopien.
Da gibt's ja mittlerweile eigene Gesetze für.
Aber es ist definitiv kein Raub und kein Diebstahl.
So.
Das heißt, damals war das ganze Zeug nicht zeitgemäß.
Die Leute wollten das nicht.
Und siehe da, man hat jetzt Streaming-Angebote.
Man hat Video-Streaming-Angebote, Musik-Streaming-Angebote.
Und siehe da, wer hätte das gedacht?
Die Leute kaufen's tatsächlich.
Und keiner lädt sich...
Guck mal, wer lädt sich heute noch mal illegal irgendwas runter?
Das Einzige, wo man sich heute irgendwas...
Ich kann's zumindest das schon von mir sagen.
Das Einzige, wo man sich heute mal vielleicht auf irgendwelchen zwielichten Seiten nochmal mal irgendeinen Stream zu Gemüte führt oder irgendwo Musik runterlädt, ist, wenn es das woanders nicht gibt.
Also zum Beispiel, ich will irgendeine...
Sagen wir jetzt mal, es gibt irgendwie BBC, irgendeine Serie oder irgendwie was, was ich aus England gucken will.
Und die bieten das quasi nur Region Locked UK an.
So, da bleibt mir ja gar nichts anderes da übrig, wenn ich das gucken will, als mir das auf irgendeiner Streaming-Seite anzugucken.
Also ich weich heute nur noch auf irgendwelche zweifelhaft legalen Angebote aus, wenn ich die Sache nicht normal bekomme.
Das ist genauso wie mit Spielen.
Also die meisten Leute kaufen sich heute Spiele absichtlich auf Steam, selbst wenn sie ein bisschen teurer sind.
Absolut, dass sie alle schönen Steam-Trimmer haben.
Also siehe da.
Wenn es Angebote gibt, dann wird das auch gemacht.
Und es funktioniert.
Und damals mit CDs war das einfach absolut nicht mehr zeitgemäß.
Genauso wie ich dieses ganze Copyright-Zeug in der heutigen Form nicht mehr zeitgemäß finde.
Weil die Sachen, diese Gesetze sind ja ursprünglich mal entstanden, fragt mich nicht.
Also lange bevor es das Internet in der Form, wie es das heute gibt, gab.
Und dementsprechend passt das Ganze auch nicht.
Und was ich letztendlich unterm Strich gar nicht verstehe ist, was sich die Rechteanbieter auf Twitch davon versprechen.
Das verstehe ich.
Nehme ich nicht.
Weil wenn man sich mal überlegt, was passiert.
Die Streamer, die jetzt quasi in...
Also es gibt natürlich auch Streamer, die ja ihren Lebensunterhalt damit verdienen.
Das heißt für die ist das nicht so wie bei mir, wo ich sage, hey, wenn da mal irgendwie was gesperrt wird oder so,
dann warte ich halt sechs Wochen und mache weiter oder so.
Leute, die damit ihren Lebensunterhalt verdienen, ist, wenn die mal sechs Wochen nicht streamen dürfen, ist halt scheiße.
Ja.
Was machst du als Vollzeit-Streamer, wenn du jetzt nicht einer der riesengroßen bist, der schon...
Hunderttausende gecheffelt hat, wenn du so im Mittelfeld bist, was machst du, wenn du sechs Wochen nicht streamen kannst?
Da bist du ziemlich im Arsch.
Ziemlich kacke ist das.
Du bist nicht gleich verhungert, du hast vielleicht ein bisschen Reserven, aber sechs Wochen nicht streamen...
Ist schon was.
Gut, sechs Wochen habe ich jetzt einfach mal aus der Luft gegriffen, ja.
So.
Das ist schon ganz schön scheiße.
Deswegen werden die das Risiko nicht eingehen.
Das heißt...
Im Endeffekt wird das dazu fühlen, dass um alles, was auch nur ansatzweise...
Irgendwie...
Verdächtig sein könnte, da irgendwie dagegen zu verstoßen, wird nicht mehr gemacht.
Was dazu führt, dass viele beliebten Sachen auf Twitch nicht mehr gemacht werden.
Na, zum Beispiel kein GTA mehr.
Oder keine Spiele mit Zwischensequenzen mehr.
Oder was auch immer.
Was natürlich Twitch auch nicht gefällt, weil das das Programm einschränkt.
Und den Streamern nicht gefällt.
Und die Frage ist, ob das den Spieleherstellern gefällt.
Letztens hat ja wieder irgendein Typ auf Twitter erzählt, dass...
Spielehersteller...
Sollten...
Geld dafür nehmen, dass Let's Player die Let's Playen dürfen.
Warte mal.
Der Lost hat das, glaube ich, Twitter...
NetLost...
Ich glaube, der heißt nur noch Lost, ne?
Letztens auf Twitter gepostet.
Und was ich ganz witzig fand, den Typ...
Von dem habe ich schon öfters mal was gelesen.
Wisst ihr, wer das ist?
Er hat es nicht in seinem Profil stehen.
Aber wenn ich euch das sage, lacht ihr euch kaputt bei dieser Aussage.
Also er hat geschrieben...
Also in der Wahrheit ist es so, dass die Streamer die Entwickler bezahlen sollen,
wenn sie...
Wenn sie Spiele streamen.
So.
Der Typ...
Der...
Der Typ, der macht...
Der macht...
Der macht neben dem, dass er für Assassin's Creed zuständig war und sowas...
Wisst ihr, wo der noch mitarbeitet?
Der Chat hat schon gespoilert.
Der gleiche Typ...
Ist bei Google Stadia mit dabei.
An entscheidender Position.
So, da wundert mich jetzt nichts mehr.
Wenn solche Leute bei Stadia dabei sitzen, dass da nichts klappt, ja?
Er hat's...
Er hat's irgendwie nicht...
Er hat's irgendwie nicht mit...
Hier drin stehen.
Aber wenn ihr danach sucht, der Typ ist Stadia...
Irgendein Stadia...
Er ist kein Stadia-CEO oder so.
Er ist ein Stadia-Creative-Director.
Also der hat schon was zu sagen bei Stadia.
Das ist jetzt kein Stadia...
Also solche Leute sind da am Start.
Und das ist natürlich komplett...
Naja.
Komplett bescheuert.
In seinem Profil steht nichts von Stadia, oder?
Steht da was von Stadia?
Oh mein Gott, das ist Raubkopie.
Ah, geh fort.
Äh...
Da steht nichts von Stadia, oder?
Ne, da steht nichts von Stadia.
Das hat er nämlich rausgenommen.
Oder was auch immer.
Also...
Äh...
Das steht nicht drin.
Deswegen dachte ich auch erstmal, der Typ kommt hier bekannt vor.
Aber der ist es nicht doch.
Dann hab ich nachgeguckt, das ist der Stadia-Mann.
So.
Und...
Ja, um jetzt diese Copyright-Geschichte mal abzuschließen.
Also, alle Streamer werden einen großen Bogen drum machen.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Und was die sich versprechen, was die sich davon versprechen...
Äh...
Kapier...
Kapier ich nix.
Kapier ich nicht.
Weil, was wird denn die Folge sein?
Oder sag mal mal...
Was kann ihnen denn Schlimmes passieren?
Überlegt doch mal, was kann einem Content-Vermarkter denn so Schlimmes passieren,
wenn jemand im Stream ein Spiel spielt, wo Musik eines Künstlers, den er vermarktet, drin ist?
Meint der wirklich, ihn entgehen dadurch Verkäufe?
Also, was ist...
Also, was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Irgendein großer Streamer spielt GTA.
Oder spielt irgendein Spiel mit Sachen im Soundtrack, ja?
So.
Also, sag mal GTA.
So, irgendein großer Streamer spielt GTA.
So.
Und dann macht er das Radio an in GTA.
Aber das läuft ein Spiel, also eine Zwischensequenz mit irgendwie, irgendwie einem coolen Song in, in einem Spiel.
So.
Meint der dann wirklich?
Die Leute sagen dann...
Also, jetzt hab ich den Song ja schon gehört.
Ähm...
Jetzt kauf ich mir nicht mehr.
Das ist doch so total, total beknackte, beknackte Dings.
Also, was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Dass jemand in einem Spiel, in einem, in einem Stream, in einer Zwischensequenz ein Lied hört,
das googelt, wer das ist.
Und sich eventuell mal Probe anhört, ob ihm der Künstler gefällt.
Und wenn ihm der Künstler gefällt, das vielleicht auf Spotify oder Amazon Musik kauft.
Also, also, was ist, was ist wahrscheinlicher?
Dass der sich das aus dem Stream rippt und sagt, das muss ich mir nicht mehr kaufen,
weil mir reicht die Musik 30 Sekunden mit dem Streamer, der dabei labert.
Oder, dass der sagt, ja, ich kauf's mir vielleicht.
Also, die Chancen, dass er sich danach die Sache zulegt, wenn er sich das mal im Stream angehört hat,
ist meiner Ansicht nach viel höher, als dass jemand dadurch nicht mehr die Sache kauft.
Okay.
Was natürlich auch noch sein könnte, ist, dass die selber mitbekommen haben,
dass qualitativ vieles, was released wird, absoluter Scheiß ist.
Und sie nicht wollen, dass man schon im Vorfeld erkennt,
bevor man es sich vielleicht kauft, dass die Musik scheiße ist.
Allerdings ergibt das keinen Sinn, weil wahrscheinlich Spiele nicht die Scheiß-Tracks von einem Künstler nehmen würden.
Um sie zu, also, ne, ergibt, ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
So, also deswegen verstehe ich den Sinn nicht, was man haben möchte, was die, was die wollen.
Wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man, wenn man,
wenn man diese ganze Copyright-Geschichte auf Twitch macht.
Flowpop sagt, schade, dass Twitch sich da raushält.
Ja gut, es ist, es ist schwierig.
Also was soll Twitch, was soll Twitch großartig machen?
Ich meine, die Gesetze gibt es ja.
Und das kommt durch, wie gesagt, das kommt meiner Meinung nach durch Corona,
dass jetzt, dass immer mehr in, in Fokus rückt von irgendwelchen Stonks und CEO.
Wie, wie heißt denn eigentlich der, wie heißt denn der Chef der Rechtsabteilung?
Es gibt einen CTO, das ist der Technologie-Mensch.
Wie?
Wie heißt denn der Chef von der, von der, der Rechtschef, CLO, Chief Lawyer, Office, keine Ahnung, wie nennt man sowas?
Zumindest die sind jetzt halt darauf aufmerksam geworden.
Also es führt, es führt meiner Meinung nach zu nix und was passieren wird ist, das komplette Gegenteil von dem, was die sich erhoffen in irgendeiner Art und Weise,
äh, was passieren wird ist, dass einfach alle Streamer einen riesen, einen riesen, riesen Bogen um alles machen, was irgendwie Copyright, ähm, äh, Kram anrüchig ist, ja,
und dann werden sich, wird sich Twitch aufregen, dann werden sich die Spielehersteller aufregen, dann werden sich letztendlich die Künstler aufregen, es werden sich alle aufregen
und am Ende gibt es irgendeinen Deal mit Twitch, dass man das wieder machen kann, in etwas geänderter Art und Weise.
Da geh ich mal von aus.
Weil der aktuelle Zustand ist letztendlich, das ist so ein bisschen Muskelflexen voreinander, ähm, im Endeffekt hat keine Seite mit der aktuellen Regelung wirklich was von.
Weder die Streamer, noch die Zuschauer, noch Twitch, noch die rechte Inhaber, ja, die hoffen einfach beide Seiten oder alle Seiten, dass sie irgendwie was für sich Erträgliches quasi damit jetzt raushandeln können.
Die einen hoffen vielleicht noch ein bisschen Lizenzverträge abzuschließen mit Amazon für Twitch, die andere Seite, äh,
ähm, auf dass ihre Spiele und Sachen weitergezeigt werden, die Streamer hoffen natürlich auch, dass das, dass das funktioniert und, äh, können natürlich auch dementsprechend Druck aufbauen, indem sie einfach nicht irgendwelche halblegalen, grauen Sachen, äh, machen, sondern, und da geh ich auch von aus, dass die meisten Streamer das machen werden, die werden einfach nichts und jetzt wirklich gar nichts mehr zeigen, was irgendwie Musik enthält.
Was aber, was halt dazu führt, dass das den Druck auf Spielehersteller...
Twitch und Zuschauer, also, im Endeffekt hat keiner was von.
So, und deswegen denke ich, wird es da über kurz oder lang eine Einigung geben, dass das, äh, wieder möglich ist.
Vielleicht in gar nicht so langer Zukunft.
Was ist denn, wenn sich ein Streamer eine GEMA-Lizenz holt? Ich glaube, das ist in dem Fall ziemlich wurscht, weil das eine Ami-Plattform ist, aber ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Was ist mit DJ-Musik-Streamern? Tja, das ist eine gute Frage, die können erstmal einpacken.
Sofern die irgendwas verwenden, was Copyright-rechtlich relevant ist.
Was die meisten wahrscheinlich machen.
Das heißt, äh, DJ-, also Musik-Streams wird es nicht mehr geben.
Es ist ja auch schon, also, viel, viel eingeschränkter als jetzt.
Also, es, zumal es ja auch wirklich, es ist ja, es ist ja Grauzone aktuell.
Es ist ja Grauzone aktuell, ob du zum Beispiel was, äh, äh, covern darfst und sowas.
Normalerweise, bauchmäßig, würde man sofort sagen, klar darfst du was covern und spielen.
So klar ist das gar nicht.
Das ist zwar geduldet und eigentlich...
...eigentlich auch okay, aber ob das noch so ohne weiteres jetzt sich die Leute trauen, ist, sei mal dahingestellt, ja.
Also, DJ-Musik-Streams wird es aktuell ganz, ganz schwierig auf, auf Twitch.
Auf YouTube ja auch eh schon.
Deswegen läuft ja nur so gedudelt hier auf YouTube.
Tja, so sieht's aus.
Total bescheuert, hat keiner was von.
Also, zur Zeit hat da wirklich keiner was von.
Twitch nicht, Zuschauer nicht, Streamer nicht, Musikindustrie nicht.
Künstler erst recht nicht.
Die haben ja lustigerweise von allem immer am allerwenigsten.
Ja.
So, also, was gucken wir?
Was gucken wir mal?
Warum?
Also, das, das leuchtet mir jetzt überhaupt nicht ein.
Das ist, das, das, wie gesagt, ich will das jetzt gar nicht großartig gucken.
Aber warum missbraucht man einen Raspberry Pi so und baut da draußen einen, einen, einen, vier Platten nass?
Das taugt dafür doch überhaupt nichts.
Das, äh, aber anscheinend sind viele, interessiert das viele Leute.
Und der Grund, warum das für eine Nass nix taucht, ist ganz einfach.
Weil sich die, wie nennen die sich denn?
Ist das die Raspberry Pi Foundation?
Keine Ahnung, die, die Raspberry Pi Hersteller, der Raspberry Pi Hersteller, der hat sich bei der ARM-Lizenz nämlich was gespart.
Der hat sich gedacht, wir kommen mal ganz ohne aus.
Äh, Unrundead kannst du machen.
Äh, die haben sich nämlich gedacht, wir sparen uns die Lizenz für die Crypto-Extensions im ARM.
In der ARM.
In der ARM-CPU.
Und das Doofe ist, dass eine Nass ohne Crypto-Extensions mit so einer schwachen Hardware, wie es der Raspberry Pi ist, leider suckt.
Es sei denn, man möchte wirklich rein, also man möchte gar nichts darauf verschlüsseln oder so.
Aber ich finde, ein ganz normaler Anwendungszweck auf einem Nass ist eigentlich auch, dass die Platten voll verschlüsselt sind.
Also Nass ohne Verschlüsselungsfähigkeiten zu bauen heutzutage.
Nicht sinnvoll, zumal es genug Hardware gibt, die ähnlich günstig ist, die das kann.
Also da muss man sich, oder vielleicht nicht ganz so günstig, aber die das kann.
Und an sich ist ein Raspberry Pi mit 4 GB RAM ist das vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber sowohl von den Schnittstellen her, als auch von der CPU-Leistung her und vor allem den fehlenden Crypto-Extensions her, ist der Raspberry Pi kein allzu gutes Nass-System.
Gerade wenn die hier 4 Platten anschließen wollen.
Der Rasp intern sind die Sachen ja alle.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das hier irgendwo sieht.
Wie sieht denn das mit den Platten eigentlich aus dann?
Zeig mal her.
Wie sieht denn das eigentlich aus mit dem...
Wobei, wir suchen eigentlich...
Wir suchen mal kurz danach.
Ja.
Wie sieht denn das Gehäuse so aus?
Okay, das sind einfach ganz normale SATA Backplanes.
Okay, und es sind auch noch...
Jetzt kannst du nicht...
Ach du Scheiße, ist das eine wackelige Konstruktion.
Will man sich das wirklich geben?
Also mal ganz im Ernst.
Der Kram kostet...
Was kostet das?
Quads, SATA-Heads...
Kostet...
Kostet was?
Kostet so ein komisches Gehäuse.
Shop.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Kann man nicht kaufen.
Ja.
All Net China.
Exit.
Also 35 Dollar.
Dann nochmal irgendwie 70 Dollar für ein Raspberry Pi.
Guck mal.
Du bist mit dem Gehäuse und diesem ganzen Kram...
Du bist, wenn du alles zusammen hast, bist du vielleicht bei 150 Euro am Ende.
Du brauchst dann auch ein Netzteil.
Du brauchst noch ein Gehäuse.
Äh, du brauchst noch...
Ähm...
Nee, eigentlich brauchst du nur ein Netzteil.
Also sag mal so...
Du bist bei ungefähr 150 Euro.
Ohne die Festplatten.
So, und dafür kannst du dir eigentlich auch schon entweder das Einsteiger Synology kaufen,
wenn es unbedingt sein muss.
Oder irgendwas anderes selbst bauen.
Also ich bin immer noch dafür, der Raspberry ist kein gutes Nasssystem.
Und hauptsächlich wegen den fehlenden Crypto-Extensions.
So.
Ähm.
Ja.
New Year Pi sehe ich auch so.
Das sehe ich genauso.
Es hat eigentlich keinen Sinn, sich ein Raspberry Pi nass zu bauen.
So, ähm...
Ja, also es gibt eine Frage.
Ich habe das Problem bei mir, dass alle Daten plus zwei anzeigen.
Also wenn es um elf passiert steht, ist es um eins in Grafana.
Egal, welche Zeitstunde ich in Grafana einstelle, bleibt das Problem bestehen.
Du könntest mal über die Rest-API was abrufen.
Und gucken, was da wirklich für ein Timestamp drin steht.
Ähm, aber ansonsten kannst du...
Hast du es irgendwie Docker-mäßig laufen oder auf dem Host installiert?
Da könntest du nämlich mal gucken, was du für eine Zeitzone auf deinem Server eingestellt hast, falls das du was bringt.
Habe ich aber wenig Erfahrung mit...
Also mein...
Ich habe übrigens ein paar neue Grafana-Dashboards bei mir am Start.
Also, das ist ja meine Heizung.
Die habe ich euch jetzt ja schon oft genug erzählt.
Guck mal, der Cute-Mod ist da.
Äh, Fenris, äh, ESX auf dem Raspberry Pi haben wir ausprobiert.
Funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Ist zwar nach wie vor reichlich sinnlos, aber funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Äh, Xen muss ich noch ausprobieren.
So, also das ist ja einfach die Sache für die Heizung.
Die kennt ihr ja schon.
Das ist übrigens das ganz neue Grafana.
Gestern als geupdatet 7.1 noch was.
Ähm...
So, dann habe ich nämlich noch den Plattenplatz von...
Für die Fernsehaufnahmen im Wohnzimmer.
Der aus irgendwelchen Gründen hier meint, dass es...
Irgendeinen Alarm gegeben hat.
Okay, was auch immer.
Was eigentlich Blödsinn ist, ich habe gestern an dem Alarm rumgespielt.
Wahrscheinlich deshalb.
Aber was ich gestern gemacht habe...
Ist, ich habe alle meine Domains...
Also...
Also alle meine...
Äh, nicht Domains.
Alle meine SSL-Zertifikate mal reingemacht mit Ablaufdatum.
Dass ich nicht übersehe, sollte irgendeine Zertifikatverlängerung nicht funktionieren.
Also sprich, das sind alle Zertifikate, die ich ausgestellt habe hier unten.
Ist das easy?
Das ist ziemlich easy mit Grafana, ja.
Und guck, hier neben sieht man, wie lange die Zertifikate noch gültig sind.
Also sprich...
Am...
Die meisten...
Die meisten laufen noch über 50 Tage.
Und das ist tatsächlich ziemlich easy, so was zu machen in Grafana.
Du brauchst erstmal einen...
Also du brauchst erstmal einen Prometheus-Exporter, der das macht.
Das kann man aber auto-discoveren lassen.
Macht das nicht Sinn?
Doch, das könnte man auch machen.
Ja, wobei...
Ne, wenn du das hier meinst, also das auf 0, dann ist das zu...
Zu klein, dann siehst du ja die Änderungen kaum noch.
Ja, also ich lasse das auto-discovern.
Und dann brauchst du eigentlich nur eine Sache einzubinden.
Ich bin jetzt hier leider nicht eingeloggt, deswegen kann ich das nicht zeigen.
Das ist ein Befehl, den man hier eingeben muss.
Ich habe gesagt, wenn du noch 5 Tage übrig bist, dann soll er mir eine Nachricht schicken.
Ja, PC lustig, kann man machen.
Ja, du musst dafür sorgen, dass dein Prometheus das Auto-discovert, was du für Host hast.
Das können wir vielleicht mal im Stream machen.
Also wenn man...
Wenn du jetzt so Enterprise-Business-Geschichten laufst, dann...
Wie jetzt irgendwie einen Docker-Swarm oder einen Kubernetes oder irgendwie Konsul und noch was.
Also in größeren Container-Deployments ist es kein Ding.
Dann hat man ja schon so einen zentralen Store, wo drinnen steht, was man für Server, Container, was auch immer laufen hat.
Dann kann das Prometheus discovern daraus.
Wenn man das nicht hat, was ich im Heimbereich nicht habe, entweder macht man das selbst.
Ich mache das über DNS.
Ich mache das über DNS aktuell.
Ich habe zwei Zeilen...
Ich habe einen Bash, nennen wir es mal programmiert, die eine Datei erstellen, die Prometheus einliest.
Ich mache einfach einen Dig auf meinen DNS für die eine IP, Reverse-Lookup für die eine IP, Reverse-Lookup für die andere IP,
weil ich habe ja bloß zwei Hosts, wo intern wirklich großartig was läuft.
Ich habe hier einmal die Intel-Low-Power-Kiste, wo Heimautomatisierung und sonst was draufläuft
und ich habe den einen Raspberry Pi im WLAN, wo Unify und sonst wie Kram drauf.
Ich mache einfach einen DNS-Reverse-Lookup, der spuckt mir dann alle Host-Names aus
und das schreibe ich in eine Datei, die Prometheus einliest.
Das sind wie gesagt zwei Zeilen Bash und das lässt du einfach alle fünf Minuten laufen
oder kannst du auch alle zehn Sekunden laufen lassen.
DNS-Abfragen kosten ja nicht viel.
Und sobald du einen neuen Server in deinen DNS einträgst, was du ja eh machen musst, wenn du ihn intern auflösen möchtest,
sobald du einen neuen Server in deinen DNS einträgst, dann ist der automatisch da mit drin.
Also ich kann es dir zeigen, wenn du willst, wie das aussieht.
Hier stehen keine Systeme fest drin.
Jetzt war eigentlich das Aufwachen ein Stream, aber das zeige ich dir trotzdem noch kurz.
Ja, Blackbox.
Muss mich mal einloggen.
Und mal Admin.
Dann habe ich das...
Ah, excellent.
So, Edit.
Das ist alles, was man abfragen muss.
Also sprich...
Es kommen automatisch alle Hosts rein, die diese Sache hier exportieren.
Beziehungsweise alle Hosts, die automatisch abgefragt werden.
Also du siehst hier nirgendwo explizit ein Host drin stehen.
Und er zieht die aktuelle Zeit davon ab, dass es immer aktuell ist.
Das ist alles.
Das ist der normale Blackbox-Exporter.
Du sorgst einfach dafür, dass der überall Zertifikatinfos abgreift.
Also wenn ich jetzt...
Wenn ich jetzt...
Neues System in DNS eintrage, ist es dann nach ein paar Minuten da.
Ich kann es dir jetzt nicht zeigen, weil das neue System muss auf HTTPS...
Also muss antworten auf...
Weil...
Also...
Das kann...
Das erscheint nicht da drinne, wenn dort kein Webserver läuft.
Also der muss einmal initial gültiges Zertifikat abgefragt haben.
Ist ja logisch.
Greifst du die Heizungsdaten vom E-Bus ab?
Nein.
Ich greife die Heizungsdaten mit einem...
Damit ab.
Mit so einem Kabel greife ich das ab.
Jede Heizung hat vorne so ein Ding.
Da kann man so ein Kabel reinstecken.
Genauso sieht das bei mir im Keller auch aus.
Und...
Und dann machst du das dran.
Auf die andere Seite kommt ein Raspberry Pi dran.
Und dann musst du ein bisschen Magic machen.
Dann brauchst du das hier.
Was die Wiesmann-USB-Geschichten versteht.
So, und damit kannst du die Sachen auslesen.
Das ist nicht so schwierig.
Die haben auch ein gutes Wiki, wo sie erklären, wie es funktioniert.
Das Projekt ist auch aktiv.
Das ist nicht enttaint.
Musst du dir angucken.
So, und dann habe ich noch was drumherum programmiert,
was das Ganze als Prometheus-Metrik exportiert,
damit es Grafana einlesen kann.
Moin, Michael Pfufdspilian.
Exquisite kalte Pizza morgens um 9.40 Uhr.
Excellent.
So, also, gucken wir uns mal was an.
Was schauen wir uns denn an?
Wir gucken uns erstmal Schlösseraufmach-Stream an.
So, ich guck mal schnell.
Habe ich irgendwas vergessen hier im Chat?
Max, ich habe am Freitag...
Ich habe am Freitag das Geilste meines Lebens erlebt.
Bei uns in der IT-Security-Abteilung, da ruft ein Supporter mich an,
intern, und sagt, XY-Kunde will ein Raspberry Pi 4-Bär bauen,
um ihn als USB-Stick zu nutzen.
Geht das?
Ja, das geht, aber warum?
Also, du kannst...
Ich glaube, der Raspberry Pi kann sich als Storage-Device melden über USB.
Das geht.
Aber warum?
Das ist ja dann nur ein Oversized-Micro-SD-zu-USB-Adapter.
Wo ist denn der Sinn?
Den Sinn verstehe ich auch nicht.
Nee.
Hast du deine Monitore nahtlos aneinander, oder ich habe die direkt nebeneinander stehen?
Also, das ergibt für mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch wenig Sinn.
Also, ich muss sagen, mein Lieblingsanruf, den ich jemals bekommen habe,
auf der Arbeit, war eine, die gesagt hat, ihr System geht nicht mehr.
Wobei, stimmt gar nicht.
War gar kein Anruf.
Das hatte ich E-Mail geschrieben.
Ihr System geht nicht mehr.
Und die ist lustigerweise bei mir rausgekommen.
Also, ich habe damit eigentlich gar nichts zu tun, so supportmäßig, wenn ein System nicht geht.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist die Mail bei uns im Gruppenpostfach aufgeschlagen.
Und ich habe mich dazu herabgelassen, mal zu sagen, ja, ich kümmere mich drum.
Und habe ihr dann geantwortet und habe gefragt, ja, von welchem System spricht sie denn?
Weil die auch von irgendeiner Klinik oder so geschrieben hat, wo ich gar keine Ahnung habe.
Was will die eigentlich von mir?
Ja, also, ich wüsste nicht, dass wir Support für Krankenhäuser machen oder so.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, ja, okay, wer genau ist sie denn?
Von wo und um welches System geht es genau?
Und sie hat halt darauf geantwortet, es geht um das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Ausrufezeichen.
Und da wusste ich natürlich Bescheid.
Ich hatte danach genauso wenig Ahnung wie vorher, was die eigentlich will.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt mal an?
Das System.
Das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten.
Warte, woher soll ich das wissen?
Weißt du, das ist so geil.
Auf die Frage, ja, um was geht's?
Übrigens, da gucken wir uns das passende Video zu an.
Das war echt ganz lustig.
Ich habe schon mal angefangen zu gucken.
Moment, wo ist es denn?
Ja, das da.
Das ist echt ganz witzig.
Mal gucken, ob es laut genug ist.
Alex, hey, das Ding ist kaputt.
Es macht nicht die Sache.
Ich denke, es hat einen Glitsch.
Weißt du, weil normalerweise...
Wie man Programmierer ärgern kann.
Und da ist wirklich was Wahres dran.
Alex, hey, das Ding ist kaputt.
Es macht nicht die Sache.
Ich denke, es hat einen Glitsch.
Weißt du, weil normalerweise klicke ich auf das Button,
und dann schreibe ich in den Text,
und dann macht das andere Ding das Ding,
und es macht nicht die Sache, die die Sache machen sollte.
Weißt du?
Hier, schau.
Schau.
Das Ding.
Nein, das...
Das geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Das kennt, glaube ich, jeder.
Also, das Erste wird man wahrscheinlich eher kennen,
wenn man im Support arbeitet.
Oder, na, wobei.
Wobei, also, bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es auch öfter so,
dass irgendwie einer ankommt, so nach dem Motto,
und, was macht die Kiste?
Ja, welche Kiste?
Äh, ja, die Kiste, die irgendwelche, sagen wir mal, PDFs generiert.
Ja, und die PDFs sehen heute anders aus.
Ja, was weiß ich, was habe ich mit der PDF-Generierung zu tun?
Ja, ihr macht das doch.
Ja, sowas haben wir auch.
Aber das geht mir auch auf den Keks.
Na, da kommt dann irgendwie einer an und sagt,
ja, also, wir bräuchten jetzt mal irgendwie eine neue Metrik für...
Keine Ahnung, jetzt bräuchte ich mal irgendwas Abgedrehtes.
Wir bräuchten in unserem Monitoring eine neue Metrik für...
Genau, die fangen meistens an.
Also, wir bräuchten eine neue Metrik und...
Wir bräuchten ganz simpel mal eine neue Metrik in unserem Monitoring,
und zwar für...
Jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen was Komplizierteres,
muss ich mir jetzt mal ausdenken.
Für BIOS-Version.
Zum Beispiel für Server-BIOS-Version.
Wir möchten unbedingt Server-BIOS-Version in unserem Monitoring drin haben.
Das kann ja nicht so schwierig sein.
Mach das mal schnell für uns.
Oder dann sagst du, Moment mal, also,
du kommst nicht so einfach an die BIOS-Version von dem System dran,
um das zu exportieren.
Das ist euch schon klar, oder?
Ich finde es immer geil, wenn die...
Also, das machen viele Leute.
Die tun so, als ist das total einfach.
Sondern ich meine, es kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Du musst doch nur an dieser einen Stelle da drücken und das machen und jenes machen.
Und guck mal, das ist doch nur...
Das ist doch nur eine neue Metrik.
Das kann doch gar nicht so schwierig sein.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also, Support.
Ich würde nie freiwillig im Support arbeiten.
Ja, hier.
Genau das hatte ich auch.
Moment, wo ist der Chat?
Oh, nee, hab ich den Chat zugemacht.
Kacknub, warum hab ich den Chat zugemacht?
Ich muss den Chat auflassen.
Netzmuffel schreibt, er kennt auch sowas.
Also, was ich auch immer geil finde, ist...
Also, ich hab's ja letztens auf Twitter geschrieben schon.
Wenn die...
Ich überleg grad, was ich da für ein Beispiel auf Twitter genommen hab.
Genau.
Letztens ruft jemand an, so sinngemäß.
Ich krieg's gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen.
Irgendwas mit Host-Skripte.
Und dann hat er gesagt, die Host-Skripte...
Genau, hier, das da.
So sinngemäß.
Hallo, sind Sie...
Hat mich jemand angerufen?
Ob ich zuständig bin für irgendwelche Host-Skripte?
Ich mein, Host-Skripte.
Das ist so...
Das ist...
Ein Schritt weiter wie Skripte.
Oder sind Sie für etwas zuständig?
Fragezeichen.
Also, das ist so absolut nichts sagen.
Also, es gibt, glaub ich, kaum...
Zwei Wörter, die so in der IT so mehr allgemeingültig generic sind wie Host und Skript.
Und das in Kombination sagt überhaupt nichts aus.
Sind Sie zuständig für Host-Skripte?
Da hab ich dann gefragt, ja, welche...
Was meint er denn für Skripte?
Welche Hosts?
Und da gibt's ja tausend Möglichkeiten.
Und da war seine Antwort, ja, ich mein die Skripte, um die Sie sich kümmern.
Das ist immer...
Da weißt du auch genau Bescheid, ja.
Vor allem sind die bei mir immer...
Die sind bei mir eigentlich zu 90% falsch mit irgendwelchen Support-Sachen.
Außer, es ist wirklich was, womit ich mich drum kümmere.
Und sie haben sich schon um drei Ecken lang gefragt, ja.
Und dann, was mich dann immer noch übelst triggert ist,
wenn dann einer ankommt und meint,
ähm, ja, wir bräuchten hier noch ein weiteres Skript,
ähm, bis zur, bis zur, bis zur Statusrunde.
Ja, wann ist die Statusrunde?
Ja, in einer halben Stunde.
Dann okay.
Also sprich, ihr wollt irgendwas haben bis in einer halben Stunde,
wo ihr mir noch nicht mal sagen könnt, was und wo ihr eigentlich haben wollt.
Ja, genau.
Alles klar.
So, jetzt muss ich erst hier nochmal fertig ankommen.
Ja, also das geht mir auch auf den Keks, wenn die Leute immer sagen,
ah, das ist doch total einfach.
So, I was thinking today, we should just rebuild the entire checking app.
Maybe while we're at it, we can redo it in the Android version.
Just add in some code, some X's and O's, some 1's and 2's, 0's and 1's,
some ABC's, some 1, 2, 3's.
That should be easy, right?
Ähm, oh, die gibt's natürlich auch, ja.
Das gibt Leute, die möchten immer super, super clever klingen.
Das gibt's aber auch nicht nur in der Technik.
Das gibt's nicht nur in der Technik.
Wollte ich jetzt mal was aus, äh, aus, aus, aus, äh,
so meinem eigenen Leben erzählen, wo es jemand gibt,
der das auch gerne macht.
Mein Vater macht das nämlich gerne.
Ähm, also ich hab nicht so wahnsinnig viel Kontakt mit meinem Vater.
Aber, äh, also in letzter Zeit nicht mehr so viel.
Da bin ich ehrlich gesagt auch ganz froh drum.
Aber, äh, unabhängig davon, hat, hat jetzt, äh,
hat jetzt hier mit nichts zu tun.
Der macht das auch extrem gerne.
Der sucht sich immer Themen raus
und tut dann so, als kennt er sich aus.
So.
Und ich weiß, es klingt jetzt erstmal abgedreht,
aber ihr kennt, ihr kennt den nicht.
Aber, der war mal der Meinung,
er, äh, versucht sich jetzt als Holzverkäufer.
Der wollte, wollte mal Holz verkaufen.
So einfach random.
Dem ist einfach, dem ist von heute,
das hat er gerne gemacht, so Dinger.
Dem ist von heute, dem ist von heute auf morgen eingefallen,
ich werde jetzt irgendwie, ich verkaufe jetzt Holz.
So richtig echtes Holz, ja.
Und er hatte natürlich keine Ahnung von,
aber, was er sieht, dann, dann geht er ins Internet
und sucht ein bisschen danach.
Und das Erste, was ihm aufgefallen ist, ist,
dass man Holz irgendwie in Raummeter misst.
Und ihr glaubt das nicht,
der hat mich die nächsten zwei,
drei Monate war jegliche Einheit,
in die was umgerechnet wurde, war Raummeter.
Der hat alles in Raummeter Holz umgerechnet.
Und, äh, einzig und allein nur,
weil das, äh, wichtig, weil das, weil das,
mehr klingt, als hätte er Ahnung vom Holzverkaufen,
als er eigentlich hat.
Er hatte keine, er hat, also,
er hat generell absolut keine Ahnung von Holz
und Holzverkaufen und, und,
und Holz und Forstwirtschaft, also, null.
Gar nicht.
Das ist überhaupt nicht sein Gebiet gewesen.
Ja, gar, absolut nichts.
Und, ähm,
und dann hat er immer,
er hat immer erzählt, nach dem Motto,
ja, das sind, ja, jetzt sagen Sie mal,
wie viel Raummeter ist das hier und Raummeter da
und Schüttmeter hier und, und, und sonst wie
und Raummeter da.
Und da hat er halt versucht, so wirkt es so zu klingen,
als kennt er sich aus.
Also, so Leute kenne ich auch.
Genug.
Alex.
Hey, I was curious about that new bug we're gonna fix.
Do you think maybe we could refresh our browser?
Have you tried changing out the flux capacitor on it?
Run the new SMTP settings we have.
Have you tried using MS-DOS?
When was the last time you ran a curl?
Have you tried IoT, the Internet of Things?
What about artificial intelligence?
Do you try jailbreaking your computer?
Have you tried USB Type-D?
Is this your monitor?
Das ist auch was, was mir bei Leuten extrem auf den Sack geht hier.
Wartet mal.
Hier.
Die erstens Abkürzungen verwenden.
IoT, the Internet of Things.
Das, oh, die Leute regen mich auf.
Die Abkürzungen verwenden, von denen sie keine Ahnung haben
und dann meinen, sie sind so schlau,
dass sie dir die Abkürzungen nochmal erklären müssen.
Das ist auch immer richtig ätzend.
Im Gegensatz dazu hast du irgendwelche Stonksleute,
die den ganzen Tag mit irgendwelchen Stonksbegriffen um sich werfen
und davon ausgehen, selbstverständlich, dass es jeder kennt.
What about artificial intelligence?
Do you try jailbreaking your computer?
Have you tried USB Type-D?
Is your monitor in 4K or 1080p?
Have you tried typing in command in a terminal?
What about big data?
What about advanced machine learning?
Yeah, I've never heard of that database.
We can totally integrate with that.
Das ist auch geil, ja.
We can probably get it done tomorrow, maybe the next day.
Can we get the latest?
Yeah, no problem at all.
We'll get them rolling on right away.
Hier, wir haben ein Ticketsystem und brauchen einen MP3-Player da drin.
Ja, klar, gar kein Problem, machen wir sofort.
Oh ja, die Leute gibt's auch.
Moment, hier ist der Typ Eierkopf gerade, der ihm was schickt?
Hier ist der Eierkopf?
Warte mal.
Moment, Moment, Moment, wo ist der Typ, der Nachrichten schickt?
Ach, Erik Knopf, nicht Eierkopf.
Ich habe Eierkopf gelistet.
Ja, so Leute hast du leider wirklich.
Die dir alle 50...
Hey, I sent you a message, did you get it yet?
Ja, so Leute hast du echt...
Ey, alles ASAP, alles ASAP.
Man muss übrigens mal, wenn man das wörtlich nimmt,
die meisten Leute, die meisten Leute verwenden ASAP nicht für das, was es heißt,
nämlich sobald es geht.
Sobald es geht.
Sondern für sofort.
Kennt ihr das auch?
So Leute, die sagen, oh, wir müssten das und das jetzt machen.
Aber ASAP.
So nach dem Motto, von der Betonung und von dem Kontext bedeutet das,
wie die das sagen, aber sofort.
Allerdings bedeutet ASAP gar nicht sofort.
Hey, I got this super quick, super fast fix that needs to get done like ASAP.
Ah, genau.
As soon as possible.
Hey, you're a hard guy to track down.
But I see you got here fast.
Allright, there, could you just type me out a couple quick lines of code?
Oh, whoa, hey man, I know you're about to leave for the weekend,
but I just got like three bugs that could be fixed real quickly,
make my world so much easier.
Think about it, no traffic at seven, I'll buy dinner.
So Tüben hast du wirklich manchmal.
Also das kann jetzt, wenn man im Homeoffice ist, nicht mehr wirklich passieren.
Aber ich hatte schon ab und zu mal Leute, wenn ich runtergefahren bin mit dem Fahrstuhl,
die gesagt haben, ich fahr mal kurz mit und dann wollten die noch irgendwas.
Who's my favorite developer?
Come on, let's go.
No, you're Peter.
Das ist eigentlich die beste Antwort.
Das müsste man eigentlich wirklich immer sagen.
Wenn jemand zu einem sagt ASAP, dann muss man sagen,
ja, das mache ich eigentlich immer so.
Also ich mache das immer so schnell, wie ich kann.
Was soll er dann sagen?
Dann muss er nämlich im Zweifelsfall wirklich sagen,
ach nee, nee, ich meine ja eigentlich jetzt sofort.
Und wenn dann einer zu dir sagt, so jetzt sofort,
dann kannst du sagen, ja, Moment, da muss erst mal mein Chef fragen,
weil da muss ich ja andere Sachen für liegen.
Das ist so ein Ding, was man glücklicherweise,
wenn man in ein bisschen größeren Laden arbeitet,
immer gut machen kann.
Wenn irgendwie einer zu euch kommt und sagt,
ihr sollt was machen, auf was ihr jetzt absolut wirklich gar keinen Bock habt,
dann könnt ihr immer sagen, oh nee, ist jetzt gerade schlecht,
ich habe da gerade so viele andere Sachen zu tun.
Geh mal zu meinem Chef und frag den, ob der der Sache irgendwie Priorität gibt.
Das macht keiner, niemand.
Also vielleicht ein Prozent der Sachen, die wirklich wichtig sind,
gehen wirklich zu deinem Chef.
Und fragen.
Also wenn dir jemand loswerden will,
musst du einfach nur sagen, ja, also priorisierungsmäßig geht das gerade nicht.
Geh mal zu meinem Chef und frag, ob ich das machen darf jetzt.
Das machen 1 bis 5 Prozent, wenn es hochkommt, der Leute.
Dann ist man, die meiste Sachen, ist man los.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier zu bieten?
Windows-Fan-Teste-Linux-Laptop.
Ach nee, das gucken wir uns irgendwann später an.
Das stimmt tatsächlich, ja.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal ein Schloss, den gucke ich immer gerne an.
Ups.
Äh, nein.
Ich kenne keinen Pineapple.
Ich kenne Pineapple-Pizza.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
... in der gleichen taiwanischen Fabrik,
die Loks für mindestens eine halbe Dutzend verschiedene Pizzen macht.
Das ist nichts, was generell ist.
Wir haben ein Sliding-Bolt-Design mit einem 90 Millimeter breiten,
hartesten Loks-Body und einem gut beschützten 11 Millimeter-Molybdenum-Alloyshackle.
Aber was dieses Lock apart setzt, ist das Core.
Es ist ein Dimple-Design mit vier Pin-in-Pin-Körnern
und einem Pin, der nur mit einem Magneten gesetzt werden kann,
wie das kleine, das du hier auf der Kante siehst.
Es ist ein Core, das nur ein sehr kleines Grupp,
ein sehr gekennzeichnetes und wissenschaftliches Picker,
... und ein sehr kleines, das nur mit einem kleinen,
... aber das nur ein sehr kleines, das nur ein sehr kleines,
... obwohl es nicht so klein ist, was ich das wirklich mag.
Also, schauen wir mal, was es kostet, um das zu öffnen,
und dann werde ich es apart nehmen, um dir zu zeigen,
... was das neue Lock ist.
Bevor wir anfangen, setze ich ein kleines Magnet von meiner Verpackung,
... für Locks wie dieses.
Du wirst sehen, wie ich das in einem Moment benutze.
Wir werden...
Es ist gar nicht, dass es so Mini-Magnete gibt.
... eine Z-Bar als Wendepad nutzen,
... um zu schieben,
Das erinnert mich irgendwie so ein bisschen an Zahnarzt, immer wenn er mit diesem Zeugs da anrückt.
Ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt, wie einfach die meisten...
Gut, wahrscheinlich zeigt er auch nur Sachen, die er einfach aufkriegt.
Aber der Rest wird noch ein bisschen komplizierter, weil das Video ist acht Minuten.
Sebaro geht mir auch so.
Ich weiß gar nicht, in welche Richtung ich überhaupt drehen muss.
Also wenn ich den Magneter reinmachen würde,
ich würde den irgendwo hinschieben wahrscheinlich und nie wieder rausbekommen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Easy.
Aber schon heftig, oder?
Wie easy der das aufmacht.
Der hat halt auch Übung, der Kerl.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwie der 0815-Random-Dude mit dem passenden Werkzeug das irgendwie in zwei Minuten aufkriegt.
Aber es ist trotzdem heftig, wie easy das bei dem ausschaut.
Hä?
Jawohl.
Doesn't seem to be coming out easily.
Let's give it a little bit of a tap with the mallet.
Jawohl, gib's ihm.
There we go.
S-Clap.
Now we should be able to remove the security cover and the core.
To take the core apart, we have two screws on the back.
Wenn mir einer sowas zeigen würde, ne?
Ich wüsste nicht mal, zu was für einem Gerät das überhaupt gehört.
Also ich würde im Leben nicht erkennen, dass das irgendwie der Zylinder von einem Schloss ist.
Also wenn mir das irgendwie einer von den Amis zeigt, würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, das ist irgendwie eine Schrotpatrone oder so.
All we should need to finish taking this apart is the key and a follower.
You can see our four pin-in-pin chambers and then up front is the magnetic pin.
You'll see if I pull the key out just a little bit.
That magnetic pin will pop up.
It's made out of steel, so a magnet will pull it.
Back down.
Okay, let's drop everything out here, including this little slug of steel down in the bottom of the keyway.
I'm not entirely sure what that's for.
Okay, we dropped the magnetic pin out.
Kriegt ihr die Sachen danach auch wieder zusammen?
...pin out.
Weil ich habe teilweise schon Probleme, wenn ich eine Steckdose mit fünf Teilen auseinander baue,
dass die danach wieder an die richtigen Stellen hinkommen.
Chamber one.
I'm sorry, two.
Let's separate the inner and outer pins now.
Now let's get the driver pins.
There shouldn't be anything on slot one.
Oh, I see what we have.
There's just...
This is not really a driver pin.
It's just something with a hole on it into which that magnetic pin will fit.
Ich weiß absolut nicht, wo da was herkommt.
Okay, we have an interesting arrangement for the pin.
It looks like the inner and outer pins...
...have separate springs.
Aber anscheinend ist das ein Thema, wofür sich viele Hackermans interessieren.
Weil ich habe beim letzten CCC, habe ich auch einen Vortrag oder mehrere sogar Vorträge gesehen,
irgendwie was über Schlösserknacken und Alarmanlagen ausmachen und so.
Scheint so Hexor-Hobby zu sein.
Das geht ja schon fast als ASMR-Video durch hier.
Okay, so spannend finde ich es jetzt.
Ehrlich gesagt nicht, was da alles drin ist, weil ich checke eh nicht, was was macht.
Also, nicht übel.
Also, das ist echt heftig.
Also, wie easy der das aufgekriegt hat am Anfang.
Mal kurz nochmal husten.
Hey, so.
So was dringe.
Excellent.
Krieg Corona.
Habe ich euch erzählt, dass wir auf der Arbeit den ersten Corona-Fall haben?
Aber was mir egal ist, also für mich persönlich,
weil ich mache ja schon Homeoffice.
Seit einer Weile.
Also, ich kann es nicht haben.
Also, nicht von ihm zumindest.
Was? Next Level GitHub Profil Readme?
Hä? What?
Hier. Ach so.
Okay, was ist die Next Level?
Was ist denn das?
Äh, es ist Markdown.
Okay, er hat eine Next Level GitHub Readme.
Excellent.
Der braucht es, also ganz ehrlich, der braucht länger für die Readme,
wie ich wahrscheinlich für die ersten Videos.
Das ist die erste Test-Version von irgendeiner Software.
Kann man mal machen, ja.
Wenn man sich denkt, ah, ja, ich habe eigentlich gar kein Projekt heute,
keinen Bock an dem Projekt weiterzuarbeiten,
dann machen wir einfach die Readme schön.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Also, Windows Fanate, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
How does Microsoft make money?
Mit Azure.
Also, ich würde mal sagen, Microsoft macht das meiste Geld nach wie vor mit Azure.
Also, mit Azure, mit, ähm,
irgendwelchem Office-Transfer,
mit Microsoft 365 gedöhnt, das ist ja mehr oder weniger Azure.
Mit was macht Microsoft noch Geld?
Also, mit Windows eher weniger.
Vielleicht noch mit irgendwelchen,
wobei, ne, mit Hardware-Verkäufen kann Microsoft auch Geld machen.
Was macht Microsoft eigentlich Geld?
Mir fällt ja jetzt nur Azure,
Azure GitHub wird jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel bringen.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ja, Office und Azure ist ja mehr oder weniger.
Außerdem heißt es jetzt ja sogar Microsoft-Rad 65, ja.
Mit der neuen Xbox machen die auch gerade noch nicht allzu viel Geld.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt legit keine Ahnung, mit was Microsoft Geld verdient, außer Azure.
Und mit Sicherheit auch so Sachen wie Server-Betriebssystem, SQL-Geschichten und sowas.
Aber ich glaube, das ist gegen Azure wahrscheinlich alles kleiner, kleiner Anteil, ja.
Ne, ne, Xbox bringt nicht so viel Geld.
Also, die, die letzte war nicht so wahnsinnig erfolgreich.
Aber es ist ja eh so, dass er gerade, gerade am Anfang,
wenn Konsolen neu sind, dass da die Hersteller immer gerne ein bisschen drauflegen,
um ihre Plattform mehr zu verbreiten.
Was sagst du zu Office?
Äh, nein, das heißt nicht mehr Office 365, das heißt Microsoft 365
und läuft alles bei, in, in Azure, Azure.
Das ist mehr oder weniger das Gleiche, wo das drauf läuft.
Also, das ist, äh, wird halt nur als Office vermarktet,
aber die Infrastruktur drunter ist das, was man sich auch in Azure mieten kann.
Okay, das kommen wir uns mal an.
Was haben wir uns mal an?
Die besten, die fünf besten Windows-10-Apps.
Okay, das ist wieder was, wo ich, wo ich, wo ich schön drüber ablästern kann.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt schnell angucken.
In der Taskleiste kann man die Lautstärke laut...
Der hat sich immer so ultraglücklich an, der Sprecher.
...lauter und leiser stellen.
Es erfüllt zwar seinen Zweck, doch wie es potenziell aussehen könnte,
zeigt die App Ear Trumpet sehr eindrucksvoll.
Ja, die ist wirklich gut.
Ey, die, die ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Sie kombiniert den...
Die einzige App, die ich kenne, die ich mir überhaupt aus, ähm, äh, Windows-Docker,
aus Store installieren würde.
...einfachen Lautstärkeregler, klug mit einem zusätzlichen Mixer.
Ja, die, die ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Also, das kann man wirklich, äh, empfehlen, die App.
...lautstärke einzelner Apps nachjustieren,
falls ein Programm wieder mal lauter als der Sprachchat ist.
Möchte man eine App zurücksetzen, setzt man sie auf 100 Prozent.
So einfach ist das.
Keine Fummelarbeit, anders als...
Aber ich, aber ich hab's, ich hab's, äh, trotzdem nicht installiert,
weil, äh, man kann ja auch hier drüber gehen.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, du hast hier ein paar andere Funktionen,
sodass er sich die letzte Einstellung merkt und sowas.
Aber mir reicht der Mixer hier.
...am integrierten Lautstärkeremixer.
Ich kann einfach nicht akzeptieren, dass eine App 1 Prozent leiser als der Rest ist.
Ansonsten möchte ich noch erwähnen, dass man mit einem einfachen Rechtsklick
eine spezifische App auf ein anderes Wiedergabelgerät legen kann.
Cool ist auch...
Oh, das ist gut.
...dass sie mit dem Maus...
Das ist gut.
...Ausrat direkt auf das Icon drehen lässt im Trail, um die Lautstärke zu regulieren.
Das spart dann im Alltag nochmal einen Klick.
Die zweite App, die ich euch heute vorstelle, ist...
...der Microsoft Store.
Ach nee, so eine Kacke, ey.
Da haben die sich so verrannt drin in dem komischen Microsoft Store.
Niemand...
Nicht mal Microsoft selbst verwendet den Microsoft Store.
Weder Visual Studio noch Visual Studio Code noch...
Was gibt's denn sonst noch von Microsoft?
Weder noch der neue Edge noch sonst was.
Nichts kommt über den Microsoft Store und sogar die offiziellen Sachen von Microsoft nicht.
Treesize in der völligen...
Ich glaub, das neue Windows-Terminal gibt's über...
...über den Store, hä?
...ausreichenden Gratis-Version.
Treesize hilft euch beim Ausfindig-Machen von Speicherfressern,
indem es einzelne Verzeichnisse oder ganze Laufwerke analysiert.
Moment, das kenn ich.
Hieß das nicht...
...anders als im Windows...
...hieß das nicht Win...
...Win...
...Deer...
...Stat oder so früher?
Explorer lassen sich die Ordner dann nach der Größe sortieren und...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Win, Deer, Stat gab's doch sonst immer.
Ja, das da mein ich.
Das...
Das hab ich früher unter Windows immer verwendet, um zu gucken, wo was ist.
Okay, aber mein, das geht auch.
Das sieht eh relativ ähnlich aus.
Treesize sieht ein bisschen moderner aus, ja.
Falls ihr also etwas Speicher auf eurem Computer freiräumen möchtet,
seien es Spiele, vergessene Videos oder auch temporäre Dateien,
dann ist Treesize genau das Richtige für euch.
Quick Look!
Klingt nicht nur so wie ein MacOS-Feature,
es ist tatsächlich eine Kopie einer beliebten Funktion aus Apples Betriebssystem.
Wie der Name schon sagt, können wir schnell einen Blick in Dokumente werfen,
ohne das damit verknüpfte Programm starten zu müssen.
Oh, ne, Brauschnitt.
Da kannst du einfach im Windows Explorer irgendeine Datei markieren
und dann auf die Leertaste eurer Tastatur drücken.
Ich mein, gerade, also das ist auch so ein Feature, was irgendwie, also ich kenn das aus Mac,
das MacOS.
Ich benutze zwar nicht aktiv MacOS, aber gesehen habe ich schon,
wo ich so genau nicht verstehe, warum es da ist.
Vielleicht merkt man das erst, wenn man das öfters verwendet.
Aber habe ich nicht genau extra Programme für bestimmte Dateitypen installiert,
weil ich sie darin öffnen möchte?
Also zum Beispiel habe ich doch einen PDF-Reader installiert,
damit ich PDFs darin öffne.
Wo ist denn der Sinn, wenn ich PDFs
in einem Vorschau-Programm öffne, um sie dann im PDF-Reader zu öffnen?
Also, wisst ihr, bei manchen Sachen, so genau verstehe ich den Sinn nicht.
... und dann auf die Leertaste eurer Tastatur drücken.
Es ist einfach und schnell.
Und es werden wirklich sehr viele Dateitypen unterstützt,
seien es Office-Dokumente, Videos, Bilder oder PDFs.
Eine Frage, die sich viele von euch bestimmt schon gestellt hat,
wieso kann man eigentlich nicht die Helligkeit seines Monitors mit Windows steuern?
Kann man!
Ja, ich frage mich vieles, warum man das unter Windows nicht machen kann.
... der App Twinkle Tray.
Nach der Installation aus dem Microsoft Store erscheint die App, ähnlich wie ihr Trumpet,
im Tray-Bereich der Taskleiste.
Also ich meine, über die Grafikkartensettings kann man das machen, ne?
Wenn man auf das Icon klickt, kann man ganz einfach per Schieberegler
die Helligkeit aller angeschlossenen Monitore einzeln
als Gesamtes regulieren.
Weitere coole Funktionen verbergen sich in den Einstellungen.
War nicht so schlecht.
Dort kann man einzelne Monitore benennen,
iBurner ist ein guter Name,
Hotkeys festlegen und auch die Anpassung der Helligkeit nach Uhrzeit automatisieren.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ein Beispiel hierfür wäre die Reduzierung der Helligkeit von 70 auf 40% um 19 Uhr.
Doch aufgepasst, nicht wieder monitoren.
Strom spart man dadurch definitiv nicht.
Vielleicht spart man dadurch Strom, wenn man einen Monitor hat mit dimmbarer Hintergrundbeleuchtung.
Dann vielleicht, aber normalerweise nicht.
...verbergen sich in den Einstellungen und kein lebender Zombie ist, sollte es eigentlich klappen.
Also einfach herunterladen und ausprobieren.
Wenn es nicht läuft, kann man sie sauber deinstallieren.
Der krönende Abschluss unseres Videos stellt einen würdigen Ersatz für das alte eingestaubte Notepad dar.
Einfach Visual Studio Code installieren und gut ist.
Welches seit Jahrzehnten in Windows herumgeistert.
Also wenn jetzt nicht Visual Studio Code kommt, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Weil das ist die einfachste Variante, cross-Plattform einen gescheiten Editor zu kriegen, den jeder bedienen kann.
Wenn es nach mir geht, würden wir alle Vim verwenden.
Aber ich bin ja nicht jeder und ich kann es verstehen, warum die meisten Leute lieber Visual Studio Code verwenden.
Ich ja mittlerweile auch.
Einfach weil Visual Studio Code sehr schön erweiterbar ist mit vielen nützlichen Sachen.
Da kann Sublime Text und Notepad++ leider nicht mithalten.
Also gerade wenn man auch was machen möchte, außer ein bisschen Text eintippen, sind gerade die Visual Studio Code Plugins echt Gold wert.
Und das ist das aktivste Editor-Plugin-Ökosystem, was es zurzeit gibt. Für alle Editors.
Also eigentlich kommt man in vielen Bereichen um Visual Studio Code gar nicht mehr rum.
Hängen wir eine S an den Namen, bekommen wir eine schöne und moderne Nummer.
Das ist die moderne Version des Notepads.
Im Endeffekt kann Notepads genau das, was der Editor kann.
Nichts außer unformatierten Text bearbeiten.
Nur, dass es dabei wie ein modernes Windows-Programm aussieht.
Dann doch lieber gleich Visual Studio Code.
Die App wäre natürlich nicht auf dieser Liste, wenn sie nicht noch ein paar Vorzüge besässe.
Mein Lieblings-Feature ist der kompakte Modus, bei dem ein kleines Fenster voll recht und top über alle anderen steht.
Ja gut, also.
Man muss sagen.
Was echt ein bisschen nervig ist an Visual Studio Code.
Was sich aber auch legt, nachdem man es ein paar mal geöffnet hat.
Ist, dass es beim ersten Start ein bisschen dauert.
Ich hatte es noch nicht offen.
Wenn ich jetzt Visual Studio Code aufmache.
Drei, vier, fünf.
Also es dauert schon so fünf Sekunden, bis das dann da ist.
Allerdings, wenn man es ein paar mal öffnet, dann geht es natürlich schneller.
Und man kann irgendwo in Windows, fragt mich nicht wo, kann man irgendwo einstellen,
dass man solche Programme standardmäßig quasi schon preloadet.
Gibt es einen Dark Mode?
Tja, gute Frage.
Keine Ahnung.
Na gut.
Also Notepads.
Die anderen Sachen fand ich tatsächlich gar nicht.
Quick Look brauche ich nicht.
Das mit den Helligkeiten ist ganz nett.
Aber Ear Trumpet ist wirklich gut, wenn man da irgendwie Anwendungszweck für hat.
Das würde ich wirklich installieren.
So.
Das hatten wir schon.
Übrigens, das wollte ich euch mal zeigen.
Das ist mega geil, was der Typ mit seinem Haus gemacht hat.
Ich würde es im Leben nicht machen.
Das Problem ist nur, Musik, Musik im Stream.
Geht nicht.
Ähm, ähm.
Gibt es da irgendwie ein Cover von?
Was ich spielen kann.
Als Alternative.
Irgendein Cover oder so.
Cover.
Zumindest das hier. Ist das ein gutes Cover?
Oh nein, das hört sich ja schlimm an.
Zumindest der Typ hat, äh.
Ich kann das jetzt nicht zeigen.
Das geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Der Typ hat so Lichtershow gemacht an seinem Haus.
Mit der Musik.
Übelst nice.
Ihr wisst ja was.
Guck mal, was auch geil ist.
Wenn der Typ anfängt zu singen.
Kommt sogar so ein Kürbis.
Übelst nice, oder?
Richtig Poggers.
Ich meine, da kriegst du epileptische Anfälle.
Wenn du da vorstehst wahrscheinlich.
Übelst geil.
Die Nachbarn sind wahrscheinlich auch am kotzen.
Das ist doch echt geil gemacht.
Ich meine, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen aufwendig.
Also, guck mal.
Der muss sein komplettes Garagentor mit LED-Strips versorgen.
Der macht sein ganzes Haus mit LED-Strips voll.
Der hat irgendwie irgendwelche LED-Strips.
Ähm, Strahler auf dem Dach, LED-Dinger im Fenster.
Also, das ist schon nicht ohne.
Aber geil gemacht, oder?
Also, ist schon Poggers.
Da kannst du echt nichts sagen.
Schon geil gemacht.
Der hat noch mehr.
Hier, das ist auch geil.
Übelst nice.
Die Arbeit wäre es mir nicht wert.
Außerdem ist der Stromverbrauch gar nicht gut.
Nicht mal ohne.
Also, jetzt nicht auf Dauer betrachtet,
sondern du brauchst ordentliche Netzteile,
dass du diese LED-Strips betreiben kannst.
Also, jetzt mit irgendeinem, äh,
5 Volt Raspberry Pi Netzteil
kommst du da nicht so weit.
Und ich gehe auch nicht davon aus,
dass es 5 Volt LED-Strips sind,
weil 5 Volt LED-Strips über so eine Reichweite
klappt nicht.
Das wären wahrscheinlich, was ist denn das?
Wahrscheinlich 24, was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Ich habe bloß 5 Volt LED-Strips.
Was gibt es denn noch?
12 Volt, 24 Volt LED-Strips?
Zumindest 5 Volt LED-Strips werden es nicht sein,
weil die sind nach ein paar Metern,
funktionieren die LEDs nicht mehr.
Da zu viel Spannungs-Drop über, über.
Wahrscheinlich sind es 12 Volt USB-Strips, ja.
Zumindest ist es geil gemacht.
Und du brauchst ordentliche,
du brauchst ordentliche Netzteile.
Also, ich denke mal nicht,
dass du da mit, wie gesagt, so ein paar
kleinen Steckernetzteilen,
mit so kleinen
Bollern da auskommst.
Da wirst du schon im Keller so
3, 4 fette
1200 Watt Server-Netzteile brauchen
oder irgendwie sowas, wo du dann die 12 Volt
abgreifst. Oder falls es dafür
irgendwie, da gibt es wahrscheinlich schon
fertige Netzteile für. Aber
das braucht schon ein bissl was.
So eine einzelne LED-Lampe
und LEDs brauchen nicht viel, aber in der Summe
ist es schon nicht ohne.
Ich glaube, wenn man sowas in Deutschland macht,
ist das erste, was passiert,
dass die Nachbarn bei der Polizei
anrufen oder sowas.
Mittlerweile wird es ja auch
wieder von,
wie kann man das nennen,
von staatlicher
Stelle angeregt,
seine Mitbewohner
und
Anwohner zu verpetzen,
wenn die irgendwas machen, ja.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt aus dem Fenster
gehen würde und sehe, mein Nachbar
sitzt im Garten mit 10 Leuten
und trinkt einen, dann müsste ich dann
bei der Polizei anrufen, Leute, Leute,
mein Nachbar macht
illegal, illegal Corona-Party
hier, das geht nicht. Kommt mal vorbei hier und
schnappt euch den Sack. Das wird ja
gerade angeregt, also
dass man so Leute wieder verpetzen
soll, was ich auch
nicht gut finde.
Wir hatten das schon in dunkleren
Zeiten in Deutschland,
wo das Verpetzen einer Tagesordnung war und du nicht
mehr sicher sein konntest in deinen eigenen vier Wänden.
Ich finde, das muss nicht unbedingt
wie das sein.
Gerade in der aktuellen Zeit nicht, wo eh schon
jeder jedem irgendwie misstraut.
Da brauchen wir das nicht.
Übrigens, wisst ihr was wieder
geil ist auf Twitter? Twitter ist ja
gerade, ich habe den Fehler gemacht, dass ich
Twitter mal wieder auf Deutschland umgestellt habe.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe Twitter immer
auf Andorra
stehen, dass ich keine Trends aus Deutschland
mitbekriege, weil mir die Trends aus Deutschland und international
meistens so sehr auf den Sack gehen,
weil es immer wieder der gleiche Kram ist und immer wieder das gleiche
dumme Gelaber, was ich mir nicht mehr geben kann.
Andorra hat einfach gar keine Trends.
Und
deswegen ist das nicht so wild.
Da kann man Twitter sich einfach nur angucken,
was getwittert wird
von denen, die man followt
und sieht sonst nichts.
Zumindest, ich habe den Fehler
gemacht und habe Twitter mal wieder auf Deutsch umgestellt.
Mal gucken, wie es heute ist.
Mal gucken, was heute auf Twitter trendet.
Ob immer noch Klopapier trendet.
Da habe ich den Fehler gemacht und habe Twitter
wieder auf Deutsch umgestellt.
Und Trends?
Wo sind die Trends?
Keine.
Es trenden
kein Klopapier mehr.
Zumindest, ich habe Twitter mal wieder
umgestellt auf,
wie sie sich hier drüber aufgeregt haben,
wenn man China tweetet.
Also, ich habe Twitter umgestellt auf,
wo man das eigentlich nicht so gerne
umstellen kann.
Wo man das einstellen kann, hier neben bei den Trends,
wenn du eingeloggt bist.
Oder am einfachsten umstellen kannst du es über
die Smartphone App.
Aber es geht auch hier über den Browser.
Also, ich habe es auf Deutsch umgestellt
und da haben sie sich wieder über Klopapier aufgeregt.
Wie dumm Leute sind die Klopapier
jetzt horten und kaufen und sowas.
Und ich sehe es komplett anders.
Ich habe eh manchmal das Gefühl,
also ich sehe die Sachen nicht anders,
weil ich sie auch im Prinzip anders sehen will.
Aber ich habe oftmals das Gefühl,
wenn ich gerade Twitter Trends lese,
dass ich 90% der Sachen anders sehe,
wie Twitter.
Und ich die meisten Leute auf Twitter
einfach für Low Brain halte.
Irgendwie total hängen geblieben.
Also, zumindest haben sie sich wieder
über Klopapier aufgeregt und dass die Leute
wieder Klopapier kaufen würden.
Und das kein Klopapier mehr da ist.
Und wenn einer geschrieben hat,
er hat Klopapier bekommen,
dann haben die Leute wieder gleich ihn gehatet.
So nach dem Motto, du bist Teil des Problems.
Blablabla.
Übrigens der Beste,
wenn ihr euch mal kaputt lachen wollt,
bei Antworten,
dann müsst ihr mal mein Klopapier,
mein Klopapier-Tweet euch angucken.
Das war auch witzig.
Excellent.
Ich habe ja Klopapier bestellt im Internet.
Vor einer Weile.
Also hier, das ist noch vom April,
da wo das erste Mal so angesagt war.
So.
Und eine Sache.
Also das ist nicht von jetzt.
Das ist ein halbes Jahr her.
Ich habe davon übrigens immer noch welches.
Weil ich habe es jetzt so gemacht.
Ich habe quasi nur zwei, drei davon verwendet.
Und den unteren habe ich zusammengelassen.
Ich habe den ganzen unteren,
die ganzen unteren Pack habe ich noch.
Ich frage mich nicht, 68 Rollen oder 70 Rollen
oder irgendwas das ist.
Was ist denn das hier?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, oder?
Sind das sechs?
Vier, acht, ne?
Acht pro Packung.
Acht, sechzehn, vierundzwanzig,
achtundvierzig,
zweiundsiebzig?
Sind das 72?
Habe ich richtig gerechnet?
Zweiundsiebzig? Zweiundsiebzig Rollen noch?
Kann das sein?
Den unteren Teil habe ich noch.
Sind das 72?
He doesn't know.
He lacks critical information.
Quick maths.
Ich glaube 72 Rollen habe ich noch.
Ich bin schon etwas drüber aufgeregt.
Ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
das war die einzig sinnvolle Entscheidung damals,
zu sagen, hey, ich mache diesen ganzen Wahnsinn
im Laden nicht mit,
aber man möchte ja im gleichen Fall
auch nicht das Risiko eingehen,
kein Klopapier mehr zu haben.
Deswegen, was machen wir?
Das, was im digitalen Entwicklungsland
nun mal nicht so viele Leute kapieren,
ist, man kann die Sachen auch im Internet bestellen.
Also bin ich zu irgendeinem Händler gegangen,
der Klopapier verkauft.
Und?
Und habe einfach mal so eine
halbe Palette bestellt.
Und gut ist.
Du darfst deine Windows-Uhr umstellen.
Ist doch, ist doch schon.
Ist doch schon.
Ach nee, Moment, es ist 10.30 Uhr erst, ne?
Warum macht das Windows nicht automatisch?
He lacks critical information, ja?
Hallo?
Wie stellt man überhaupt die Uhr um?
Wie stellt man überhaupt die Uhrzeit um?
Ich habe das noch nie gemacht.
Jetzt ernsthaft, ich habe das wirklich noch nie gemacht.
Was?
Ich brauche Admin-Rechte.
Ich brauche Admin-Rechte
für...
Na gut.
Ah, jetzt stimmt's.
Excellent.
Gut, aber um zu der eigentlichen Sache mal zu kommen.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bin der Meinung,
das war damals die eigentlich sinnvolle Entscheidung.
Und zumindest jetzt ist es so, dass die Leute,
die...
...pisst sind...
Geil, jetzt ist wieder...
Jetzt ist mein Maus-Freigebe-Ding
abgekackt und ich kann nicht mehr auf den anderen Bildschirm wechseln.
Excellent.
Hallo?
Warum?
Alter, jetzt ist meine Maus-Freigabe
für den zweiten Bildschirm abgeschissen.
Primo, dann danke schön.
Warum ist das so?
Moment, ich starte das mal neu.
Exit.
Geht immer noch nicht. Ah, jetzt geht's wieder.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ja, jetzt geht's wieder.
So, okay, jetzt kann ich zu der eigentlichen Sache zurückkommen,
die ich sagen wollte. Und zwar...
Ja, ich habe so eingestellt, dass ich mit einer Maus
von einem Bildschirm auf den anderen kann,
obwohl er am gleichen Rechner angeschlossen ist.
Ja, ähm...
So.
Auf Twitter haben sie jetzt nämlich wieder so getan,
als sind die Leute alle böse, die...
...die Klopapier gerade wieder kaufen.
Wobei ich persönlich der Meinung bin,
dass das eigentlich genau umgedreht...
Also ich verstehe nicht, warum man sich so da überhaupt
darüber aufregt, dass andere Leute Klopapier kaufen.
Und was ich halt ganz besonders lustig finde,
ist, dass...
Es wird so getan, als wären die Leute dumm,
die Klopapier kaufen.
Dabei ist es genau umgedreht.
Die Leute, die das nicht kaufen,
sind eigentlich dumm.
Warum? Weil es im Prinzip schon so ist,
was damals Vaas in Far Cry gesagt hat.
Wenn man den gleichen Scheiß
immer wieder gleich dumm macht,
ist man halt verrückt.
So, das heißt, man hat gelernt das letzte Mal,
okay?
Die Leute drehen am Rad und kaufen
alle Klopapier. Das heißt, wenn ich
jetzt kein Klopapier kaufe,
bin ich eigentlich doof.
Weil ich weiß, was kommen wird und ich
weiß, wie es das letzte Mal gelaufen ist.
Also eigentlich
ist es genau umgedreht. Jemand, der
jetzt kein Klopapier kauft,
ist doof. Nicht der, der Klopapier
kauft. Weil ansonsten
haben sie aus dem letzten nichts gelernt.
Und natürlich ist
es so,
wenn alle Leute
sich
am Riemen reißen würden
und nur
ganz stur
nur das kaufen, was sie aktuell
benötigen, so wie
immer, dann gäbe es das
Problem nicht. Aber
wir wissen
ja, dass es nicht so ist.
Also sprich, ja, jeder, der sagt,
dass Horten führt zu Engpässen
zu Problemen, hat Recht. Aber
nachdem wir wissen, dass sich garantiert
nicht alle Leute am Riemen reißen
werden, hat man eigentlich
gar keine andere Wahl
aus dem
Gelernten vom letzten Mal
die Rückschlüsse zu ziehen. Hey,
ich kauf lieber schon mal was.
Weil ansonsten musst du dich
wieder darauf verlassen, dass andere
Leute das Richtige machen.
Oder das, das
für die Allgemeinheit, das Richtige kann man nicht
sagen, aber das für die Allgemeinheit
Verträglichere machen. Und darauf kannst du dich nicht verlassen.
Und nachdem man weiß, dass man sich darauf
nicht verlassen kann, ist man blöde,
wenn man jetzt nichts bestellt.
Allerdings, was ich
immer noch denke, was sinnvoller
ist, nicht in Laden rennen
und dort irgendwie 50
Pakete Klopapier kaufen, sondern einfach
in einen Online-Shop gehen.
Dann kauft man den Laden nicht leer
und man hat trotzdem sein Klopapier.
Genauso habe ich ja hier auch gemacht. Ich habe das Ganze
online bestellt. Ich bin ja nicht etwa in Lidl gefallen und habe
hier funny Klopapier gekauft. Ich habe einfach
online bestellt. Da kommt jeder der Reihe
nach dran. Und
es führt
auch nicht zu Engpässen irgendwie im
Supermarkt.
Welche? Also ich habe hier bestellt.
Moment. Aber da habe ich schon
von einem anderen gehört im Stream, dass
es bei ihm nie angekommen ist.
Hier.
Da habe ich das letzte Mal bestellt.
Klopapier. Hier, funny.
Müsst ihr gucken, die haben verschiedenste
Sachen. Manchmal haben die sogar
Angebote, auch in der aktuellen
Zeit. Und da kriegt
er alles. Zumindest, was ich sagen will,
ist, es ist nachvollziehbar,
jetzt Klopapier zu kaufen.
Und die, die sich auf Twitter darüber
empören, sind die Ersten, die rumheulen,
wenn sie nichts mehr bekommen.
Wie böse ja alle zu ihnen sind.
Und ich finde, das ist
eine Art von Dummheit, letztendlich.
Also wenn ich doch schon
weiß, was auf mich zukommt, und
wenn ich aus dem letzten Mal
ähm,
nichts gelernt habe, dann bin ich doch dumm, oder?
Oder verstehe ich die Twitter-Logik
nicht? Ich meine,
es gibt zwei Sachen. Es gibt
die Betrachtungsweise,
ja, es ist, ähm,
schlecht
für die Allgemeinheit, oder
unsolidarisch, wie auch immer, wenn die Leute
Klopapier holen. Okay, ja. Aber,
auf der anderen Seite, jetzt für
individuell betrachtet,
ist man doch doof, wenn man nicht daraus
gelernt hat, wie es das letzte Mal gelaufen ist.
Und, äh,
deswegen verstehe ich die Leute nicht, die jetzt rumheulen
und sagen, oh nein, Hilfe,
jetzt kaufen wir den Leuten Klopapier.
Die Ersten, die jetzt sagen, Leute,
kauft kein Klopapier, sind die Ersten,
die weinen, weil sie keins mehr bekommen.
Also, eigentlich richtig, richtig dämlich.
Es gibt ja auch genug.
Es ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir zu wenig Klopapier.
Es gab ja das letzte Mal auch genug,
die haben bloß Probleme gehabt, genug
in den Supermarkt zu bekommen. Es ist ja nicht so, als
hätten wir allgemein zu wenig Klopapier
gehabt, als wäre Klopapier jetzt
irgendwie, äh, aus der Goldmine,
als wäre die Goldmine, die Klopapiermine
in Afrika leer gewesen. Ist ja nicht so.
Wir hatten genug Klopapier, aber das kam
nicht genug in, äh, im Supermarkt.
Äh, wieso Klopapier? Oh, ich glaube,
das ist eine psychologische Frage,
wo es mit Sicherheit schon irgendwelche Studien
zugibt. Habe ich übrigens, habe ich
nicht irgendeinen Sub eben übersehen? Moment.
Ja, Tribulant, 11 Monate.
Dankeschön. Ich glaube, das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Dankeschön. Ähm,
aber irgendwie gesagt, warum Klopapier?
Keine Ahnung. Das ist, glaube ich, irgendeine
psychologische Geschichte, dass die Leute
quasi denken, okay, äh,
wenn es der Welt schlecht geht, was
ist, also das ist jetzt so eine, so eine
Hobbypsychologie-Interpretation von mir.
Was ist das, was, äh,
mich quasi
ganz intim betrifft? Und das ist natürlich
aufs Klo gehen und dann brauche ich Klopapier.
Irgendwie sowas wird der Gedankengang
da unterbewusst sein, warum gerade Klopapier.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
VTS, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Excellent subscription.
Also, ich, ich sehe schon im
Chat, dass es wieder welche gibt, die empört sind
darüber, aber wie würdet ihr das denn
nennen, wenn man absichtlich
sagt, das ist kein
Problem. Wenn man
absichtlich
Sachen ignoriert,
die man
in der Vergangenheit
quasi gesehen hat,
die nicht richtig funktioniert und sie dann ignoriert und
das absichtlich wieder
verkehrt macht.
Das ist doch eigentlich bescheuert.
Also, man hat das letzte Mal gesehen,
ja, es wäre schön, wenn sich alle solidarisch
verhalten, ähm,
und, ähm,
ähm,
nur in normalem
Ausmaß Klopapier kaufen.
Aber, man hat doch das letzte Mal gesehen,
das ist nicht so.
Und man kann
davon ausgehen, es wird jetzt auch
nicht so sein.
Du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass die Mehrzahl der Leute
jetzt auf einmal, wir haben es ja gesehen,
dass es das letzte Mal nicht so war,
sagen, wir denken solidarisch und machen
das für die Allgemeinheit und kaufen nichts doppelt
und dreifach. Da kannst du dich nicht darauf verlassen.
Das heißt, wenn man daraus
gelernt hat, was das letzte Mal
passiert ist, dann kauft man sich jetzt
bei irgendeinem großen Händler, keine
Ahnung, einen 8er
Roll, einen 8er Pack Klopapier
und macht bei diesem ganzen Wahnsinn einfach
nicht mit.
Das ist kein,
das ist eigentlich
die einzig logische Variante.
Ja, ähm, und
außerdem, es gibt kein Problem.
Es gibt genug Klopapier.
Aber du kriegst halt Probleme,
wenn die Leute den Supermarkt leer kaufen
und dort, ähm,
die Regale leer machen und die müssen das
rankarren.
Das ist ein Problem. Dass es zu wenig
Klopapier gibt, das
stimmt ja gar nicht.
Das ist ja nicht so. Das heißt, wenn man im Internet
geht und bestellt sich bei
irgendeinem Großhändler einen 8er
Pack, dann ist das für
alle Beteiligten am besten. Man selbst
hat genug,
weil man hat daraus gelernt, man bekommt nichts.
Ähm, die Leute im Supermarkt können
nach wie vor einkaufen.
Es gibt mehr als genug.
Letztendlich, letztendlich,
wenn man diese Schlüsse draus
gezogen hat, ist eigentlich für alle Beteiligten
das Beste. Na, also was Besseres kannst
du eigentlich nicht machen. Ich sagte doch die ganze Zeit
online bestellen. Bei Amazon kannst du ja teilweise
gar nicht mehr online bestellen. Wenn du bei Amazon
Klopapier bestellen willst,
dann hast du teilweise bis November
Wartezeit. Ich meine, es geht noch. Es geht noch. Ja, es sind noch
zwei Wochen. Es gibt auch welche, die sind jetzt direkt lieferbar.
Aber man sieht schon, es wird ein bisschen enger.
Ja.
Ich denke, man muss hier, man muss da zwei,
grundsätzlich, das geht jetzt nicht nur wirklich
für Klopapier, aber man muss da zwei
Sachen unterscheiden. So, die ideale
Ansicht,
die wir alle teilen, denke ich
mal, dass es das Beste
wäre, wenn sich alle solidarisch
verhalten. Das ist die eine Sache.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, da sind wir alle der gleichen
Ansicht, wenn man davon ausgeht, im
Optimalfall sollte jeder nur das kaufen,
was er gerade braucht. Gehen wir mal davon aus, man könnte
nicht im Internet bestellen, nur im Supermarkt.
Dann wäre das der
Optimalfall. So. Aber
wir haben ja gesehen, das ist
nicht so. Und man kann
davon ausgehen, so sicher
wie das Amen in der Kirche,
dass nicht auf einmal jetzt
alle anfangen und sich so verhalten werden.
Das ist
vollkommen klar. Das war das letzte Mal
ja auch so. Und jetzt
ist halt die Frage, was man macht.
Entweder man empört
sich darüber und sagt,
ihr seid alle böse.
Und steht dann am Ende
ohne Klopapier da. Das Klopapier
ist jetzt ja quasi nur stellvertretend für andere Sachen.
Hat sich aber empört
und fühlt sich moralisch auf der richtigen
Seite. Das ist
die eine Variante. Also die eine Variante ist,
man fühlt sich moralisch besser, dass man
quasi solidarisch gehandelt hat und putzt
sich den Arsch im Zweifelsfall mit der Hand
ab oder geht unter die Dusche. Das ist das eine.
Oder man sagt, okay,
in Abwägung
der Umstände und was wir aus dem letzten
Mal gelernt haben,
ich kann mich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass sich die anderen da solidarisch verhalten.
Klar, natürlich ist das eine
gewisse Kettenreaktion. Das ist schon klar.
Und ich scheiß drauf
und verhalte mich unsolidarisch.
Dafür habe ich im Endeffekt Klopapier.
Das ist eine Abwägung, die musst du bei ganz vielen Sachen
treffen. Also das
ist eigentlich, finde ich, eine ziemlich komplexe
Geschichte. Aber man
kann nicht einfach nur sagen, jemand der
jetzt Klopapier kauft, ist dumm.
Und das ist das, was Twitter macht.
Das ist, finde ich, verkehrt. Derjenige,
der jetzt Klopapier
kauft, macht eigentlich
genau das, was er
machen, also was
nachvollziehbar ist. Er hat
aus den Fehlern des letzten
Mal gelernt.
So. Also
so die zwei Sachen gibt es.
Und natürlich muss sich jeder selbst überlegen,
was er macht. Aber
viele Probleme, also viele
alltägliche Problemstellungen, die man hat,
sind eine Abwägung aus
was mache ich
jetzt individuell und was
mutig der Allgemeinheit zu?
Da gibt es
ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz
viele Sachen. Zum Beispiel
gehe ich
jetzt... Was habe ich letztens
in einem Video gehört? Hat auch einer so
was ähnliches gesagt. So nach dem Motto,
wenn ich bei einer Versicherung bin,
melde ich den Schaden
jetzt oder bezahle ich ihn selbst?
Das ist ja auch so eine Abwägung.
Bezahle ich das selbst? Okay, weil dann vielleicht die Beiträge
nicht steigen. Oder sage
ich, nee, ich lasse es von der Versicherung
übernehmen mit dem
Hintergrundwissen, dass vielleicht die Beiträge steigen.
Das ist so Abwägung. Das sind so...
Es gibt ganz viele
alltägliche Entscheidungen, die
Abwägungen sind zwischen
dem, was ich für die Allgemeinheit
mache und
abgewegt das, was ich
individuell für mich mache.
Und Klopapier ist halt so das
offensichtlichste gerade. Ja und
außerdem gibt's
bei mir, was Klopapier angeht,
ein sehr weniger Problem, weil ich habe hier mein
Profi-Klo mit
Wasserstrahl für den Bobbes.
Ja, Max du Tant sehe ich auch so.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was mir auf Twitter,
warum ich die Twitter-Trends ausgeschaltet
habe, ist, weil
die Twitter-Trends eigentlich
alle möglichen Gruppierungen
an Leuten mehr oder weniger
nur untereinander posten, um sich
gegenseitig zu bestätigen, wie überlegen
und geil sie sind. Deswegen kann ich mir Twitter
auch nicht mehr geben auf Dauer.
So, was kommen wir uns jetzt an?
Windows 10 with One, okay.
Also von dem habe ich schon ein paar Videos
geguckt, die sind eigentlich recht gut.
Normalerweise sind solche Videos ja eher
keck W, keck Triple U.
So, ähm.
Mal gucken, mal gucken, was wir
für ein Command ausführen,
damit Windows 10 schneller wird.
Okay, mal raten. Ich versuch mal, ich
versuch mal zu raten. Ähm.
Okay, Festplatten
Defragmentierungsgedöns kann's nicht sein.
Das ist kein Ding mehr.
Was könnte man machen, dass
ein Command
was Windows schneller
macht? Ähm.
Die CPU
in Performance-Modus stellen, was eigentlich
gar nichts bringt, aber man weiß es ja nie.
Daniel Null, 16 Monate.
Massive Pock.
Ja, das ist ja schon
Hyper-Subscriber.
Alles Dankeschön für
16 Monate Subscription.
Man braucht eigentlich 10 Minuten für einen
older Install or a new one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Jetzt, ja, ich hab ne Idee, was das ist.
Das ist nicht ein Kommando, was der ausführt.
Der, äh, der,
der lädt sich irgendein Skript runter
und führt das aus, was
wahrscheinlich
50 Kommandos macht.
I'm not gonna go into many technical knowledge.
Just know it is
Okay, jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Cortana, all the bloat.
But it's gonna leave everything else alone.
In past videos, when I was stripping things out,
we were taking out some functionality of Windows 10.
In this one... Ach nee, hat er schon gesagt, dass
das irgendwie... Okay, das ist too bad.
Das ist massive too bad.
...the things that have to be removed on pretty much
every single, äh, Instrumente.
So, with that said, let's get on the desktop
and actually go into
removing and de-bloating it, because I made it
to where you just run one thing
in your shell, and it will literally
strip everything out for you.
Also, das ist so eine typische Windows-Geschichte,
ne? Wir führen erstmal ein Kommando
aus oder führen... Wir laden
uns random im Internet
irgendwelche Skripte, Programme, was auch immer
runter und führen sie aus. Das ist so eine typische
Windows-Geschichte. Very easy. You have
two questions to answer, as I want
to take your feedback. So, if there's something
that you don't like, or you'd like... Ich will nicht
behaupten, dass ich nie Weghardt was nach
Bash gepiped hab oder so. Aber in der
Regel guck ich mir zumindest das erste Mal an, was das ist.
...added to this script, let me know
in the comments, because every month I
am refining this script and will
be making it better. So, if you watch this six
months from now, the script is probably
evolved and bettered for
sure. And I'll be remaking this video
as I add features as well.
But, that said, this
is version 1.0.
And, let's get into it.
So, this is a base setup of Windows.
All I've done is installed
Windows, thrown up a backup
so I have an image, so I can restore
to this point. I have not changed
anything with it. This is exactly
what Windows looks like if you install it.
Ich muss mal kurz Pause machen. Es ist
im Chat wieder... Chat, ich muss euch mal
an der Stelle loben. Ich sehe es selten
auf Twitter, sowohl als auf Twitch,
also auf Twitch eh, dass es
sinnvolle Diskussionen im Chat gibt, ist ja eh schon
kaum so. Und auf Twitter gar
nicht mehr. Aber ich muss sagen, hier im Chat,
ich muss euch da mal wirklich sagen,
das ist selten. Es ist wirklich selten, dass die Leute
halbwegs normal miteinander kommunizieren, diskutieren
und bei mir im Chat funktioniert es. Also
exquisite Big-Brain-Chat.
Deswegen, ich muss jetzt aber noch mal eine Sache kurz zu sagen,
weil es gerade diese Diskussion
nebenbei habe ich gesehen im Chat gibt, so irgendwas
weiß ich, ob man egoistisch sein sollte,
solidarisch sein sollte, sonst was. Man darf
nie den Fehler machen, alles immer absolut
zu sehen. Also, die wenigsten
Entscheidungen sind 100% schwarz,
100% weiß. Also sprich,
jeder wird tagtäglich
Entscheidungen fällen, die eher
aus, nennen wir mal so,
ich angetriebenen,
egoistischen Sachen getroffen werden, als auch welche,
die abgewegt werden, wo man sagt,
hey, ich mach das jetzt
nicht so, wie es für
mich am besten ist, sondern so, wie es für mich,
meine Familie allgemein am besten ist.
Also es gibt ja auch,
es gibt halt bei den wenigsten Sachen schwarz
und weiß. Also keiner
ist immer egoistisch und keiner
macht immer alles
für die Gemeinheit. In Wirklichkeit macht
jeder alles.
Natürlich hast du Leute, die
sind ein bisschen mehr auf sich selbst
fokussiert und Leute, die sind ein bisschen
mehr auf die Allgemeinheit, aber im Prinzip
macht
jeder alles. Deswegen kann man
das gar nicht so sagen, so nach dem Motto
es ist
das eine schlecht, das andere
gut, weil es macht eh jeder alles.
...
desktop so ist wenn du zum beispiel irgendwas man geht man geht hier über
die man geht hier irgendwie über google da drauf so und jetzt ich glaube im
desktop bereich ist es nicht so aber ich habe mobile immer das problem dass wenn
ich jetzt auf weiterlesen clique möchte der dass ich mich einloggen oder die app
installiere also sprich ich kann kein reddit mehr lesen im browser auf dem
handy ohne dass ich mich einloggen muss oder der app verwenden muss aber was
kein ding ist ich meine ich verwende eine app dafür aber also ich finde es
kacke weil viele sachen lese ich im browser und gehe rein und versuche
einfach kurze informationen anzugucken oder gehe ich wieder raus zumal die
reddit app hardcore scheiße ist reddit ihr beste beste app für reddit
und apollo reader also die einzige reddit app auf ios die man sich die man
sich geben kann aber trotzdem das switchen in die app ist zum größten teil
total unsinnig weil man sucht guck mal also du suchst irgendwas auf auf google
irgendwie was keine ahnung du suchst jetzt mal was ich linux how to bash
irgendwas und die chancen dass den reddit eintrag unter den ersten treffern
hier ist ist relativ hoch
gibt es mal reddit mit ein weil es natürlich so ist relativ hoch das heißt
viele sinnvolle antworten findet man heute heutzutage halt nur auf reddit und
deswegen du gehst in browser und willst du es da durchlesen du willst nicht erst
noch eine app starten weil vielleicht bist du ja gerade in reddit in der app
was am lesen und du willst nicht dass er einfach dass ich dann auf ein anderes
topic bringt total bescheuert ich verstehe den sinn auch gar nicht davon
warum will man so eine verfickte app pushen
es ist reddit ist ein forum warum brauche ich um den forum zu lesen eine
extra app man kann sich eine extra app installieren wenn man will und wenn man
seine seine post besser verwalten will seine subscribten sachen besser für
alles schön und gut aber die grundfunktionalität aus einer suchmaschine
in den forum zu gehen und dort eine antwort zu lesen die man gesucht hat die
will ich nach wie vor verwenden können ohne dass ich mich registrieren muss
anmelden muss oder eine app starten muss also ich weiß nicht was mit reddit da
gerade los ist die drehen voll am rad tomtricks mag sie so ein exzellent war extrem
Exzellent. Exzellente Subscriptions.
Zwei Monate hier. Huge.
Hast du heute schon mal
an Reddit gedacht? Oh ja, das ist auch
nervig. Deswegen verwende ich, wie gesagt, ich verwende
nur noch Apollo Reader.
Weil Reddit,
die Reddit App selbst ist
mir richtig schlecht. Reddit,
mal gucken, was die für Bewertungen hat mittlerweile.
Okay, die ist, hat auch ganz
gute Bewertungen. Vielleicht ist die besser geworden.
Weiß nicht. Aber ich verwende immer nur
die hier. Gut.
Leider
gibt es
keine
Um es jetzt mal ein bisschen,
wo wir das Thema zurecht. Es gibt leider
keine gute Twitch App für
Android, die nicht die offizielle Twitch App
ist. Also für YouTube
passt die ja Newpipe und YouTube
Vans und so. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Aber es gibt keine, es gibt
kein Twitch, Twitch Vans. Das
ist ein bisschen doof. Übrigens, die
Android Kenner, ich muss euch jetzt mal was
fragen. Vielleicht weiß das jemand.
Big, Big Brain Chat.
Es sind gerade über 300 Leute da.
Kann ich euch mal fragen. Vielleicht weiß das jemand.
Wie kann ich
über Tasker oder
irgendwie über irgendeine Automatisierungs
App in Android, wie kann
ich dort eine Web
App starten? Also man
kann ja, wenn man
also was ich meine
ist das hier. Es gibt
ja mittlerweile die Möglichkeit, ich brauche
jetzt mal ein Beispiel dafür.
Es gibt ja die Möglichkeit, dass du,
wenn bestimmte
Webseiten ihre,
die richtigen Sachen im
Quelltext drinstehen haben, um es mal einfach zu sagen,
dann kann man die Sachen
auf den Startscreen packen.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich
Home Assistant hab oder irgendwas anderes
und ich gehe auf die Seite, dann
sagt der mir, hey, möchten sie diese Webseite
nicht als Shortcut auf den Home Screen
hinzufügen. Das ist sinnvoll,
weil dann ist die App immer im
Fullscreen und
ich musste halt nicht im Browser starten, Twitter PWA, ich weiß aber nicht, ob man das hier im Browser machen kann,
Install Twitter, genau, also, das geht ja auf Android, also sprich, wenn ich auf Twitter gehe und ich habe nicht die App,
dann kann ich hier oben sagen, Install, das fragt mich dann Firefox oder Chrome direkt, wenn ich das aufmache,
oder auch Safari unter iOS, so, und dann kann ich die, dann kann ich die zu meinem Startbildschirm hinzufügen,
diese Anwendung, alles schön und gut, was ist denn das, das kenne ich noch gar nicht,
aber wie starte ich so eine auf den Startbildschirm hinzugefügte App über Tasker oder irgendeine Automatisierung,
wie geht das, was soll denn das sein, ach, das ist so eine Verknüpfung zu allen möglichen PWAs, die es gibt,
okay, warum nicht, wie starte ich sowas,
über Tasker, ich habe nichts Gescheites gefunden, ehrlich gesagt,
die einzige Sache, die mir einfällt, aber die ist äußerst unschön, ist,
dass ich einen Klick simuliere auf mein Homescreen, aber das ist Kacke,
also, wie starte ich zum Beispiel aus Tasker oder generell über Android,
wie starte ich eine Web-App auf dem Homescreen,
normale Apps starten über Tasker ist kein Problem,
da kannst du einfach sagen, Launch App und wählst die App aus,
aber PWAs stehen da nicht,
und ich habe legit keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert,
das wäre nämlich ganz praktisch, weil ich wollte es auf meinem Tablet so machen,
du kannst auch per Code was starten, aber ich weiß nicht wie,
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie,
ich wollte es nämlich so machen, dass wenn ich mein Bildschirm entsperre auf meinem Tablet,
was meinst du, sowas wie Lama, nee, was soll das sein,
ach so, Automate, ja, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ja,
also es ist jetzt egal, es ist jetzt egal, ob man Automate verwendet, ob man Tasker verwendet,
eigentlich ist es egal, weil alle haben das gleiche Problem,
also wie starte ich aus irgendwie einem dieser Automatisierungs-App,
mir ist auch vollkommen egal, welcher, wie starte ich eine PWA, die auf dem Homescreen ist,
was ist eine PWA, das ist, wenn du auf eine Webseite gehst und die dich fragt,
ob du diese Webseite auf deinen Startbildschirm, auf deinen Homescreen hinzufügen willst,
das ist eine PWA, also eigentlich eine Verknüpfung zu einer Webseite,
die in einem Fullscreen-Browser läuft,
also wenn du mit deinem Handy auf Twitter gehst, Home Assistant gehst
und das erste Mal auf die Seite gehst, dann fragt die dich,
wie ist das, wie ist das, wie ist das, wie ist das, wie ist das, wie ist das, wie ist das,
möchten sie diese Seite jetzt zum Startbildschirm hinzufügen
und wenn du dann sagst, ja will ich, dann ist das meistens eine PWA
und wie starte ich diese Verknüpfung, die ich dort auf den Homescreen hinzugefügt habe,
ich finde nichts, das einzige, was mir einfällt, ist von Hand dort auf den Startbildschirm zu klicken,
aber das geht ja gar nicht,
X-Fatal, 16 Monate, danke schön für den Sub,
Hyper-Subscriber, und wie, danke schön für die Subscriptions,
was kennst du, Hermit, ne, kenn ich nicht,
Android, zeig mal her, was ist das,
äh, nein, U-Boot, kannst nicht,
damit habe ich es ausprobiert,
wie, wie soll das gehen, das geht nicht,
weil ich habe es mit Automate ausprobiert, damit geht das nicht,
du kannst mit Automate, kannst du sagen, Start-App, Launch-App,
aber du kannst nur Apps auswählen, die echte APKs sind,
aber das geht nicht, so, was ist das,
Light-Apps-Browser, ich glaube, das ist was anderes,
ich glaube, das ist was anderes, oder,
naja, gut, mal gucken, es muss ja auch eine Firefox-PWA sein bei mir,
weil ansonsten die Kameras nicht gehen,
wenn es auf Chrome-Basis ist, sackt es,
naja, hätte ja sein können, dass das einer weiß,
äh, warum startest du nicht einfach direkt die Seite, wo ist der Vorteil,
das würde ich machen, wenn die dann auch schön Vollscreen ist,
da habe ich kein Problem mit,
du kannst doch angeben, mit XY starten,
ja, aber wenn ich sage,
also zum Beispiel, wenn ich sage, starte Firefox
und gebe dann die Uhr von meinem Home Assistant ein,
äh, dann macht der ja ein Browser-Fenster auf
mit, mit, äh, Browser-Bedienelementen und Uhrleiste und sowas,
aber knackraff, knusprig, äh, wie gesagt, ich wüsste nicht, wie das funktioniert,
ich muss die nicht vom Startbildschirm starten,
ich will die, äh, einfach nur im Fullscreen starten,
so wie es halt eine PWA macht,
naja, ich muss mir das nachher nochmal angucken,
aber ich habe da nichts gefunden,
weil was ich machen will, ist,
folgendes, ich, ich habe mir hier so einen Workflow eingestellt
für mein Android-Tablet,
billiger Amazon Fire-Tablet,
dass wenn ich den Bildschirm entsperre,
nee, das geht nicht,
Herz 93, man kann kein Fullscreen automatisch machen,
Fullscreen muss immer interaktiv sein,
ähm,
mach's gut, Sibaro,
äh, fuck, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau,
ich will nämlich, wenn ich meinen Bildschirm entsperre,
bei meinem Android-Tablet, will ich, dass
direkt nach dem Entsperren als erstes
meine Heimatomatisierung aufgeht,
ja, Tribulon, das Problem hiermit könnte sein,
dass es Chrome-basiert ist,
und ich muss es in Firefox starten,
Chrome-basiert geht nicht,
ich muss es in Firefox starten,
weil Chrome, lustigerweise,
auf den Fire-Tablets
keine Videos abspielen kann,
die H.264 encoded sind,
Firefox kann's,
die haben einen Decoder drin,
Chrome hat keinen Software-Decoder drin,
für das gängigste Videoformat der Welt,
muss er nicht, weil normalerweise
verwenden die den Hardware-Decoder
vom jeweiligen Device, aber das kann Chrome
auf dem Fire-HD nicht,
Silk kann's,
aber Silk kann kein Fullscreen,
das ist echt ätzend,
ne, der Fully-Kiosk-Browser reicht nicht,
weil das ist auch Chrome-Webview-based,
und Chrome geht nicht,
Chrome kann meine Kameras nicht anzeigen,
nur Firefox kann das unter Android
auf dem Fire-TV,
und Silk, aber Silk kann kein Fullscreen,
tja, das ist nicht so einfach,
ne,
doch Chrome auf Linux hat einen H.264-Decoder,
was, ein Software-H.264,
unter Linux ist es, äh,
Tomox, unter Linux ist es genau umgedreht,
unter Linux verwendet Chrome
immer den Software-Decoder,
und bis vor kurzem nie den Hardware-Decoder,
ne, iPad kaufen bringt mir ja schon mal gar nichts an der Stelle,
mit iPads kannst du ja noch
weniger automatisch machen,
als mit Android,
das ist auch für mich die große Daseinsfrage,
das ist die Daseinsberechtigung von Android,
dass man viel mehr automatisch machen kann,
ja.
Ich probiere das mal nachher aus,
was ihr geschrieben habt,
aber ich fürchte, es wird nicht funktionieren.
Gerade getestet mit Haskell,
na gut, ich muss,
ich brauche die Home Assistant PWA,
muss ich starten,
nachdem der Bildschirm unlockt wird.
Ich probiere das,
ich probiere mal PWA zu,
PWA zu,
äh, Firefox,
es muss, es muss Firefox-based sein.
Ja, umut, ich hab's gesehen,
ich probiere das nachher mal aus,
also, ich hab nichts Gescheites gefunden,
bisher,
es sackt ein bisschen.
So, gucken wir mal weiter,
was haben wir denn hier sonst noch Schönes?
Wie machen Microsoft,
achso, genau, wir wollten uns ja
How to Speed Up Windows angucken,
genau, also.
Was macht der denn?
Übelstes Debate-Video.
Postchamp sagt er.
Wisst ihr, was witzig ist?
Dass allein schon das,
für die meisten 0 nach 15 Anwender,
der übelste Hacker-Move ist.
Also, allein schon, allein schon,
wenn ihr das hier macht.
Für die normalen Windows-Anwender
ist das der krasseste Hacker-Move des Jahrtausends.
Die sagen,
wow,
du kennst dich aber gut aus mit Computer.
Hai, jai, jai, jai, jai.
Die harte, so dass hier,
und,
Moment, hab ich das,
hab ich das,
hab ich das jetzt auch schon?
Hab ich, hab ich auch schon?
Man kann übrigens, glaube ich,
Alt-D oder so,
nee, äh,
Alt-R, ja.
Ähm, äh, äh, äh,
hab ich das jetzt auch schon?
Oh, nee, ich hab immer noch 20.04.
Oh, nein.
Ich hab immer noch kein 20.02.
Gibt's das noch nicht,
oder wie ist das?
Was, Moment,
check, update, update,
update checken.
Ey, gibt's doch gar nicht,
guck mal.
Ich bekomme gar kein 20,
kein 20.02 angezeigt.
Was, was soll das?
Warum krieg ich kein 20.02?
Nee, das sind Driver-Updates,
das ist was anderes.
Das jetzt auch mal.
Warum, warum krieg ich das nicht?
Pepega, Microsoft-Dings, ja.
Huge Pepega.
Oh, nee, nicht so,
nicht so ein doofes Debloat-Skript wieder.
Davon gibt's so viele
und ich würd's mir nie im Leben
auf meinem Rechner ausführen, nie.
Wer weiß, was das da alles deploatet.
Ich hab keinen Bock,
mir vorher erst mal 500 Zeilen Skript durchzulesen,
dass es keinen Scheiß baut bei mir auf dem Rechner.
Und außerdem, was, was, was genau
muss man da eigentlich alles deploaten?
Es gibt also zwei Sachen,
die mir spontan einfallen.
Erstens, dass man diese ganzen
Candy Crush-Geschiss deinstalliert,
das kann man aber auch so machen.
Und dass man ein paar Telemetriesachen abschaltet.
Aber ansonsten wüsste ich nicht,
was man an Windows 10 großartig deploaten,
muss.
Okay, es installiert mir schon mal
zig Programme, die ich nicht haben will.
Top.
Sehr gut.
Genau das brauch ich.
Genau das, genau, genau das brauch ich.
Ich brauch unbedingt ein Skript,
was mir Geschiss installiert,
was ich nicht brauch.
Das erste geht noch,
das kann man installieren.
Notepad++ brauch ich nicht,
ich hab Visual Studio Code Info,
brauch ich erst recht nicht mehr.
VLC installier ich mir selbst.
Java will ich erst recht nicht drauf haben.
Äh, Adobe Reader und Brave
will ich auch garantiert nicht haben.
Also, wozu?
So, was macht's denn sonst noch?
Äh, removes all store app.
Okay, das ist in Ordnung.
Telemetry ist in Ordnung.
Disable Cortana ist auch okay.
Äh, das find ich nicht gut.
Moment.
Das hat er doch hier schon gemacht.
Doch, Windows Store.
Das will ich auch nicht,
auch nichts gefixt haben.
Das braucht man nicht.
Ich find's aber auch geil,
das ist ein,
ich wollte hier 1337,
exakt das, ähm,
sie sagen, sie deploaten, dann,
Windows und installieren die erst mal,
äh,
äh, 8 von 10 Programmen,
die ich nicht brauche.
Excellent.
... everyone should use
and should have on their system
because it just makes your life easier.
Notepad++,
which is a better notepad.
IRFanView,
which is a good replacement
for just viewing images on your system.
IRFan, heißt das wirklich so?
Ich hab früher immer IRFanView gesagt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das so ausspricht.
Wie wird man das auf Englisch aussprechen?
Ar, ar, arven, arvenview.
I, arvenview.
Ne, das kann man nicht aussprechen, ne.
Ich hab immer IR, IR, IRFan,
IRFanView gesagt.
... a lot of times people are using
Chocolaty ist ein Package Manager
für Windows systemweit,
den ich nicht mehr verwende.
Ich verwende nur Scoop mittlerweile.
Scoop ist ein Package Manager
für Entwicklertools für Windows,
der, äh, aber benutzerbezogen ist.
Warum installieren die überhaupt irgendwas?
Das ist so eine gute berechtigte Frage,
wundert mich auch, ja.
Wenn's deploated ist,
sollen sie vielleicht nur Sachen wegmachen.
... the built-in photos,
from Windows 10,
and it's just not very good
compared to that program,
which is all free and open source as well.
VLC, as that's most people's pick
from video viewing or video playing,
so I chose that.
In a past video I said I liked MPC
a little bit better,
which is Media Player Classic,
but I know most people do prefer VLC,
so I did change my script to use VLC.
Das ist auch ...
VLC ist ein gutes Beispiel für,
wenn sich mal Software durchsetzt,
wegen der Funktion und nicht wegen der Optik.
Weil man muss halt mal ehrlich sagen,
VLC selber sieht halt ...
... jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt richtig ...
... hübsch aus für das Jahr 2020,
aber die Funktionen machen's halt aus.
... to accommodate everyone else ...
Wozu braucht man eigentlich Java?
... and Java ...
Sorry, Leute.
Java.
Java braucht man.
Nicht Java.
Java.
... do run Java
or you'll need it as a dependency.
That's it.
This is pretty much the baseline of just ...
I think every system should probably have
these things installed already,
but don't.
And then it will ask for two different programs
that you want to install
and you'll see that during the script run.
Was? VLC hat bombe neue Themes bekommen
vor kurzem.
Echt jetzt?
Wo?
Den muss ich mir gleich angucke.
Wo geht das?
Habe ich überhaupt ein aktuelles ...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich habe kein aktuelles VLC.
308, was ist das aktuelle VLC?
Was ist das aktuelle VLC?
3.0.11.
Ho, ho.
Na, da muss ich mal updaten.
Mal VLC updaten.
Excellent.
Schon die neueste Beta von VLC gesehen.
Echt hässlich.
Wow, wow, wow.
Okay, ich habe lange nicht mehr geupdatet.
Ja, ja.
Ist ja gut.
Ist ja alles ...
So, erst mal VLC updaten.
Oh, VLC still running.
Okay.
3.0.11.
Ist ja gut.
Das ist der Akku-Manager, den ich meine, den ich unter Windows verwende.
Das ist aber auch der einzige Akku-Manager, der taugt, finde ich.
So, VLC.
So.
Okay, 3.0.11.
So, also.
VLC-Skins.
Ja, das muss man jetzt ausprobieren.
Was hat VLCs für Bomben-Skins?
Ist das jetzt neu?
Gibt es das nicht schon ewig?
Soll ich hübsch finde ich die jetzt.
PWA to APK funktioniert?
Ja, Hauptsache, das ist Firefox-Based und nicht Chrome-Based.
ist. Ja, okay.
Ich dachte, es gibt jetzt so generell irgendwas
Neues. Dass es
VLC-Skins gibt, weiß ich.
Aber die ändern
ja jetzt so grundsätzlich mal an, dass
sich VLC irgendwie oldschool anfühlt.
Nix. Auch wenn es natürlich
cooler aussieht. Also das
finde ich jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig.
Wie sieht dann VLC-Beta aus?
Wie sieht es...
Oh, VLC-Media-Player
4-Beta.
Äh.
Sieht ja aus wie eine Elektronen-Oberfläche, Alter.
Igitt.
Also dann bevorzuge ich tatsächlich lieber den
oldschool-Look.
Das sieht nicht hübsch aus. Aber was ist denn das?
Igitt.
Das
kommt raus.
Das kommt raus,
wenn Leute, wenn
Programmierer, die
richtig clever sind,
was Algorithmen und
Funktionen und Sachen angeht, sich an
UI-Design versuchen. Dann kommt sowas raus.
Okay, das ist die Android-Version, ja.
Naja. Kommen wir mal weiter hier.
Bin stehen geblieben.
Wozu?
Warum überhaupt nur
einen Browser? Man kann einfach alle Browser
nicht verwenden. Chrome, Chromium, Vivaldi.
Ab und zu haben wir sogar noch ein Edge am Start.
Firefox. Dann brauchen wir noch
Opera GX.
Für RGB-Steuerung.
Nee, aber,
Firefox, Chrome, Chromium
ist eigentlich default bei mir.
Ich hab
sogar oftmals alle drei Sachen
parallel offen.
Also ich mach so, ich mach meine komplette
Homeoffice-Geschichten
über Chrome. Kommt drauf an, was du
machen willst.
Also ich mach meine ganzen Homeoffice-Geschichten
nur über Chrome.
Mit dem Browser mach ich sonst nichts anderes.
So, dann hab ich Chromium
für alles.
Andere. Und Firefox
für YouTube. Und ein paar andere Sachen,
wenn Chrome nicht mag.
Gibt ja immer noch ein paar Sachen,
die besser im Firefox laufen. Beispielsweise sind die
Entwicklertools, find ich, schöner im
die standardmäßigen Entwicklertools
im Firefox schöner als im
Chrome.
Hast du nicht einen dedizierten PC-Notebook
für die Arbeit? Nö.
Ich hab meine eigene Windows, also, nee, Quatsch.
Ich hab, äh, ich hab eine Linux-VM,
wenn ich Sachen machen muss. Und
äh, ansonsten geh ich über den
Browser drauf.
Oh, jetzt wird's, äh, jetzt wird's aber
Hacker-Style hier.
Also wenn ich Random-Skripts aus dem
Internet in der PowerShell als Admin
ausführen muss, dann, da hab ich schon immer
so leichte Vorbehalte dagegen.
Weiß nicht, wie's euch da so geht.
Übrigens, interaktive
PowerShell-UIs sehen so
hässlich aus, ne?
Also, es gibt ja unter,
also viele Kommandozeilen-Sachen in Linux
sehen auch nicht, äh, nicht hübsch aus, aber
äh, also gerade PowerShell-Skripts,
die dann versuchen, solche Progress-Bars
zu machen, so, das sieht so
hässlich aus.
Da sah das unter Linux mit, mit
NCurses und so vor 20 Jahren schon besser aus.
Das ist, äh, wollte ich grad sagen, es ist
super vertrauenserweckend, ey.
Wenn ich sowas hier sage, ey, guck mal,
äh, PowerShell-Admin-Execute,
irgendeine komische Git-Url, das ist das
Gegenstück zu, ähm,
sudo minus i,
wget, äh, pastebin
pipebash. Das ist so das
Gegenstück dazu.
Imp, keine Ahnung.
Also, mir fällt
Windows-Installationen immer direkt irgendwas
über, kann man irgendwas über PXE machen,
aber da hab ich keinen Schimmer vorne. Ich hab Windows-Installationen
noch nie automatisiert.
Ah, das hat schon gut funktioniert.
Wer hat sich bei Microsoft eigentlich gedacht,
es ist eine gute Idee, die PowerShell-Konsole
standardmäßig blauen Hintergrund zu machen
und Fehlermeldungen dann schwarz auf rot zu machen.
Das sieht, das sieht,
das sieht ernsthaft aus wie
in einem ollen Unix-System
von 1985 oder so.
Sieht so, so kacke an, ey, da, da
hattest du keinen farbigen Bildschirm, sorry, aber
äh, es sieht, es sieht so kacke aus.
Was für ein Ding!
Oh and oh shut up!
Free Anti-Spy-Tool für Linux.
Ah, okay.
Noch mehr, noch mehr
random Software von irgendwo
runterladen und ausführen. Excellent.
Also, ich bin kein Fan von
Telemetrie-Funktionen in Windows 10,
aber ob das jetzt, ob es
jetzt der Weisheitsletzter Schluss ist,
irgendwelche
ungeprüfte Software aus dem
Internet zu laden und auszuführen,
ist fraglich. Dann würde ich
mir lieber gucken, welche Funktionen ich von Hand
ausschalten muss, dass die Telemetrie
Dinger nicht mehr funktionieren und würde mir das von Hand
machen, anstatt hier, anstatt
so Zeug auszuführen.
Aber Hauptsache, sie sind Microsoft
Gold-Partner. Kennt ihr die
ganzen indischen Scammer?
Die sagen auch immer, sie sind
Microsoft Gold-Partner.
This is Peter?
Old Don, Old Don, this is Peter.
Microsoft Gold-Partner?
A lot of people love Oh No Shut Up.
It's a fantastic tool that strips out
and changes all the settings in Windows.
Ich kenne das nicht. Es kann durchaus sein, dass das okay ist,
man sich das installieren kann, aber ich würde es
mir vorher mal in Ruhe angucken, bevor ich es mir installiere.
Also ich,
weil ich es nicht kenne. Hätte ich das jetzt schon
ein paar Mal installiert und hätte mir gesagt,
okay, das ist in Ordnung, dann würde ich mir auch nicht
jedes Mal neu angucken.
To be privacy oriented, meaning it
removes all the bloat and actually changes
everything. Now I created a
custom hidden script that
automatically makes those configuration changes
for you, so you don't even have to do anything.
It will automatically download,
set it up for you
and make all the recommended changes
using Oh No Shut Up's
recommended version.
Right now I'm just installing those programs
I just went over. And now is the first question.
Do you want to install Adobe Reader?
We're gonna say no to this.
And then do you want to install Brave Browser?
That's the browser I like.
But it has Microsoft Edge, which is
Chromium based as well. I'm gonna say no.
Habt ihr die Sicherheits-Look in Chrome
mitgekriegt vor ein paar Tagen?
Let's go a little faster.
So this is actually removing
a lot of apps. As we saw
on the start menu, there was
a lot of apps. And then also
the task manager itself
has roughly 140
something processes running.
And that's it.
So the entire run time of this script
is about 60 seconds.
On average.
This system right here is about a 5 or 6 year old
PC. So if it
takes only a minute to run, it might run
a lot faster on your
newer PC.
So with that, we'll go ahead and close
this. And I'm gonna go ahead and
restart the PC. And let's see
what it looks like on startup.
Alright, we're back on.
Es sieht wahrscheinlich genauso aus wie vorher,
nur dass ein paar Sachen deinstalliert wurden.
Our desktop here and
everything is right there.
Der Hintergrund ist weg.
Aber wozu?
Was ist Schwachsinn?
This XML file. But you can easily
just delete this as it was just trying
to set your default application.
If you go to settings,
all the privacy settings, you'll notice
it's been changed as per the script.
So if you go to there, you'll notice all of this
is off.
Ja, geil. Okay.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich würde,
bevor ich random Scripts im Internet
in PowerShell Admin pipe, würde ich mir
die paar Settings, die ich brauche, das werden ja vielleicht
5 bis 10 Sachen sein, würde ich mir
raussuchen, entweder selbst von Hand einstellen
oder selbst irgendwie ein Script bauen.
Gerade unter Windows,
PowerShell Admin pipe
Pipe sudo bash,
nee,
Microsoft ist nicht going to suggest
Apps to you. It's not going to
go ahead and send everything back to
Microsoft saying they're using this computer this
way. Okay, das ist langweilig.
Obviously, I didn't change anything
from Windows Store. Post, Deploy,
Prozesse sind Performance. Okay. You'll see
OneDrive down here. As I said, I didn't
uninstall that. Task Manager,
let's see what it's doing. I did leave
Windows Defender and Defender Updates
alone, so it does have any virus
on here where a past script, I did remove
it. This is a little more on
the higher end of things where I don't
want to be, but again, this will
be rough.
Scheißegal, was da im Hintergrund läuft.
Solange die Dinger keine CPU-Zeit
brauchen, ist ein gestarteter Prozess, ein paar
Kilobyte RAM, who cares, ja?
Oder ein paar Mega, oder ein paar
100 Megabyte RAM, wenn es Elektron ist.
Aber gestartete Prozesse
ist an sich jetzt überhaupt nichts Schlimmes.
PC out there. 110
Processes, effectively killing
about 30 to 35 Processes
with this bloat script.
Not the greatest, but
something, again, everyone
can use, so.
Der Schwachsinn braucht kein Mensch.
Übrigens zur Chrome-Sicherheitslücke von vor ein paar Tagen,
die ist eigentlich ganz interessant, man weiß leider die Details
nicht. Zumindest solltet ihr gucken, dass
ihr mindestens Chrome-Version, die hinten
1111 hat oder so,
habt,
also mindestens die Version hier,
mindestens die Version,
weil die hat eine Sicherheitslücke
im Font-Rendering, was eigentlich ganz witzig
ist, weil
die das gleiche verwenden, was
Linux auch zum Font-Rendern verwendet, also zum
Schrift-Rendern.
Mal gucken, ob das da mittlerweile
jetzt mehr Infos... Hat der Heise
da nicht eine ganz, ganz brauchbare Sache
zu...
Ja, ne.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Chrome. Ja.
So, und da haben die doch auch
die Nummer
hier da. Ja, das da
ist das.
Das ist die eigentlich interessante
Browser-Lücke.
Gucken, ob wir dazu jetzt mittlerweile mehr Informationen
haben. Zumindest, anscheinend
war das so...
Ne, okay, man weiß noch nichts. Die halten
oftmals die Informationen
zu den Sachen zurück, bis genug
Leute die Updates inszeniert haben, dass nicht
die ganzen Möchtiger und Hexer auf
dieser Welt auf die Idee kommen, das auszunutzen.
Aber gerade diese Sicherheitslücke hier im
Chrome, die war wirklich nicht ohne.
Also
FreeType ist eine Library,
womit man Schrift rendert. Also sowas hier zum
Beispiel. Ich glaube unter... Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, dass das so ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es unter Windows auch
verwendet wird, aber wahrscheinlich,
weil sonst gibt es kein Problem.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass Chrome
FreeType gebundelt hat fürs Font-Rendering
und nicht, dass Windows
interner verwenden wird. Ehrlich gesagt,
keine Ahnung. Im Detail
kenne ich mich da nicht so aus mit
welchen Font-Render-Geschichten
Cross-Plattform. Zumindest Linux
verwendet es standardmäßig und Chrome
hat es anscheinend auch gebundelt. Und die
Sicherheitslücke war,
wenn PNGs,
gerendert werden und wenn PNGs
ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob Chrome
ClearType verwendet, ehrlich gesagt. Keine Ahnung.
Äh, sie werden es zumindest zum Teil
FreeType verwenden, weil Windows war auch
betroffen davon.
Und unter Windows macht ja eh jeder ein bisschen
was anderes, was Font-Rendering angeht. Guckt
ihr alte Windows-Apps an, guckt ihr
WPF-Apps an, guckt ihr UWP-Apps an, alles
ein bisschen anders. Ähm...
Ne, das ist egal.
Ob du Chrome oder Chromium verwendest, macht eigentlich kein
großer Unterschied. Das ist alles unter der Haube das Gleiche.
Äh, ich verwende... Ich habe ursprünglich,
Chromium verwendet, weil es kein
Chromecast unterstützt.
Das war die einzige... Das war der einzige Grund, warum ich damals
Chromium angefangen habe.
Weil ich nicht aus Versehen Sachen
streamen wollte ins Wohnzimmer.
Wenn man sich
verklickt. Man konnte in einem der...
Als Chromecast, äh, noch, ähm...
Ja, also diese Chromecast-Funktion
war früher ziemlich einfach,
sich zu missklicken bei einem Video.
Das wollte ich nicht.
Hahaha. Der Chat...
Der Chat vermutet schon wieder, dass das...
Nimmst du ja gleich.
So, ähm, zumindest...
Die haben einen Buffer... Buffer-Overflow
oder sowas gehabt, wenn sie...
ähm, PNGs rendern.
Und jetzt könnt ihr euch überlegen,
also, wie passt das zusammen?
Warum muss eine Library...
Chat, und ihr kommt bestimmt drauf, weil ich weiß,
wir sind BigBrainChat. Es gab heute
auch schon ein paar Subs, und wir wissen ja, dass mit jedem Sub,
der IQ, also der Durchschnitts-IQ des Chats
ansteigt. Ähm,
wann muss denn eine Library,
die für Schrift zuständig ist,
PNGs rendern? Habt ihr da eine Idee?
Emojis, richtig.
Genau.
Korrekt. So sieht's aus.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Kengin, 5 Monat,
danke schön für den Sub. Excellent.
Emojis, und es ging nicht...
Es ging um Embedded...
Es ging um PNGs, die Embedded
in Schriftarten sind.
Und das wird unter anderem für
Color-Emojis verwendet.
Supportig, Twitch Prime, danke schön für den Sub.
Und, äh, übrigens, das ist auch ein Thema,
wo ich mich, äh,
lange drüber auskotzen könnte.
Es gibt,
mindestens,
mindestens, äh, sehr gut, dass
du's fragst, XtraManiaGamer,
es gibt mindestens vier verschiedene
Varianten, wie farbige Emojis
funktionieren. Es gibt
den, das Format von, äh,
Adobe, es gibt das Format von Microsoft,
es gibt das Mozilla-Format, und es gibt
wahrscheinlich das Google-Format.
Ich glaub, das sind, das sind die vier.
Ähm...
Also sprich, es
gibt vier verschiedene Ansätze,
wie man Color-Emojis machen kann, oder was?
Facebook... Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich meine nicht verschiedene Emoji-Typen.
Ich meine wirklich Formate,
wie das gespeichert wird.
Und ein Format sind Embedded-PNGs.
Deswegen ist
ja auch das Problem, dass, ähm,
manche Anwendungen,
manche Sachen unter unterschiedlichen
Betriebssystemen unterschiedlich funktionieren, was
Color-Emojis angeht. Also es ist nicht so,
es, also gerade, äh, Emoji-Support
in Fonts ist eine sehr
plattformspezifische Geschichte.
Und eines der Formate ist Embedded,
Embedded, äh,
PNGs. Hier, genau.
Die da gibt's. Ach nee, Apple war's. Hier, guck.
Genau. Das, das, das gibt's.
Hier. Hier steht's.
ArchWiki, eh das Beste.
Genau. Also diese verschiedenen Emoji
Fonts,
also das sind nicht
unterschiedliche Emoji Fonts, also
es geht nicht um das Aussehen der Emojis,
da sind verschiedene Formate,
wie man Informationen
speichern kann, wie Emojis aussehen.
Wie die dann im Endeffekt
die Bilder aussehen, ist wieder was anderes. Das ist
die Art und Weise, wie die
Informationen gespeichert werden.
Sondern es gibt dann die Variante von
Google, die Variante von Apple,
sind auch Embedded
PNGs, es gibt die Variante von Microsoft
und von Mozilla
Adobe, das sind SVGs.
Also man sieht schon mal, es ist wieder
unendlich wirr,
wie so ein Color Emoji auf den
Bildschirm kommt. Die haben natürlich dann
auch so griffige Namen, wie
Zimtl, Zimtlz,
cbdt,
cblc, alles klar.
So.
Und
irgendwas davon verwendet
Embedded Emojis, fragt mich nicht.
Und Freetype, Freetype
kann sie halt alle.
Freetype kann sie halt irgendwie alle
und deswegen verwenden die viele Freetype.
Ja, wie gesagt, so richtig
im Detail habe ich mich damit nie beschäftigt.
Und das konnte halt dazu
führen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
dass wenn du auf eine Webseite gegangen bist,
leider gibt es da noch keine Details,
die eben manipulierte
Emoji
Geschichten hinterlegt haben
oder so, Emoji Webfonds mit
Embedded PNGs, dass es
dann einen Buffer Overflow gegeben hat
in Freetype und du konntest Sachen
auf dem jeweiligen Rechner außerhalb der
Browser-Sandbox ausführen.
Nein, das muss nicht jeder Browser implementieren,
dafür gibt es ja sowas wie Freetype.
Freetype ist eine Font-Library, die das
macht und der Bug war
ja auch nicht in Chrome, sondern in Freetype.
Allerdings, nachdem
Chrome quasi Freetype
mitbringt in Version XY, ist
Chrome davon auch betroffen. Und gerade
Browser sind von sowas immer besonders
betroffen, weil
der Browser so ziemlich das einzige
Programm ist, was man auf dem Rechner hat, was permanent
Code ausführt,
der unbekannt ist.
Also ein Browser ist ja nichts,
führt ja quasi nie
irgendwas
aus, was ihr programmiert habt. Ein Browser führt
den ganzen Tag unbekannten Code
irgendwie aus und das möglichst sicher.
Deswegen ist es eh erstaunlich und beeindruckend,
wie sicher Browser mittlerweile sind.
Es gibt kaum noch richtige große
Browsersicherheitslücken.
Also schon noch ab und zu, so wie hier jetzt, aber
selten und auch nicht mehr in dem
Ausmaß, wie das das früher gegeben hat.
Also es ist, das ist auch
sowas, wo die normalen Leute sagen,
Alter, es kann doch nicht so schwierig sein, warum
haben denn Browser immer so viele Sicherheitslücken?
Naja, weil der Browser das erste ist, was
eine Internetseite trifft,
und immer was ausgeführt
wird, was nicht verifiziert ist vorher.
Und
es ist echt schon beeindruckend, wie sicher Browser
und gerade Chrome und Firefox mittlerweile sind.
So, und hier gibt es wohl noch
irgendwelche Details, aber das will ich mir jetzt nicht so
äh, hier gibt es
Freetide-Patches, alles klar, exzellent.
Heap Buffer Overflow
Sicherheitslücke, alles klar.
Enload
Sbit PNG, das ist die Funktion.
Das ist die Funktion,
und die haben einen Heap Buffer Overflow,
weil sie irgendwelche
Zahlen abschneiden oder so.
Das will ich mir jetzt nicht so sehen.
Ach du große Kacke!
Okay,
man kann es auch übertreiben.
Das müsste ich mir jetzt mal
eine Weile angucken, bis ich das kapiere.
Das kann ich nicht so aus dem Ärmel schütteln.
Also, die Sicherheitslücke gibt es
in der Funktion Load Sbit PNG,
wenn
PNG-Images in Embedded Fonts
verarbeitet werden.
Was zum Beispiel bei Emojis
passieren kann.
Und dann geht es kaputt.
Exzellent.
Ja, das ist
tatsächlich mal eine ziemlich schwerwiegende
Sicherheitslücke gewesen.
Wenn du dir vorstellst, du kannst einfach irgendeinen manipulierten Webfont
oder sonst was nehmen und dann
dort Code ausführen auf dem
Rechner des
Browser-Benutzers,
ist schon Kacke.
Deswegen ist es gerade auch besonders,
wo wir wieder, haben wir nicht letztens ein Video
geguckt, haben wir nicht letztens ein Video
geguckt, wo irgendein Dude erzählt hat,
er verwendet noch Windows 7,
obwohl es nicht mehr gepatcht wird,
weil sein Browser ist ja sicher.
Haben wir nicht letzten Sonntag so ein Video
geguckt, wo ich schon gesagt habe,
letzten Sonntag so ein Schwachsinn?
Genau daran sieht man, dass es wichtig ist,
dass sein Betriebssystem gepatcht ist,
weil wenn sein Browser mal ein Problem hat,
was ja hier jetzt nun vorkommt,
das erste, was passiert ist,
die können Code ausführen,
im Kontext hier dieses,
ich weiß nicht, ob es vielleicht sogar noch
in der Sendbox ist, dass nichts passiert,
aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen,
außerhalb der Browser-Sendbox ist,
rate ich jetzt einfach mal,
ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht,
und das heißt, du bist erstmal Account gebunden
an diesen Account,
unter dem der Browser läuft.
So, und dieser Account hat keine Adminberechtigung,
aber hast du jetzt ein ungepatchtes Windows 7,
wo es bekannte Sicherheitslücken
gibt, wie man beispielsweise Adminrechte
bekommen kann, dann ist der nächste Schritt
zu, ich habe deinen PC übernommen, ziemlich einfach.
Da muss der Hacker noch nicht mal
richtig krasser Hackerman sein,
sondern in ein paar Monaten gibt es da
fertige Sachen,
die ich auf meinem Webserver
kopieren kann und habe
auf einmal ein russisches Botnetz
am Start, so nach dem Motto.
Das geht immer relativ schnell, wie es da sowas gibt.
Da muss ich noch nicht mal großartig
Hacker-Typ sein.
Ich muss einfach nur lang genug warten,
bis das andere für mich erledigt haben,
und wenn ich dann noch genug Leute finde,
mit ungepatchtem Windows, ungepatchtem Browser,
dann habe ich halt Glück.
Und der Pech. So sieht er aus.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt?
How does Minecraft make money?
Ich will jetzt irgendwas anderes gucken.
Battlefield Top Place.
Reale Irrsinn. Nicht bestellt, trotzdem geliefert.
Geliefert von Amazon. Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Wenn der Postmann zweimal klingelt,
und dann nochmal,
und nochmal,
dann klingelt er bei Pascal Pieper
aus Bremen.
Ich bekomme ständig von Amazon
Pakete, die ich weder bestellt,
noch bezahlt habe, und es geht mir mit.
Ist doch geil! Könnt ihr das bei mir auch machen?
Ich nehme sie. Ich nehme sie alle.
Mittlerweile tierisch auf die Nerven.
Ja okay, ich verstehe, dass es ihm auf den Sack geht,
aber ich nehme sie. Ich nehme sie alle.
So denn. Pakete kriegen ist doch eine packende
Angelegenheit.
Free stuff, never sub, never donated,
free entertainment,
neighbors, wifi,
oder wie auch immer.
Ich habe am Tag bis zu zwölf Pakete
von drei verschiedenen Paketboten,
die morgens bis abends klingeln.
Das geht schon seit anderthalb Monaten so,
und irgendwann ist es auch vorbei.
Am Anfang fand ich es noch witzig,
aber mittlerweile ist es einfach viel zu viel.
Tja, jeder hat sein Päckchen zu tragen.
Und Herr Pieper eben noch ein paar mehr.
Geschickt und eingefädelt
von chinesischen Händlern aus
der Amazon Marketplace.
Die Chinesen wieder.
Oh Leute, ich habe das böse Wort gesagt.
Jetzt kriege ich wieder Antworten
auf Twitter. Ich bin
ultra Rassist, weil ich Chinese gesagt habe.
Hatten wir letztens erst.
Und die Verbraucherzentrale Nordrhein-Westfalen
liefert eine mögliche
Erklärung dazu.
Händler leeren
angeblich so kostengünstig
ihr gemietetes Lager bei Amazon.
Statt Unverkauftes teuer
wieder in China zu verschiffen,
schicken sie es einfach wahllos an
willkürlich ausgepickte Adressen
aus Deutschland.
Was? Ernsthaft?
Die können ruhig meine
Adresse willkürlich auswählen.
Vollkommen okay.
Die Chinesen
sind clever. Das muss man echt mal
sagen.
Die Chinesen sind schon echt big brain.
Es ist ja echt so.
Der Kram kostet wahrscheinlich viel mehr,
wenn die das zurückschicken.
Ja, so ein
Missgeschickt kann schon mal passieren.
Dafür darf Herr Pieper
speziell behalten,
was in seinen Paketen drin ist
und hat jetzt einen Haufen
nützlicher Dinge zu Hause.
Das meiste ist wirklich Rotz.
Halloween-Deko
ziemlich viel.
Ein sexy Kimono.
Kinderspielzeug.
Krampfader-Creme
für meine Krampfader-
Die brauch ich auch.
Gib die Krampfader-Creme.
Halsbänder.
Mega-Rave-Handschuhe.
Eine Projektionslampe
für die Decke.
So ein Bug-Zapper,
mit dem ich Tiere töten kann.
Fünf von diesen
Babysocken,
in die man angeblich Babys reinstecken kann.
Amazon bietet zwar
die Plattform für die Händler,
kann aber laut eigener Aussage nur begrenzt
in die Geschicke eingreifen.
Warum nehmen Sie denn noch Pakete an, Herr Pieper?
Ich nehme noch Pakete an,
weil der Kundendienst
bei Amazon Prime gesagt hat,
dass nur so...
Warum nehme ich noch Pakete an,
weil's free stuff ist?
...nachvollziehen können,
wo die Leute herkommen,
also welche Händlerprofile das sind.
Gebracht hat das, äh, nichts.
War das ein Fieber-Thermometer gerade?
Welche Händlerprofile das sind?
Also ich glaube,
ein chinesisches Fieber-Thermometer
würde ich nicht verwenden.
Gebracht hat das, äh, nichts.
Ein Fieber-Thermometer, oder?
Elegant!
Das elegante... äh, exquisite.
Also in China
Fieber-Thermometer muss man in Bobbes schieben.
Zumindest kein AliExpress Fieber-Thermometer.
Nichts.
Tja, blöd. Herr Pieper, Sie sind leider...
Achso, das könnte
ein Temperaturmesser
für, äh, wenn ich
Braten mache oder so sein. Könnte auch sein, ja.
Ausgeliefert.
Es muss ein Ende haben, auf jeden Fall.
Es ist voll, ja.
Ja, ja. Hat eben nicht jeder so...
Ihr Big-Brain-Hochkant, äh,
Computer-Bildschirm.
Ja, hauptsache, hauptsache viele Emo...
What the fuck?
Der hat nen
Bildschirm-Hochkant, dass er alle Emojis
anzeigen kann? Das ist mal was!
Big Brain!
Das ist ne coole
Sache, ey! Wenn man den ganzen Tag
am chatten ist, ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Was ist denn das?
Erkennt das jemand, was das ist?
Was ist das für nen Chat?
Ist das Skype? Was ist das?
Telegram? Whatsapp?
Ne, Telegram, hä?
Telegram. Chat. Ja, okay, der Chat weiß.
Chat kennt sich aus. Telegram ist das.
Telegram und erstmal davon
30% für Emojis. So
muss man's machen. Wir können nur hoffen, dass
der aktuelle Chrome-Version hat.
Ja, ordentliches Bench-Power-Supply
und sonst was. Alle möglichen
Sachen. In der Wendler-Gruppe.
Genau.
Was sonst?
Jeder so ein Sendungsbewusstsein wie sie.
Huch?
Sie haben Post?
Doch nice!
Ist doch nice!
Also ich würd's sofort nehmen.
Und wisst ihr, was ich machen würde, wenn ich
das bekommen würde?
Ich würd mir so nen Paketsack
oder zwei Paketsäcke ans
Hoftor machen. Und ein Schild dran,
dass die alle ihre Sachen in den
Paketsack schmeißen sollen.
Das würd ich dann im Stream auspacken und testen.
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Aber es gibt
so nen Paketsack.
Paketsack?
MeinPaketsack.de
Alles klar.
Äh...
Da passt doch gar nix rein.
Und außerdem...
Wie funktioniert denn das?
Das war viel zu klein. Da passt doch nix rein.
MeinPaketsack. Okay, das
müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Ach so ist...
Ach so funktioniert
das!
Aha!
Das kapiert mein Zusteller nicht.
Die sind meistens
schnittfest, die Dinger.
Also das kapiert der Amazon-Zusteller schon mal nicht.
Die Amazon-Zusteller
sind eh
nicht unbedingt die...
mit dem größten Brain.
Okay.
Die Sprecher klingen
immer so super hyped
und glücklich.
Aber gut, würde ich auch machen.
Warum soll ich da einen hinsetzen, der sagt
Ah, jetzt bekomm ich schon wieder ein Paket.
Was mach ich mit dem Kack?
Also dann ist so ein Sprecher schon besser.
Das kapiert der nicht.
Also...
Äh...
Das...
Also...
Wenn ich da gerade an die
Amazon-Zusteller...
Das kapieren die nicht.
Ich mein,
die Amazon-Zusteller bei mir,
die können da ja auch jetzt
wenig für.
Das sind jetzt nur so
Das sind jetzt nicht die
hochqualifizierten.
Das sind halt die, die billig sind.
Und die, die eh keine Zeit haben, was zu machen.
Weil die Sache ist die,
Amazon macht das ja nicht direkt.
Amazon hat irgendeinen Subunternehmer,
der einen Subunternehmer hat und der fährt ein Auto
mit einem Amazon-Aufkleber drauf.
Und die haben keine Zeit und keinen Bock.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Allerdings, ich hab jetzt schon ein paar Mal probiert
zu kommunizieren
mit dem Amazon-Paketlieferer.
Ich bin dabei, mit dem ich mich
auf so einem Zwischending auf
Deutsch und Englisch unterhalten konnte.
Das funktioniert schlecht.
Und deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass sowas hier
mit denen funktioniert.
Das macht er im Leben nicht.
Im Leben nicht macht er das.
Das niemals, nie.
Nie macht er das, nie.
Also,
den DHL-Mann, der immer
der gleiche ist,
dem kann ich
das vielleicht noch erklären.
Aber
den 50 verschiedenen Amazon-
Zustellern kann ich das nicht erklären.
Also Amazon macht das ohne
ohne Unterschrift bei mir.
Dem DHL-Mann
könnte ich es noch erklären. Das sind immer die gleichen.
Aber bei Amazon gibt es
einen random Pool aus 50 Fahrern
oder so.
Und gerade, dass du das aufmachen musst
und dann wieder zumachen.
Und außerdem, wie ist das?
Guck mal, du brauchst sogar noch ein Schloss dafür.
Im Leben nicht.
Das klappt nicht.
Leute, das klappt nicht.
... wenn schon ein Paket drin liegt.
Den Code dazu trägst du beim Online-Shopping
einfach in dein Adressfeld ein.
Mein Paketsack hat
Platz für alle Pakete in den gängigen
Größen und ein Fassungsvermögen
von bis zu 220 Litern.
Im Leben nicht.
Das klappt, das klappt nie.
Das ist eine gute Idee,
aber das scheitert daran, dass die
Pakets, die machen nicht mit.
Übrigens, super
sicheres Ding hier oben.
... entnommen hast, kannst du ihn ganz einfach
wieder zusammenfalten.
Niemals, nie.
Okay, okay, okay.
Bitte alle Pakete in
meinen Paketsack ablegen.
Da sagt der Amazon-Lieferant,
nee, ich nehm's einfach wieder mit.
Oder ich schmeiß es übers Tor.
Das macht Amazon bei uns auch ganz gerne.
Please put all my
packages
in my parcel bag.
Dann kommt's in Französisch.
Dann kommt's in Türkisch.
Oder?
Dann in Polnisch.
Oder sowas.
Und das da unten, was ist das?
In Italienisch.
Und dann noch in Arabisch.
Oh ja, unbedingt. Na gut.
Es orientiert sich halt
an dem, was verbreitet ist.
Ich vermute mal,
dass das Arabisch unten drunter ist.
Ah, Nele, genau.
Deine Nachbarn erhalten Infopostkarten,
die wir mitliefern.
Was geht das
meinen Nachbarn an,
ob ich da einen Paketsack an meiner Tür hab?
Die wir mitliefern.
Paketsack ist universell montierbar.
Egal ob an Haus- und Wohnungstüren
oder an der Hauswand,
an Pfosten oder Geländern.
Mit dem Türmontageset ist er auch
ideal für Mietwohnungen.
Das klappt nicht.
Schau dir die verschiedenen Varianten
von meinpaketsack auf
meinpaketsack.de an
und verpasse nie...
Wer hätte auch nur denken können,
dass man sich die unterschiedlichen Varianten
von meinpaketsack auf
meinpaketsack.de anschauen kann.
... wieder ein Paket.
Mein Paketsack füllt die Lücke
zwischen bequemem Online-Shopping
und nervigen Abholbenachrichtigungen.
Das klappt nie.
Nie klappt das.
Das ist die Sicherheit.
Wie ist das?
Alle Pakete sicher verwandt.
Wasser, die Safe von meinpaketsack
ist auch sicher.
Veröffnungsversuche mit Messern.
Ok, es ist...
Ok, kostet.
Wäre ok.
Ich mein, das ist ganz schön teuer
für einen Sack.
Aber für einen Sack mit einem Schloss,
den du wahrscheinlich in 2 Sekunden offen hast.
Aber...
Die machen...
Wie gesagt,
meinem DHL-Zusteller könnte ich das erklären.
Aber spätestens bei...
Bei Hermes auch noch.
Das sind auch meistens die gleichen.
Aber spätestens sollte mal doch was von DPD kommen
oder von GLS oder von Amazon.
Die machen das einfach nicht.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
die schmeißen das auch ein.
Also ich hab's schon geschafft bei Amazon,
dass die das zugestellt haben.
Ich hab's geschafft.
Ich war einfach nicht da.
Zugestellt an Briefkasten.
DHL hat ne eigene Box.
Ja, die Telekom hatte auch mal ne eigene Paketbox.
Das Problem ist nur,
dann bräuchtest du ja wieder 5 verschiedene
Paketsäcke von
unterschiedlichen Anbietern.
Das Sinnvollste ist sowas hier,
was für alle gilt.
Aber das scheitert daran, dass das die...
Ich hab echt
riesen Zweifel, dass
da die meisten Paketzusteller mitmachen.
Amazon-Paketsack.
Haben die auch sowas?
Hat Amazon auch sowas?
Amazon hat Paketstationen, ja.
Das weiß ich.
Amazon locker.
Ja, da muss ich mal schauen.
Vielleicht ist das echt ne Option,
die Sachen an die Paketstationen liefern zu lassen.
Naja, gut. Schauen wir mal weiter.
Was haben wir sonst noch schönes hier?
Können wir ne Battlefield-Top-Place
gucken? Das haben wir geguckt.
25 Home-Automation-Ideas.
Das letzte Mal haben wir Teil 1 geguckt.
Das war eigentlich ein ziemlich gutes Video.
Haben wir das letzte Mal
25 oder?
Oder haben wir das
das letzte Mal schon geguckt?
Oder haben wir das letzte Mal Teil 1
geguckt? Ich bin mir da jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher.
Wo ist Part 1?
Volume 1.
Ne, ich glaub wir haben Volume 1 geguckt.
Ja, das haben wir geguckt. Der Typ mit seiner
Garage.
Genau, das haben wir das letzte Mal geguckt.
Dann gucken wir jetzt Teil 2.
Das ist auch so ein Channel, den hab ich erst in letzter Zeit
entdeckt. Der hat wirklich ganz gute
Ideen, was Heimautomatisierung angeht.
Und auch ganz gute Tests,
was Lampen
und sowas angeht. Die anderen Sachen
sind ein bisschen ziemlich Kokona
bezogen, weil bei den Amis
kannst du halt
Schalter in die Wand sägen und sowas.
Das funktioniert hier halt nicht wirklich.
Also, wenn ihr euch beispielsweise mal
diese Schalter anguckt.
Das funktioniert
bei uns nicht.
Das ist einfach so die typische
Kokona-Wand hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
What the fuck?
Also, das funktioniert halt bei meiner
Wand hier nicht.
Im Freedomland
funktioniert das.
Es ist 11.53 Uhr.
Guckt, das sind alles so Kokona-Switche.
Das funktioniert bei uns nicht.
Wenn ihr euch das schon anguckt,
das kannst du im Leben nicht bei uns einbauen.
Also, das kannst du vergessen.
Das ist halt Kokona-Technologie.
Aber
die anderen Sachen, die da
getestet sind, sind echt ganz interessant.
Zum Beispiel auch die Smart Bulbs.
Also, die RGB-Lampen und
dimmbaren Lampen und so.
Ich habe mir beispielsweise
jetzt zwei
zwei Lampen gekauft.
RGB-Lampen.
Weil ich sie bei ihm im Video
gesehen habe.
Ich habe ja in letzten Streams immer wieder gesagt,
ich habe kaum Automatisierung
gemacht, was Licht angeht.
Ich bin gerade dabei, ein bisschen zu experimentieren,
was man so machen könnte.
Sagt, ob es laut genug ist.
Okay, Amazon Smart, also
Smart Assistants,
die alles aufzeichnen,
stelle ich mir nicht hin.
In einem Artikel, Link unten.
Übrigens, was wir letzte Woche erfahren haben, ist,
die Telekom, falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet,
die Telekom hat auch einen
Smart Assistent Speaker,
also sowas wie Alexa und Echo Dot
und sowas bei Amazon.
Das nennt sich
Magenta,
ich glaube Magenta Speaker
sogar. Und wisst ihr, was man
sagen muss, um das anzusteuern?
Man sagt, bei Amazon ist ein
Alexa, bei anderen ist es Siri und Google.
Man muss bei der Telekom sagen,
Hey Magenta!
Das ist schon so cringe und Fremdschämen,
das
würde ich im Leben nicht verwenden.
Das ist ein Baro, das stimmt aber.
Das ist wirklich Hey Magenta.
Oh, es gibt
längere, bevor wir das gucken, es gibt noch längere Fragen
im Chat, wie es aussieht.
Also, mein Bruder und ich machen gerade
einen Game Server.
Wahrscheinlich Minecraft oder sowas.
So der Klassiker.
Für viele Leute, die sich selbst
hosten irgendwo.
Dazu brauchen wir einen MySQL Server
und einen Web Server mit PHP.
Um SQL Abfragen zu machen.
Ich habe als Web Server
Nginx genommen.
Nginx ist top, kann man nichts mit falsch machen.
Aber je nachdem, was ihr machen wollt,
kann man es auch viel einfacher haben.
Was sagst du zu Nginx?
Zweite Frage, wartet mal kurz.
Ich juckts am Ohr.
Muss das Headset kurz abziehen.
Zweite Frage,
wenn ich vor dem Game Server
und Web Server ein Reverse Proxy Firewall
hängen will, was soll ich da nehmen?
PFSense?
Ne, weder noch.
Also, ich würde einfach
die eingebaute Ubuntu
Firewall nehmen, UFW.
Einfach UFW
allow ssh
UFW
enable und UFW
default deny.
Und dann kann eh nichts mehr
drauf zugreifen von außen auf den Server.
Es sei denn, du machst irgendwelche Docker-Geschichten,
dann muss man ein bisschen genauer gucken, weil
das geht an UFW vorbei.
Dann muss man ein paar Sachen einfügen,
dass das funktioniert.
Also ich würde erst mal UFW einschalten.
So wie ich das im vorletzten Stream oder so gemacht habe.
Erst mal UFW einschalten.
Und damit ist der ganze Firewall Aspekt schon mal
außen vor. Da brauchst du keinen PFSense
davor oder sowas, das ist totaler Overkill.
Dann
würde ich generell
vor die ganze Geschichte in den Reverse-Proxy
stellen, der
einmal Let's Encrypt
SSL-Zertifikate für mich macht
und der vor alles
irgendwie einen Basic Auth oder sowas macht.
Das nicht random Sachen
im Internet hängen, die man da nicht hängen haben will.
So und
da kannst du auch den nginx für verwenden.
Du kannst auch
ich persönlich mag den hier am liebsten.
Der ist schön einfach. Fünf Zeilen
Eintrag und es funktioniert.
Aber wie gesagt mit nginx und so,
kann man eigentlich wenig verkehrt machen.
Die Sache ist nur die,
also die Frage ist, muss es PHP
sein, wenn du eh einen
Hetzner Server hast?
Also es sei denn, ihr habt was, was halt in PHP
programmiert ist, dann
ansonsten kannst du auch irgendwas anderes nehmen.
Und nachdem ihr eh schon einen Reverse-Proxy davor
habt, brauchst du auch nicht noch einen extra
Webserver, sondern kannst eigentlich
zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt
ein .NET Programm machen würdest,
dann kannst du einfach .NET starten
und dein Reverse-Proxy auf den
internen .NET Webserver loadbalancen
lassen, ohne dass du einen extra Webserver
brauchst. PHP hat bestimmt auch einen eingebauten
Webserver. Python hat bestimmt auch eine eingebauten Geschichte.
Dann
brauchst du nicht noch einen nginx irgendwie
dazwischen. Wobei ich keine Ahnung habe, wie es mit
PHP ist. Also wenn es irgendeine
Game Engine gibt, die keine SQL-Abfragen
machen kann, dann frage ich mich, was das für ein Kram ist.
Weil im Zweifelsfall gibt's
doch sicherlich irgendwelche Schnittstellen, dass man das machen
naja gut.
Achso!
Was?
Ihr baut ein eigenes
Game, was dort im Backend
läuft?
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich's!
Jetzt verstehe ich's!
Ah, nee, nee, nee, das würde ich anders machen.
Also, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist,
ihr verwendet
irgendeine Programmiersprache, sagen wir jetzt mal,
und diese Game Engine hier,
und ihr wollt SQL-Abfragen machen.
Und weil ihr quasi nicht wisst,
wie man aus dieser Game Engine, was ist denn das?
C? C++? C Sharp?
Was ist das? Go?
Keine Ahnung. Wie man da SQL-Abfragen
macht, wollt ihr Web-Requests machen.
Und die
Web-Requests sollen euch Sachen
aus einer Datenbank zurück
liefern. Das würde ich ganz anders machen.
Das ist eine ziemliche
Krücke, das würde ich nicht machen.
Also, wenn man es relativ easy machen
will, ohne Web-Server, dann nimmst du ein Postgres
mit GraphQL davor.
So.
Das ist die eine Geschichte.
Das ist dann quasi eine Datenbank,
die direkt schon eine Web-Schnittstelle hat,
wo ich abfragen kann.
Wenn ich wirklich über den Umweg
von Web-Geschichten
gehen will, dann würde ich
Postgres mit GraphQL davor nehmen.
Das ist out of the box ein fertiges Ding
und funktioniert.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass es nicht möglich ist,
aus einer Game Engine
oder irgendwie hier
Abfragen zu machen gegenüber
einer Datenbank, weil
die läuft ja
mit irgendwas.
Es gibt zig C++-Libraries,
Go-Libraries, was auch immer,
für Datenbankzugriff. Das würde mich sehr wundern,
wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Und wenn ihr wirklich Web-Requests machen müsst,
dann würde ich es, wie gesagt, nicht über den Umweg
von PHP-Skript, was in die Datenbank geht,
nehmen, sondern irgendwas
wie zum Beispiel Postgres
und GraphQL zusammen.
Wie heißt denn das?
Postgres Elephant oder so?
War das das?
Ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Also Postgres ist
neben MySQL
die meistverbreiteste Datenbank, die es gibt.
Und ich habe letztens was
Schönes gesehen. Das war ein GraphQL
Frontend für Postgres.
Und ich bin...
War das das hier sogar?
Ich müsste mir das noch einmal im Detail angucken.
Ich habe es noch nie verwendet,
aber ich habe es letztens gesehen und habe mir gedacht,
ey, das ist ein richtig cooles Projekt,
was man braucht.
GraphQL ist quasi
so ein bisschen
SQLite
ohne so richtig
SQL zu sein
über HTTP.
Und deswegen bietet sich das an,
wenn man das denn über den Umweg
von irgendeiner Web-Schnittstelle machen will,
das mit GraphQL zu machen.
Da müsst ihr mal genauer gucken.
Irgendwas mit Elephant hieß das doch, oder?
War es nicht Elephant?
Also das ist das Logo von denen.
War das das da?
Ne, das war irgendein Anbieter.
Ich bilde mir ein, das hieß
dieses GraphQL Frontend.
Müssen wir mal nachgucken.
Ich kann es euch ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht sagen.
Aber mich würde es sehr wundern, wenn man
nicht direkt Abfragen machen kann
gegenüber einer Datenbank.
Nein, nein, nein.
GraphQL ist
eine webbasierte
Abfragesprache.
Du kannst das ohne
Probleme gegen jede x-beliebige Datenbank
machen, wenn du einen Adapter hast.
Also du kannst das gegen
SQLite machen, gegen
MySQL bestimmt auch, gegen Postgres.
Aber Postgres ist ganz schön.
Habe ich zumindest letztens was drüber gelesen,
dass du quasi so
das mehr oder weniger so out of the box
fertig konfiguriert
kriegst, dass du Postgres mit
GraphQL mit ein paar
drei, vier Schritten quasi starten kannst
und es funktioniert.
Theoretisch auch gegen Excel, wenn du
was programmierst, was das übersetzt.
Das geht auch.
Das muss man sich auch mal im Detail
angucken. Das habe ich so noch nicht gemacht.
Wäre vielleicht auch mal was.
Ähm, ist jemand stehen geblieben?
Ah, hier.
Das ist doch echt Overkill, oder?
Ich meine, das erste finde ich cool.
Das erste finde ich cool.
Wenn er aufwacht, dass dann quasi Sonnenaufgang
simuliert wird.
Es gäbe natürlich auch noch die Möglichkeit,
den echten Sonnenaufgang
durch das Fenster
reinzulassen.
Aber das wäre glaube ich zu oldschool.
Also ich meine, wenn man die Auswahl hat
zwischen echtem Sonnenaufgang
und RGB-Sonnenaufgang,
was nimmt man dann?
Also, ich bin eindeutig für RGB-Sonnenaufgang.
Wer braucht echten Sonnenaufgang?
Und außerdem ist zu der Zeit,
wo du aufstehst, natürlich nicht unbedingt
der rechte Sonnenaufgang. Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Sowas habe ich mir auch überlegt,
ob ich das nicht machen soll.
Ich habe mir zwei RGB-Lämpchen gekauft.
Das habe ich mir auch wirklich überlegt,
ob ich das nicht machen soll.
Wisst ihr, was natürlich richtig
Big Brain wäre?
Was richtig Poggers wäre?
Man müsste einfach eine Automation machen,
die quasi checkt,
die über eine Web-API abruft,
wann Sonnenaufgang ist.
Wenn Sonnenaufgang ist,
15 Minuten vorher,
bei der Outdoor-Kamera
den Sonnenaufgang
recorded,
und wenn du dann aufstehst,
spielt es dir den echten Sonnenaufgang
vor deiner Haustür
um 11 Uhr auf deinem Display
neben deinem Bett ab.
Das wäre doch mal was.
Das ist doch mal Next Level
Big Brain Automation.
Wer braucht RGB-Sonnenaufgang,
wenn er echten Sonnenaufgang recorded haben kann
auf seinem Display?
Und dann dazu noch RGB machen.
Und wenn es bewölkt ist, ist halt der echte Sonnenaufgang.
und wenn es bewölkt ist, ist halt der echte Sonnenaufgang.
..
ob das sicher oder unsicher ist.
Das ist alles lokal auf eurem Server drauf.
Von außen kommt da doch eh keiner dran.
Da würde ich, ich würde das ganze Ding nicht mal mit Passwörtern schützen.
Wozu?
Du speicherst in deiner Datenbank ja eh nur Sachen von und dein Game State in irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Also quasi das, was du normalerweise im RAM hast, was du persistent speichern willst.
Das heißt, wozu irgendwelche Passwort-Authentifizierung, wenn es rein lokal ist?
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich eh komplett weglassen.
Also je nachdem.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch noch gar nicht richtig kapiert.
Mir ist aber noch was dazu eingefallen.
Es kann doch jede x-beliebige Programmiersprache C-Funktionen aufrufen.
Oder?
Also außer Go, die das nur um sich umwägen können.
Aber sonst kannst du zumindest von jeder x-beliebigen Programmiersprache externe C-Funktionen, FFI genau,
aufrufen.
Warum macht ihr nicht einfach eine Mini-C-Library oder eine C++-Library, meinetwegen, wenn es sein muss,
oder eine Go-Library oder irgendwas, was euch die passenden Funktionen als C-kompatible Sachen exportiert
und die ruft ihr auf aus eurer Game Engine.
Das muss gehen.
Du musst irgendwelche C-Funktionen callen können.
Also mir fällt quasi keine Programmiersprache, jetzt mal Brainfuck außen vor ein, die keine C-Funktionen callen kann.
Übrigens, Go kann das nicht.
Weil Go das um fünf Umwege macht, um es zu können.
Also Go kann es, aber nicht direkt.
Also wie gesagt, Leko, du müsstest das dann gar nicht einbauen und neu kompilieren.
Du kannst bestimmt, wie heißt das Ding?
What the fuck?
Irgendwie sowas hier.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich kenne mich damit null aus.
Aber du musst daraus externe Funktionen aufrufen können.
Was ist denn das sonst für eine Game Engine?
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es irgendeine Runtime, was auch immer gibt,
die nicht externe C-Funktionen aufrufen kann.
Das ist so die Basics der Basics eigentlich.
Was ja auch wichtig ist, weil sonst kannst du ja mit nichts anderem interagieren.
Das kannst du aus Python machen, aus Ruby, wahrscheinlich sogar aus Brainfuck mittlerweile.
Aber die einfachste Sache, wenn das alles nicht geht und du wirklich das über Webrequests machen musst,
was übrigens übelst lahm ist, ne?
Ja, also das mit PHP finde ich auch übelst der Hack.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Man muss ja auch sagen, Webrequests sind ultra langsam.
Ich meine, wenn du dir überlegst, so ein Function Call dauert ein paar Nanosekunden.
So ein Webrequest dauert, was weiß ich, mit allem drum und dran vielleicht mal 1-2 Millisekunden.
Das ist auch ein riesen Overhead, den man sich damit einfängt.
Aber ich kann dazu leider nicht wirklich viel sagen, weil ich habe weder diese Engine noch bisher verwendet,
noch weiß ich, was das für Restriktionen hat, noch habe ich das Problem so hundertprozentig erfasst.
Aber das mit Webrequests über einen PHP-Skript in die Datenbank hört sich eklig an.
So, also, oh, das will ich übrigens, das will ich mir auch noch machen, so was hier.
Das ist richtig Big Brain, was der hier jetzt treibt.
Also, ich finde, die Motivationsrede am Anfang auf einem Display ist bescheuert, das braucht kein Mensch.
Das ist cool, das hier ist total overkill.
Der Homehub startet automatisch ein motivatives YouTube-Video zu spielen, um mich für die...
Ich brauche kein Motivational-YouTube-Video morgens, wenn ich aufstehe.
Ich brauche keinen, der auf meinem Tablet morgens mir ins Ohr schreit,
schreit, do it, just do it.
Das muss echt nicht sein.
Die sollen mal alle ihre Klappe halten.
Nee, das muss nicht sein.
Das nächste, was er hier hat, finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Also das nächste ist cool.
Das hier, sowas will ich mir unbedingt auch noch unters Bett bauen.
Ich habe es mal mit einem Gewichtssensor probiert, aber das funktioniert nicht so genau.
Das ist so eine Matte, die erkennt, wenn Druck drauf ist.
Und damit kann man super Automations auslösen.
Zum Beispiel könnte man einen Schalter einbauen, quasi, es ist nach 22 Uhr
und das Bett ist belegt, länger als 15 Minuten.
Wenn ich jetzt noch vergessen habe, irgendwo was auszuschalten,
schaltet er automatisch aus, weil ich bin im Bett.
Also sowas will ich unbedingt auch noch einbauen.
Mal gucken, ob der die Matte verlinkt hat.
Hat er die Matte verlinkt?
Ja.
Oh, ich habe Bad Pleasure Sensor gelesen, da habe ich schon gedacht, what the fuck.
Wow, seid ihr noch bei Sinnen?
Warum ist der Scheiß so teuer?
Da ist es ja nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Also, ich weiß ja nicht, ich weiß ja nicht, wie das bei dir aussieht,
ob du 15 Minuten still auf der Matte liegst, ohne dich zu bewegen.
Aber wenn ja und es nach 22 Uhr ist,
dann geht der Geschirrspüler aus.
Das ist dann tatsächlich ein Problem.
So, äh, warte mal, wo sind wir denn jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, ich wollte diese, ich wollte diese, mal gucken, was die Matte kostet.
Du kannst ja auch, du kannst ja auch einen Bewegungssensor noch installieren,
der dann erkennt, wenn da, äh, wenn es da gerade zur Sache geht,
dann kannst du das ausschalten.
Sowas kostet sowas, gibt es das in Deutschland?
Wow, warum mit Nokia?
Das hat doch mit Nokia...
Da, äh, nix, nix zu tun.
Okay, das ist definitiv zu teuer.
Außerdem, das hier ist IT-Informatiker-Stream.
Das Problem haben die meisten Leute hier natürlich gar nicht.
Wenn die im Bett liegen, dann liegen die einfach im Bett, um zu schlafen.
Paper hands.
Äh, ähm, das ist ganz schön teuer.
True, sad girl.
Ähm, das ist ganz schön teuer.
Äh, äh, äh, äh.
Sleep-Sensor.
Net oder so.
Das gibt es doch garantiert billiger.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Das ist einfach nur ein langgezogener Drucksensor.
Das ist einfach nur...
So ein langgezogener Drucks...
Warum ist das so teuer?
What the fuck?
Ich geb...
Ich geb dir auch keine 120 Euro für so einen publichen Drucksensor aus.
Äh, nein.
Nein?
Körperwaage.
Da habe ich da, also
übrigens die Waage, die wir mal zusammen
im Stream eingerichtet
haben, die mit Bluetooth,
also diese, die über Bluetooth
die Sache,
die funktioniert seit einem halben Jahr
oder so ziemlich gut.
Blood Pressure Monitor.
Die wollen es jetzt aber echt wissen.
Das ist unglaublich
teuer. Oh, guck mal,
es ist 3 Euro reduziert.
Poggers, gleich kaufen.
Hat das Home Assistant
Integration?
Ah, das Home Assistant Integration.
Anscheinend.
Moment, Moment, Moment, was?
Ich brauche einen Account?
Ich brauche einen
Account bei den Chinesen
irgendwo oder was?
Dass das Ding erkennt,
ob ich im Bett bin?
Da fuck. Ne, das ist nämlich nicht.
Ach ne, okay, braucht man nicht.
Braucht man nicht.
Das ist Nokia. Es sind alles Chinesen
mittlerweile. Alles hängt da irgendwie
zusammen. Und wahrscheinlich läuft das
in der Alibaba Cloud oder so.
Okay,
es geht auch...
Warum brauche
ich irgendwelche Callbacks?
Das ist ein...
What the fuck?
Das ist ein Sensor im WLAN oder so,
der einfach funktionieren soll.
Ne, das auf Twitter
darf ich das gar keinen Fall sagen.
Ich bin einfach ein Drucksensor, genau.
Ich brauche keinen Online-Account.
Das muss ich mir mal im Detail angucken.
So, schauen wir mal weiter.
Was macht denn die?
Also so ein Ding, das steht bei mir auch auf jeden Fall
noch auf dem Plan.
Da bin ich die ganze Zeit schon so am gucken.
Ein Drucksensor für
das Bett.
Und was cool ist,
dass sogar das Gewicht noch erkennt.
Wobei das Gewicht nicht wirklich aussagekräftig ist,
wenn man so verteilt drauf liegt.
Aber zumindest kann ich den Unterschied erkennen,
ob ich drauf liege oder die Katz gerade im Bett rumhüpft.
Weil das wird das Ding kaum merken.
Habe ich absichtlich nicht gemacht?
Also ich habe mir auch schon überlegt,
ob ich nicht vielleicht meine...
Ich habe ja Tablets oben und unten im Flur hängen.
Ob ich die nicht auch morgens
irgendwas vorlesen lassen soll?
Also zum Beispiel Wetter oder nächsten Termin
oder sowas. Aber warum ich es nicht gemacht habe,
ist, weil ich weiß, ich erschrecke mich des Todes,
wenn ich durch den Flur laufe und an nichts denke
und auf einmal kommt eine Stimme von meinem Tablet.
Ich kriege einen heiligen Herzinfarkt.
Und deswegen habe ich das nicht gemacht.
Okay, da bin ich gerade dabei.
Das habe ich gerade, weil ich habe ja gerade angefangen mit...
Zigbee-Thermostaten an der Heizung.
Und Fenstersensor habe ich ja schon.
Also das funktioniert...
Im Wohnzimmer funktioniert das schon.
Wenn ich das Fenster aufmache, dass dann die Heizung ausgeht.
Oh, das ist cool.
Oh, das ist eine coole Idee.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Das gefällt mir.
Oh, das ist eine coole Idee.
Dazu muss man aber erstmal ein Workout machen.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Das gefällt mir echt.
Welche Sensoren hast du?
Ich habe Z-Wave...
Moment.
Ich zeige dir, ich habe Z-Wave...
Alter, AliExpress, geh weg.
Window, Door, Sensor.
Sensor.
Leben sie ihr bestes Leben?
Alles klar.
Weder noch.
Wo sind denn die überhaupt alle hin?
Irgendwie Coolcam oder so hießen die Dinger.
Habe ich mir mal bestellt.
Die Dinger habe ich.
Aber, wie gesagt, nicht kaufen, einfach so.
Ich habe die bestellt, als es die mal für 10 Dollar bei Banggood gab.
Das Stück.
10 Dollar das Stück konnte man machen, ansonsten viel zu teuer.
Da habe ich gleich...
äh, etwas größere Bestellungen getätigt.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz cool, dass es dir die Termine vorliest.
Okay, das bräuchte ich nicht.
Es ist schön, dass das nur für mich passiert und nicht für jemanden, der vor mir in den Raum kommt.
Ich benutze diese Dinger, um...
Äh, du wirst keine C-Wave-Window-Door-Sensoren finden, die 5 Euro kosten.
Und wenn, dann würde es mich mal interessieren, welches.
Achso, 5 für 50.
Äh, das ist okay.
Zeig mal.
Das ist okay.
Das ist ein guter Preis.
5 für 50 ist okay.
10 Euro pro Door-Sensor kann man ausgeben.
Natürlich wäre es besser, wenn es noch günstiger wäre, aber...
Ja.
Der Preis ist okay.
Scheint auch gerade ziemlich im Angebot sein.
Das kann man sich gönnen.
Was kostet denn der Versand?
Nehmen wir mal 3 Stück.
Dann haben wir 15 Stück.
Das reicht.
Kostet Versand was?
Kostenloser Versand auch noch.
Ja, wenn man ZigBee hat und ZigBee Aquara-Sensors verwenden kann, ist es okay.
Das ist tatsächlich ein ganz guter Deal.
Aber ich hatte damals nur C-Wave.
Wenn man ZigBee hat, kann man das auch damit machen.
Ja.
Man darf aber nicht vergessen, ZigBee ist auf der gleichen Frequenz oder ähnliche Frequenz
wie WLAN, C-Wave nicht.
Also deswegen finde ich C-Wave auch an sich die nettere Technologie.
Aber gerade was Thermostate angeht oder so, gibt es halt nur Müll.
Das ist tatsächlich recht günstig.
Also hätte ich nicht schon, hätte ich nicht schon meine Fenster und so damit ausgestattet,
ich würde mir das...
Ich würde mir das wahrscheinlich kaufen.
50 Euro für 5 Stück inklusive kostenlosem Versand ist nicht schlecht.
Gut, es ist AliExpress.
Man wartet einen Monat drauf.
Aber scheiß drauf, ja.
Guck mal.
2 kaufen, 1% bekommen.
Excellent.
Achso, man muss das anklicken, ne.
Guck mal, man kriegt sogar noch 1%.
Guck mal, man bekommt sogar noch 2%.
Das ist echt okay.
Keine 150 Euro, 15 Stück.
Und kein Versand.
Das ist echt nicht übel.
Schickt mal bitte einen Link hier.
Moin, Twinkor.
Ja, das ist gut hier.
Also, wenn ich nicht schon welche hätte, würde ich mir die wahrscheinlich holen.
Aber wie gesagt, das lohnt sich nur, wenn man eh schon C-Wave Sachen daheim hat.
Also wenn man keine C-Wave...
Das ist kein WLAN.
Also Achtung, ne.
Also wenn man das jetzt irgendwie über WLAN betreibt...
Oh Moment, es ist Z-Welle Plus.
Ja, alles klar.
Ach Moment, Warenkorb-Link.
Und ich hab das Falsche geschickt.
Mein Warenkorb-Link bringt dir wohl nicht allzu viel, denke ich mal.
Hier.
Da ist der, ist der...
Der Link dazu.
Um die Leute nicht zu verwirren, ich lösch mal meinen...
Kann ich meine eigene...
Ey, ich kann meine eigene Nachricht gar nicht löschen, oder?
Lol.
Ich wollte gerade meine Nachricht löschen, das geht nicht.
Dass ich die Leute nicht verwirre mit Warenkorb-Link, aber gut.
Ich kann auch meine eigene Message nicht löschen, das ist ja witzig.
Mal angenommen, ich hätte jetzt Mist im Chat geschrieben.
Wo ich nicht will, dass es jemand sieht.
Wie krieg ich meine eigene Message wieder weg?
Das ist tatsächlich mal eine interessante Frage.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Mich selbst bannen, genau.
Tja, interessant.
Keine Ahnung, wie ich meine eigene Message löschen kann.
Ist ja auch nicht wild.
Ist ja nichts Schlimmes.
Aber trotzdem.
Interessant, dass ich nicht meine eigene Message leeren kann.
Ja.
Und wie gesagt, das ist aber halt rein Z-Wave.
Das heißt, wenn man keinen Z-Wave aktuell im Einsatz hat, dann würde ich das nicht empfehlen.
Wenn ihr Zigbee habt, dann könnt ihr die Aqara Door Windows Sensors verwenden.
Die sind noch ein bisschen günstiger.
Die sind sogar noch einen Ticken günstiger.
Wenn ich sie aus Russland bestelle.
Bekommen wir uns am Start.
Also wenn ihr Zigbee habt, dann würde ich sowas hier nehmen.
Und über WLAN gibt es nichts Gescheites.
Und Z-Wave ist wie Zigbee.
Es ist ähnlich.
Es sind zwei unterschiedliche Protokolle.
Es sind unterschiedliche Leute für zuständig.
Aber vom Ansatz her sind die ähnlich.
Es sind beides zwei Protokolle für Heimautomatisierungs- oder für IoT-Geräte.
Und es sind beides Protokolle mit Mesh-Netzwerk.
Also sprich, umso mehr Geräte und umso mehr Basisstationen du hast, umso besser ist das Netzwerk.
Und es sind beides Sachen, die für Ultra-Low-Power-Geräte gedacht sind.
Und gerade solche Fenster-Tür-Sensoren möchte man ja auch, dass sie eine Weile halten.
Und ich will nicht nach einem halben Jahr überall das Ding.
Also ich habe jetzt welche, die sind drei Jahre alt und die Batterie geht immer noch.
Und das ist auch eine Zeitspanne, die ist okay.
Dann ab und zu mal Batterie wechseln.
So, und im Bereich WLAN gibt es da nichts, weil WLAN halt ein bisschen viel Strom braucht.
Deswegen gibt es bei den meisten WLAN-Geräten was, was halt nur maximal ein halbes Jahr oder so hält.
So, dann gucke ich jetzt nochmal schnell in den Chat, weil ich habe jetzt gerade gesehen,
dass jetzt gleich drei Fragen auf einmal kommen.
Hey Max, eine Frage.
Wie kann ich, wenn ich bei einem Debian-Server die Platte mit dem Bordmittel verschlüsselt habe,
wenn ich den Neustart über SSH das Encryption-Kennwort mitschicken?
Hast du es schon so eingerichtet, dass er dich, also hast du schon voll verschlüsselt,
dass er dich beim Booten fragt nach einem Passwort?
Dann brauchst du das hier.
Dann installierst du das hier.
Unter Debian installierst du das hier.
Also hier, das da, DropbyInit, RAMFS musst du installieren.
Und dann musst du, glaube ich, nur noch einmal dein Image updaten und es geht direkt.
Ich glaube, viel mehr musste man gar nicht machen.
Ich glaube, du musst dein SSH-Key noch hinkopieren.
Aber lese dir mal einen Guide dazu durch.
Das ist nicht schwierig.
Das haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal im Stream gemacht.
Also das ist das Paket, was du brauchst für Debian.
Das ist quasi ein SSH-Server.
Embedded in deinem Boot-Image.
Und dann kannst du dich per SSH einloggen und er fragt dich nach deinem Passwort.
Also hier, guck dir mal irgendwie so einen Guide da an.
Das ist nicht sonderlich kompliziert.
Ich habe gefunden, wie man auf C++ von der Engine aus zugreifen kann.
Kann dann C++ defaultmäßig...
Naja, also du hast in der C++-Standard-Library nichts drin für irgendwie MySQL-Libraries oder so.
Aber du kannst dir einfach irgendeine C++...
MySQL-Library nehmen und das damit machen.
Da gibt es mit Sicherheit jede Menge für.
Ach hier, guck mal.
Hier ist sogar das Link zum Watt.
Guck mal, hier haben wir es doch gemacht.
Oder auch nicht.
Verschlüsselung.
Guck mal, hier ist sogar das Watt.
Welches Watt denn?
Das Watt.
Ja, guck mal da.
In dem Watt haben wir das sogar schon gemacht.
Linux-Server verschlüsseln.
Das will ich nicht.
Nein, das will ich nicht.
Ja, ja.
Aber da haben wir es ganz abgedreht gemacht.
Da haben wir selbst...
Da haben wir quasi Petzner-Papier-XE gebootet oder solche Dinger.
Das musst du natürlich nicht machen.
Du brauchst nur den letzten Part, wo ich hier irgendwo, frag mich nicht, den Kram installiere.
Muss ich mal ein bisschen durchklicken.
So, weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Kann man bei G-Drive, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist nicht schwierig.
Guck dir lieber einen Guide an.
Du musst einfach nur diesen Dropware-Init-RAM-FS installieren und ich glaube, dein SSH-Key reinkopieren
und dann rebooten und dann geht das schon.
So, was hat er denn sonst noch hier für Sachen?
Das sieht kacke aus.
Man könnte den Kram da dran kleben.
Wobei er hat ihn dran geklebt.
Manche LED-Strips haben das Problem, dass sie ultra heiß werden, wenn sie da fest aufliegen.
Gibt es eigentlich eine Liste an Produkten, die ich empfehle, so eine Art FAQ.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Wir wollten sowas schon mal erstellen, aber es lag auch nicht am Sbarro oder so.
Das Sbarro hat schon angefangen.
fangen und
ich hab dem Sebarro aber nie was geschickt, also
das lag an mir. Der Cute-Mod ist
unschuldig. Da mach ich aber
mal was, das ist ne gute Idee.
Da kann ich gleich ein bisschen Rafflings
unters Volk bringen.
Vielleicht bekomm ich mal mehr als
20 Euro Amazon-Rafflings.
Seit ich
kein YouTube-Zeug mehr mach, gibt's...
Ich hab teilweise, ich hab mal
vor ein paar Jahren hatte ich über 1000 Euro
Amazon-Rafflings an Weihnachten.
Mittlerweile sind's
keine Ahnung, 20 Euro oder so.
Das Gute an Amazon-Rafflings
ist, dass es halt
kein was mehr kostet.
Das ist ne coole Idee.
Das ist ne coole Idee, wenn's klingelt,
dass die Lampen
pulsieren.
Das ist ne coole Idee, die gefällt mir.
Jetzt müssen wir mal schauen, wie man die drückt.
Hallo?
Wer drückt die Tür?
Ich kann nicht glauben, dass ich die Tür in meinem eigenen Haus drücken kann.
Wenn ich lange sitzen werde,
wird mein Tisch automatisch aufgeräumt,
damit ich stehen muss.
Das hilft mir, mein Standesk zu nutzen und weniger leise zu sein.
Oder macht es mich mehr leise,
als...
Da hab ich auch zwei Stück von.
Die sind richtig cool.
Damit kann man Sachen drücken lassen.
Die sind nice, da hab ich auch zwei Stück.
Die sind super cool.
Das ist echt cool.
Moment, hat er jetzt...
Das ist schon...
Das ist schon Big Brain, oder?
Eigentlich richtig cool.
Dafür könnte ich das auch verwenden.
Eigentlich ist das eine richtig geile Idee.
Ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Und ich habe noch mindestens einen von diesen Switch-Bots über.
Das wäre eigentlich richtig nice.
Dann muss ich nicht meinen Schreibtisch von Hand hochfahren,
sondern könnte meinen Schreibtisch über meinen Home Assistant hochfahren.
Alternativ ist halt auch die Sache, ich könnte einfach auf den Knopf drücken.
Weil ich habe hier die Bedienung von dem Tisch liegt 30 cm von meiner Hand weg.
Aber die Idee ist cool, die Idee gefällt mir, die hat was.
Gute Idee, gute Idee.
Könnte ich auch machen.
Eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee für den Vorratsschrank.
Ich glaube, sowas in der Richtung werde ich nochmal einbauen.
Das sieht viel zu stylisch aus für einfach so einen popeligen Abstellschrank.
Guck mal, richtig coole Beleuchtung für den Abstellschrank, muss ich sagen.
Aber es ist fast schon Perlen vor die Säue, wie man da so schön sagt.
Eigentlich fast schon, es sieht schon zu gut aus.
Für einen Abstellschrank.
Guck mal hier, das ist das Smart Home Ersatzteile-Schrank hier.
Ja, das Solar von Astor, das wäre natürlich noch besser,
wenn ich den Tisch gar keinen Schalter mehr drücken müsste.
Geht wahrscheinlich ohne Probleme, ESP32 dran.
Und dann von Hand die Kontakte, das geht bestimmt.
Gibt es eigentlich einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch mit Restarm?
Nee, aber das könnten wir bauen.
Also ich könnte garantiert diesen Control-Button-Ding ersetzen durch einen ESP32,
der das für mich schaltet.
Und dann könnten wir dem Ding auch eine Rest-API verpassen.
Moment, Amazon hat jetzt eine Alarmanlage?
Amazon Guard?
Oder ist Amazon Guard?
Das ist eine Funktion von Echo.
Ich verwende kein Amazon-Zeug, ich habe keinen Schimmer.
Ah, das sieht so aus, als wäre man zu Hause.
Okay, das fällt für mich schon mal komplett raus,
weil ich weder Alexa noch Amazon Echoes noch irgendwelche Amazon-Dinger habe.
Das ist eine Funktion von Echo.
Hat meiner nicht, hat keine Kameras, meiner hat nur so einen Laser-Abtast-Sensor.
Ich will auch ehrlich gesagt gar keinen China-Roboter mit Kameras haben.
Aber der Staubsauger-Roboter, der steht ja gerade im Wohnzimmer und ehrlich gesagt, hauptsächlich macht der auch nur das Wohnzimmer aktuell.
Der funktioniert ziemlich gut, seitdem wir den...
Den haben wir ja auch im Stream geflasht.
Ja, da.
Da ist er.
Karte vom Wohnzimmer, hier ist die Eingangstür.
Null.
Guck mal, ihr seht mal, wann er gefahren ist.
Man sieht sogar noch die letzten...
Man sieht sogar noch, wie er das letzte Mal gefahren ist.
Hier.
Hier ist die Dockingstation.
Hier ist das Sofa, da kommt er nicht drunter aktuell, weil da was davor hängt.
Hier ist ein Sessel, da kommt er auch nicht drunter.
Und hier hat er sauber gemacht.
Ist auch cool, dass man das...
Das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Die Dockingstation ist nicht da.
Die Dockingstation ist da.
Das ist ein Zimmer, ja.
Ja, ja, das ist nur das Wohnzimmer.
Das ist nicht meine Wohnung, das ist nur das Wohnzimmer.
Hier ist die Tür zunächst zum Flur.
Das ist gerade nur ein Zimmer, was auf der Map drauf ist.
Übrigens, so ein schickes Webinterface
gäbe es auch nicht ohne Custom-Firmware.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, warum ich alles flashe, was China-Firmware hat.
Und ich mir keine China-Geräte anschaffe, die man nicht flashet.
Ich muss übrigens mal gucken, ob es eine neue Tuya-Convert-Version gibt für China-Geräte.
Gibt es nicht.
Ah, exzellent.
Moment, das erkennt das Ding.
Da habe ich irgendwie...
Meint ihr, das funktioniert gut?
Ob das gut funktioniert?
Ich habe da irgendwie meine Zweifel, dass das so zuverlässig geht.
Außerdem, warum scheißt sein Hund in die Wohnung?
Warum scheißt sein Hund überhaupt in die Wohnung?
Das ist doch die eigentliche Frage.
Und wo ist mein Kack-Emoji da?
Guck mal, der guckt auch schon so.
Der guckt auch schon so.
Ich wurde erwischt.
Wartet mal kurz.
Ja, also, warum scheißt sein Hund in die Wohnung?
Oh, das fällt...
Ja, kein Wunder, wenn ein Remote zu dem Hund was sagt.
Wenn ich nach Hause komme, wenn die Garage-Dür noch offen ist,
habe ich den LED auf meinem Lichtschalter,
die die Farben verändern, um mich zu notifizieren.
So kann ich es sofort sehen,
ohne die Notifikation zu warten.
Hä? Warte, das habe ich nicht kapiert.
Ich habe den LED auf meinem Lichtschalter,
die die Farben verändern, um mich zu notifizieren.
So kann ich es sofort sehen,
ohne die Notifikation zu warten, um mich zu notifizieren.
Ah, das ist, wenn die Tür auf ist.
Okay, das ist nicht schlecht.
Ich möchte Audible bedanken,
für das Sponsoren-Video.
Audible hat die weltweit größte Selektion von Audiobooks.
Und sie machen...
Ist das gerade sehr laut?
Es ist wirklich sehr einfach, Audiobooks zu hören,
während du abends essen,
arbeiten oder wirklich jederzeit.
Eines meiner Lieblings-Audiobooks ist diese Biografie über Elon Musk.
Das ist doch Sponsored, oder?
Elon Musk.
Das ist sehr faszinierend.
Es erzählt seine Geschichte von seiner Kindheit
bis zu all den Techniken, die er gefunden hat.
Und wow, ich konnte nicht aufhören, zu hören.
Du kannst einfach zurück und wieder
zwischen dem Hören auf deinem Telefon...
Patrick hat Resub.
Nee, du hast nicht Resub,
du hast, äh, Abo verschenkt?
Ach so, ich hab dir das letzte Mal,
ich hab dir das letzte Mal ein Abo...
Ach jetzt, diese Meldung hab ich so noch nie gesehen.
Ja, nice, für den Sub.
Huge. Wir hatten was gekriegt.
Captain Seekai hat heute alles gekriegt.
Excellent.
Den hab ich schon öfters hier gesehen,
der hat's definitiv verdient.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das ist ja, du bist ja auch schon ganz schön lang dabei,
das ist ja quasi schon...
eigentlich, eigentlich eher...
Ja, das brauch ich nicht.
Das ist unsinnig.
Nee, das brauch ich nicht.
Das brauch ich nicht, zumal das eh sehr laut ist.
Okay, das ist übelst sell-out.
Ja, ist jetzt gut.
Ähm, kommt bei mir nicht in die Tüte.
Wir haben so eine, so eine Oldschool, ähm, Türgegensprechanlage.
Da hatten wir es ja schon ein paar Mal von,
über, über das Abenteuer mit meiner Türgegensprechanlage
und Klingelzignal abgreifen,
hab ich mir schon oft genug ausgelassen.
Das kommt bei mir allerdings nicht in die Tüte.
Ich will keine dieser, dieser, ähm...
Vor allem, guck mal hier.
Das ist so typische Kokona-Installation hier
mit, mit, mit dem Kabel durch die Wand und sowas.
Das ist eine, das ist eine Siedle-Tür, Türgegensprechanlage, ja.
Äh, DomPC, neun Monate.
Danke schön für den Sub.
So, ähm, aber sowas kommt bei mir nicht in die Tüte,
weil, ähm, mich nervt's mal ein bisschen,
dass man meine aktuelle Türgegensprechanlage,
also wir haben so ein Ding hier, äh,
äh, hätte ich, ich hätte damals was anderes installiert,
hätte ich mir damals um Smart Home schon Gedanken gemacht,
als wir hier eingezogen sind.
So ein Ding haben wir da.
Aber es hat auch seine, was, Unify-Klingel?
Ne, hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Unify-Door.
Kabel, die kenn ich auch nicht.
Das ist wirklich super, äh, wirre Technik,
wie das funktioniert.
Ich hab ja mal so ein Ding gebaut,
ich glaub, haben wir uns das nicht so ganz zusammen im Stream angeguckt,
wie man das hier abgreifen kann.
Das Klingelsignal.
Eigentlich, eigentlich ne coole Sache.
Aber, äh, ich hätte wahrscheinlich jetzt was anderes eingebaut,
wenn ich mich, wenn ich mir damals schon um Smart Home Sachen Gedanken gemacht hätte.
Aber, ähm, die Sache ist die, warum ich das nicht austausche,
ist der Kramverbrauch.
Der Kramverbrauch funktioniert wirklich sehr robust.
Also, wir haben zwei Gegensprechanlagen, äh, äh, Telefone im Flur hängen,
direkt daneben hängt das Heimautomatisierungstablet,
passt ganz gut.
Ähm, das Zeug ist wirklich sehr robust.
Weil, mal angenommen, man hat so ne, mal angenommen, man hat hier so ein Ding,
Moment, wo hab ich's denn?
Mal angenommen, man hat so ein Ding.
Ähm, sobald, sagen wir mal, die Fritzbox nicht da ist mit dem WLAN
oder sobald man den Router neu startet, irgendwas,
funktioniert die Klingel nicht mehr.
Das ist halt der Vorteil von diesem Oldschool-Zeug,
egal was ist, wenn nicht grad Stromausfall ist, geht die Klingel.
Und, ähm, ja, wir haben, ich hab hier so ein Ding mal gebaut,
müssen wir mal gucken, ob ich noch die, die Bilder finde,
ob das eins, eins von beiden...
Hahaha, dieses Bild hab ich jetzt eigentlich nicht gesucht.
Und das auch nicht, okay, ich find mein...
Hahaha, ich find, ich find, ich find dieses gar nicht mehr,
wo hab ich das?
Äh, äh, Image, CC, CC,
Ah, wie hieß das denn?
Ähm, ja, äh, vielleicht hab ich's in meiner VM.
Gut, wie, wie auch immer, ich, ich, ich finde es,
ich finde das Bild gerade nicht mehr dazu.
Ich hätt mir das vielleicht mal bookmarken sollen.
Wir haben ja im Stream was gebaut, was erkennt,
äh, wann bei der Klingel geklingelt wird.
So, und das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
War das Pick?
Nee.
Das war irgendwas mit CC.
Und CC Image?
Äh, ich bin mir relativ sicher, es war Image.
Ja, ich bin ja auch blöd, dass ich mir die Dinger nicht,
nicht mal bookmarken kann.
Image?
Vielleicht hab ich hier auf dem Desktop noch eins,
oder in der VM.
Zumindest, zumindest haben wir was gebastelt.
Ich start mal die VM, dann können wir nebenbei gucken.
Was es abgreift, was das Klingelsignal abgreift.
Und es ist halt ziemlich, äh, wo ist meine, warte.
Da ist es doch.
What the fuck?
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Vielleicht muss ich einfach mal vor immer neu starten, oder so.
Äh, weil, der Knärbär ganz einfach, weil ich ja nicht geupdatet hab.
Zumindest dann, dann, ich, das geht, warte mal, History, History, History.
Ist, CC, irgendwas mit Image?
CC oder so war das.
Was hab ich denn da genommen?
Image?
keck.gg?
Was ist denn keck.gg?
Ah, Free Image Hosting.
Was, Post Image?
Ah, postimage.cc.
Warum findet der das nicht mit Image?
Mit Image, CC, Post, das ist eine Sache, wo ich Firefox deutlich besser finde, die History-Suche, suckt, in Chrome.
So, da ist es doch.
Das ist die kaputte Tastatur, und das ist irgendeine, äh, äh, äh, Ding.
So, genau, das ist das Teil, was ich gebastelt hab, nee, nee, ist es nicht, oder doch, oder nicht?
Nee, das ist der USB-Stick.
Scheiß drauf, äh, bevor ich das Bild jetzt finde, zumindest, ähm, diese Siedle-Sachen ist super kompliziertes Zeug, ähm, nee, das ist das Innen, das ist das Innen, das ist das Innen-Telefon, äh, das Bild.
APC, lustig, ich find's schon toll, dass du das besser findest als ich, also schneller findest als ich.
Ist ja auch, guck mal, was haben wir denn hier?
Nee, das ist noch was anderes.
Kann ich jetzt in meiner History nach postimage.cc suchen und dann finden wir was?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen, postimage.cc.
So viel, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal alles auf, und dann hoffen wir, dass es irgendwo dabei ist.
Und jetzt erst mal, äh, liegt.
Ach ja, genau, das ist es.
Äh, PC, lustig, warum, warum findest du die Bilder von mir schneller als, als ich selber?
Tabs Overload.
Nee, das ist immer das Gleiche, ja.
Aber er hat's, äh, der PC, lustig, hat's schon gefunden.
Nämlich das hier meine ich.
Also, das ist die, äh, Tür-Gegensprechanlage von der einen Seite, hier ist das Ding, was ich gebastelt hab, und zwar, folgendermaßen funktioniert das.
Ähm, äh, das ist, vielleicht nicht die schönste Variante, ja, aber, so, also, was, was der da macht, ist, äh, einmal hab ich, das ist ein ESP32, das hier ist ein Sensor für, das ist ein Magnetsensor, da man, daran kann man erkennen, wenn das Telefon aufgelegt wurde oder nicht.
Das Telefon ist das hier, so.
Und die haben im Hörer einen Magnet drin, ne.
Und ich stecke einfach diesen Magnet hinter den Hörer und dann erkenne ich, also diesen Magnetsensor, weil im, weil im, also hier im Hörer ist ein Magnet drin, ne, woran das Telefon selbst auch erkennt, ob das Tele, der Telefonhörer aufgehängt, aufhängt oder nicht.
So, und hier hab ich einen Magnetsensor, äh, nen, ich hab vergessen, wie der Kram heißt, nen, ähm, äh, Halssensor, genau, und der, der erkennt, ob das, äh, ob der Hörer aufgehängt ist oder nicht.
Das heißt, anhand dessen weiß ich, an welchem, äh, Handge, Sprechgerät jemand dran ist.
Das Ganze hab ich übrigens fett in Heißkleber gepackt, dass es nicht aus Versehen irgendwie sich hier kurzschließt.
So, das sind ESP32 und hier dran ist, ist das Teil von irgendeiner Galerie?
So, und hier dran ist, man erkennt's, man erkennt's nicht so genau, ähm, ist der Anschluss für die, für die Gegensprechanlage, wo, wo, woran der ESP32 erkennt, ob geklingelt wurde oder nicht.
Super.
Komplizierter.
Komplizierter Geschiss eigentlich dafür.
So, und diese Siedle-Sachen funktionieren folgendermaßen, die haben irgendwie eine normale Spannung von, ich sag jetzt mal, ich glaub, 24 Volt oder so auf der Leitung.
Wenn es klingelt, geht es hoch auf 27 und wenn abgenommen wird, geht es runter auf 15.
So, und diese Spannungsänderung muss man erkennen und weiß, in welchem Zustand die Gegensprechanlage ist.
Also, total abgedrehtes, äh, Oldschool-Zeug.
Richtig.
Aber ein Vorteil hat die Tür-Gegensprechanlage, so eine Oldschool-Tür-Gegensprechanlage versus so eine neue.
Sie funktioniert.
Sie funktioniert, ob das WLAN geht, sie funktioniert, ob die Fritzbox geht, sie funktioniert einfach.
Was ich schon einen Vorteil finde, ja.
Und dadurch, dass ich jetzt abgegriffen hab, wann geklingelt wird, kann ich zumindest mal eine Notification schicken, äh, auf alle Handys, wenn geklingelt wurde und man vielleicht gerade im Garten ist oder im, auf der Terrasse ist.
Ja.
Ist eigentlich ganz nützlich.
Was, was nicht funktioniert, äh, ist, äh, mit dem, äh, äh, sagen wir mal, über das Telefon mit dem Typ an der Tür sprechen, das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist auch nochmal, nochmal ein bisschen komplizierter, das, das einzurichten, ja.
Aber deswegen kommt mir keine neue Türsprech-Gegensprecherlage ins, ins Haus, weil ich dieses Setup hier eigentlich ganz gut finde, weil es schlicht und ergreifend funktioniert, immer funktioniert.
Und ich mach's jetzt so, wenn's klingelt und ich das mit diesem ESP32 erkenne, ob's klingelt, dann geht, äh, direkt auf dem Tablet im Flur geht der Browser auf mit der Kameraansicht von der Tür.
Also sprich, ich hab dann im, im, im Flur, man hat's ja hier gesehen, ich hab im Flur das Tablet hängen und das Telefon und wenn es klingelt, geht das Tablet an, direkt in die Browseransicht und zeigt mir die Kamera vom, vom, äh, Hoftor und dann kann ich hier drangehen.
Also sprich, ich geh zwar an diese Tür-Gegensprecherlage, aber ich sehe vorher schon, ob das vielleicht jemand ist, wo ich lieber faken will, dass ich nicht daheim bin.
Drei Abos, ne, ne, Moment.
Äh, äh, also insgesamt drei Abos verschenkt an PC Lust.
Ich, PC Lust, ich hab ein Abo von Liko gekriegt, dankeschön, für den Sub-Exquisite-Subscription, dankeschön.
Ähm, benutze normales Chromium oder ungoogled Chromium?
Äh, ich glaube mittlerweile normales Chromium, damit Hardware-Decoding geht.
Ich glaub, das war so.
So, ähm, genau.
So, gehen wir, kommen wir weiter.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich das nicht zu so einer moderneren Tür-Gegensprecherlage austausche.
Weil das Zeug einfach, äh, so wie man sagt.
Also, so, so rock-solid ist und funktioniert.
Ja, das wollte ich auch noch machen.
Hab ich nicht.
Ich hatte verschiedene Ansätze, erst mit einem Rüttelsensor, aber am besten dürfte wahrscheinlich echt sein, den Stromverbrauch zu überwachen.
Für die Familienmitglieder, die das für mich tun.
Ja, das hat vor Jahren nicht mehr funktioniert.
Wenn meine Frau zu Abend kochen beginnt, kann sie einfach ihr Handy auf den Konto swipen.
Das schickt mir automatisch eine Nachricht, die mir sagt, dass sie kocht.
Und es ist Zeit, den Kindern zu helfen.
So arbeite ich nicht zu spät.
Um Abendzeit, die Lichter schlagen langsam auf, eine halbe Stunde bevor es schläft.
Aber die einfachste Variante ist einfach keine Kinder haben.
Wenn es draußen kalt ist und dunkler als normal, wird der Lichtsensor die Lichter früher aufwachen.
So bleibt es immer leuchtend drinnen.
Ich habe die Kinder gerade im Bett.
Zeit, sich zu entspannen.
Hä? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Was, wenn es draußen dunkler wird, macht er die Lichter entsprechend hoch oder was?
Es ist Zeit, den Kindern zu helfen.
So arbeite ich nicht zu spät.
Um Abendzeit, die Lichter schlagen langsam auf, eine halbe Stunde bevor es schläft.
Ah, oh, das ist eine coole Idee.
Also wenn man sein Haus so eingerichtet hat mit Smart-Lichtern, Schaltern und allem möglichen.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Es ist kalt.
Wisst ihr, was ich bei dem auch ganz cool finde?
Der hat alles so indirekt beleuchtet.
Das sieht zwar cool aus.
Aber irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, die Räume sind nie richtig hell.
...vor dem Sonntag.
Wenn es draußen dunkel und dunkler ist als normal, wird der Lichtsensor die Lichter früher aufwachen.
So bleibt es immer leuchtend drinnen.
Puh, ich habe die Kinder gerade im Bett.
Zeit, sich zu entspannen.
Reinigen die Toiletten.
Es gibt tatsächlich einen Roboter, der die Toiletten automatisch in eine Box einbauen kann.
Was?
Das ist immer noch auf Kickstarter.
Aber die Zukunft der Roboter macht mehr als das.
Was?
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ernst sein.
Ja.
Das funktioniert doch im Leben nicht.
Das ist immer noch auf Kickstarter.
Aber die Zukunft der Roboter macht mehr als das.
Nein.
Okay.
Das funktioniert jetzt genau in diesem einen Fall.
Das funktioniert genau in diesem einen Fall.
Wo diese Toiletten so da liegen.
In dieser Größe.
Und da eine Box steht.
Im Leben funktioniert das nicht wirklich sinnvoll.
Okay.
Zeit, sie auf die TV zu schauen.
Ach.
Wenn ich nur die Toilette finden kann.
Computer.
Frag Chipolo, um meine Toilette zu finden.
Der Voice Assistant aktiviert den Tracker, um sie schnell zu finden.
Viel Glück nächstes Mal, Kinder.
Oder musst du so ein...
Ne.
Guck mal, so ein fettes Ding hintendran an der Fernbedienung.
Also wenn man schon so eine stylische Apple-Fernbedienung hat, wenn man das dann unbedingt haben will,
dann mache ich mir da so einen fetten, fetten Tracker hintendran.
Also das ist eine doofe Idee.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Ganz davon abgesehen, ich finde die Fernbedienung...
Die Fernbedienung ist, glaube ich, eines der wenigen Sachen, die immer an der gleichen Stelle liegt.
Außerdem habe ich drei Fernbedienungen.
Ich habe die Fernbedienung vom Fernseher.
Ich habe die Fernbedienung vom Shield-TV.
Und ich habe die Fire-TV-Fernbedienung.
Mit allen drei kann ich das Shield-TV fernsteuern.
Also ich finde immer irgendwas.
Außerdem gucke ich eh quasi keinen Fernseher.
Ich habe die Hue-Sync-Box und die Hue-Fernbedienung fängt automatisch an.
Die Fernbedienung sinkt mit der TV an und ändert die ganze Erfahrung beim Zuschauen eines Films.
Wenn ich die TV nachts im Fenster schaue...
... wird die TV aufgerufen.
Die TV wird aufgerufen, sodass ich nichts verpasst, während ich schaue, wer vor der Tür ist.
Ich kann auch schnell mit einer vorgeschriebenen Nachricht antworten.
Während ich nachts laufe, schalten die Motionssensoren die Akzent-Lichtung an.
Wie unter unseren Küchenkabinen.
Die Motionssensoren für nur Akzent-Lichtung können viel mehr familienfreundlich sein.
Weil es...
Hübsch!
Ich muss ja sagen...
Der Raum von ihm sieht wirklich hübsch aus.
Mich würde mal interessieren, ob die Räume bei ihm auch irgendwann mal richtig hell sind.
Weil diese...
Also jetzt soll es ja gar nicht hell sein.
Aber dieses ganze indirekte Beleuchten, was er hier hat...
Wobei, nee, hier nicht.
Aber bei den anderen Sachen...
Das macht den Raum nie so richtig hell.
... und nicht mit den Haupt-Light-Sensoren verbirgt.
Auf Trash-Night ist es einfach für mich, den Anruf auf meinem Handy auszulösen.
Wenn ich nach 8 Uhr nicht die Hintertür öffne und in die Küche gehe...
... er erinnert mich, dass ich den Trash rausnehmen muss.
Hör auf, was du tust und nimm den Trash jetzt raus.
Oh, da hätte ich ja keinen Bock drauf, wenn mir Alexa sagt, ich soll den Müll rausräumen.
Ich werde dich aufwachen und schlafen, wenn du mich nimmst.
Okay, okay.
Zu viel TV zu sehen ist ein leichtes Problem.
Besonders mit diesen Hübschen Sinklichten.
Wenn ich eine unnötige Anzahl von TV sehe, bekomme ich eine Warnung.
Es ist Zeit, von der TV eine Pause zu machen.
Pff, das ist ja schon bei der Switch immer so nervig gewesen.
Zeit mal!
Was stand bei der Switch immer?
Zeit mal rauszugehen oder irgendwie sowas.
Es kann auch automatisch die TV auslösen, wenn du oder deine Kinder keine Selbstkontrolle haben.
Wenn ich abends von der TV oder der Arbeit aufstehe und nach der Mittagszeit ins Bett gehe...
... werden meine Alarmklappenautomationen automatisch zurückgedrückt...
... sodass ich den nächsten Tag Zeit haben kann, um zu schlafen.
Mit dem selben Schlafsensor kann man automatisch...
Ja, das ist echt übertrieben.
Das ist echt übertrieben.
Wenn du einen Drucksensor unter deiner Klammer hast...
... kannst du das auch mit deinem Handy am Abend auf den Charger drücken.
Bevor du losgehst, vergesst nicht, den Audible-Link unten zu klicken.
Du kannst das Elon Musk-Buch hören, während du diese Automationen einstellst.
Der macht den Sellout aber auch gut hier.
... und bringt die Dinge zu einem ganz neuen Niveau.
Danke fürs Zuschauen und wir sehen uns zum nächsten Mal.
Auf Wiedersehen.
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk
Das muss nicht sein.
Der zweite 0€ PC aus Gratisteilen.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
USB-Port-Cable.
Oh, da kann ich flamen, wenn es unterschiedlich ist.
Ich flame gerne über USB.
Oh, das ist langweilig.
Okay, das ist langweilig.
Ich, ich, okay.
Wo, wo zeigt der die USB?
Klassiker? Kennt jeder?
Kennt auch noch jeder?
Ja, kennt auch noch jeder?
Was, der neue ist rot?
Echt? Sind die rot?
Ich dachte, rot sind die Dinger, die Quick Charge können auf meinem Mainboard.
Hast du immer noch einen Bart?
Man weiß es nicht.
Und USB 4?
Was ist, was ist dann USB 4?
USB 4 ist dann...
Jetzt müssen sie langsam anfangen zu flamen.
Um die Farben zu recyceln.
Was wird denn dann USB 4?
Lila.
Gegenbogenfarbe.
Ach nee, stimmt, das ist ja ein USB-C-Stecker.
Es bleibt ja ein USB-C-Stecker, stimmt ja.
Das ist Oldschool, das ist der richtig Oldschool USB-Anschluss.
So, so sahen die Dinger zu Zeiten von USB 1 und USB 2 aus.
Da hast du Geräte immer an diesen fetten angeschlossen.
Oder ein USB-C, jetzt neuerdings, ja.
Geht an den Rechner und das geht halt ans Gerät, das wissen wir schon.
Ja, ja, ok, ok, weiter.
Mini, ok, wow, was ist denn das?
Ok, jetzt kommen wir eher in die abgedrehten Sphären von USB.
Dinger, die kein Mensch verwendet.
Mini-B habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ich kenne Mini-USB, aber ist das das gleiche?
Micro-USB, Mini-USB?
... Connector.
Der Mini-B wird auf kleineren Geräten verwendet.
So wie ältere Smartphones und digitale Kameras.
Aber...
Ok.
Der Mini-USB wird auf kleineren Geräten verwendet.
Und das bringt uns zum Micro-B-USB-Connector.
Der Micro-B ist ungefähr die gleiche Größe...
What the fuck ist das?
Moment, das ist doch das, was ich unter Micro-USB verstehe, oder?
Das sind die ganz normalen Anschlüsse, oder?
Ich wusste nur, mir ist bloß nicht klar, dass die Dinger Micro-B heißen.
... ungefähr die Hälfte der Größe.
Ja, dann habe ich das...
Mein Blue Yeti hat Mini.
Und die Elgato Capture Card hat auch noch Mini.
... into even smaller and thinner devices.
It's made to connect to modern smartphones, modern digital cameras, MP3-Players and so on.
Also sagt man dazu eigentlich korrekterweise nicht Mini-USB und Micro-USB,
sondern man müsste sagen USB Micro-B.
Ok, das habe ich noch nie sagen gehört.
Jemand.
Es wurde im Jahr 2007 veröffentlicht, um das Mini-B zu ersetzen.
Es gab auch den USB 3.0 Type-B-Connector.
Der Type-B 3.0 hat neun Pins...
Den habe ich auch schon mal irgendwo gesehen, ja.
Ich glaube, ich habe einen externen USB-3-Wechselrahmen für SSDs, der so ein Ding hat.
... verglichen mit vier Pins in der vorherigen Version.
Und das ermöglicht es, höhere Transfer-Schwindigkeiten zu erzeugen...
... und es ermöglicht es, Power zu erzeugen...
So geil, was es da wieder für 30 Milliarden Sagen gibt, ne?
... durch die Peripheral.
Nun, um Raum für die Pins zu machen, ist der Type-B 3.0 größer...
... und hat eine andere Form als die 1.0 und 2.0 Versionen.
Also, der Type-B 3.0-Connector wird nicht...
Ja, das ist ja Absicht.
... für USB 1.0 und 2.0 verwendet werden.
Dafür umgedreht passen die da rein.
... wegen ihrer größeren Größe.
Es gibt auch den USB 3.0 Micro-B.
Und dieser Konnektor ist genauso dünn wie der 2.0-Konnektor...
... aber er ist breiter.
Es ist im Grunde ein...
Okay, hab ich noch nie gesehen. Wusste ich gar nicht, dass der existiert.
... USB 2.0 Micro-B-Konnektor...
Wozu ist das? Was ist die Daseins...
Ah, das ist einfach eine schnellere Variante von Micro-B.
... aber mit fünf zusätzlichen Pins, die auf der Seite...
Also, bei einer SSD zum Beispiel.
... die die Größe des 2.0 Micro-B verdoppelt.
Dieser Konnektor wird verwendet, um Daten und Leistung...
... an Geräte zu bringen, wie modernen externen Harddrives.
Und 2014 wurde der USB-C entwickelt.
Ja, Gott sei Dank!
Der macht diesen ganzen anderen Kram überflüssig.
... mit dem USB 3.1 Standard.
Aber die haben doch echt...
Die haben doch echt...
... komplett...
... Dachschaden, ja.
Dieser ist ein dünner Konnektor mit runden Ecken...
... und er hat 24 Pins.
Und er wird einfach in einen Port eingepackt...
... weil er keine Auf- und Herunterrichtung hat.
Heute kann der USB-C auf modernen Smartphones...
... externen Harddriven, Tabletten...
... mit einem Host verbunden sein.
Okay, gut.
Ja, zum Glück ist er nicht noch auf USB-Standards oder so eingegangen.
So, der zweite 0-Euro-PC aus gratis Ebett...
... aus gratis Ebett-Teilen.
Dann zeigt mir...
Also der erste 0-Euro-PC war nicht wirklich 0 Euro.
Das war eigentlich mehr ein G-Bait-Video.
Weil er hat zwar den PC für 0 Euro bekommen...
... aber hatte bestimmt 50 Euro Fahrtkosten.
Fokus. Hallo.
Ah.
Ey, und willkommen zurück zu einem neuen Video von mir.
Es geht heute weiter...
Dann zeig mal her.
... mit dem 0-Euro-PC aus Ebett-Kleinanzeigenteilen...
... die mir geschenkt wurden.
Und eigentlich ist der Kram ja schon fertig.
Es gab zwei Teile.
Da habe ich was Funktionstüchtiges zusammengebaut auf jeden Fall.
Aber wir haben noch Teile übrig.
Und da bin ich sehr zuversichtlich, dass da zumindest...
... irgendetwas lauffähiges bei rumkommen sollte.
Und aus diesem Grunde werde ich das jetzt auch gleich tun.
Ich lese mir nochmal eben schnell die Kommentare durch.
Vielleicht hat noch irgendjemand was angemerkt oder gesagt...
... ja, mach mal das, mach mal das.
Da können wir das hier vielleicht einziehen.
Was? Asynchron?
Nö, bei mir ist das passt eigentlich.
Somit weitermachen.
Und dann nochmal aus gegebenem Anlass...
... weil es scheinbar immer noch nicht bei allen angekommen ist.
Ich bin kein PC oder sonst was Reparaturdienst für irgendwas.
Okay, wenn du so einen Channel hast, kann ich verstehen.
Ich meine, bei mir unter den Videos damals...
... haben mir die Leute schon geschrieben, so nach dem Motto...
... Hilfe, Max, mein Drucker geht nicht.
Kannst du mir sagen, woran das liegt und sowas.
Gestern wieder irgendwie.
Da hat da jemand geschrieben, PC funktioniert nicht...
... oder ist schmutzig oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab gesagt, nö, wieso soll ich das machen?
Ich dachte, du reparierst Sachen für...
... Cash.
Nee, wann habe ich das denn gesagt?
Habe ich das gesagt?
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich meine, ihr könnt gerne Fragen stellen oder Hilfe von mir kriegen.
Die Leute sind immer so geil.
Und dann beschweren sie sich danach noch, so nach dem Motto...
... ah, du bist so abgehoben, du hilfst noch nicht mal einem Viewer oder sowas.
Aber bitte mal ein bisschen den Ball flach halten.
Und am besten auch mal lesen, bevor man mir was abschickt.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht Leute, die noch extra dazuschreiben...
... ja, tut mir leid, ich habe Lese-Rechtschreib-Schwäche oder so...
... aber bitte mal ein bisschen den Ball flach halten.
Und am besten auch mal lesen, bevor man mir was abschickt.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht Leute, die noch extra dazuschreiben...
... ja, tut mir leid, ich habe Lese-Rechtschreib-Schwäche oder sowas.
Das ist teilweise besser zu lesen als...
Das ist eh die geilste Ausrede.
Ja, schade.
Also, ich weiß, es gibt genug Leute, die das haben, aber es gibt auch genug Leute,
die das als Ausrede verwenden.
Echt, da wäre noch etwas im Hinterkopf gewesen.
Ja.
Das ist echt...
... das ist echt...
... ich glaube, dass das eigentlich die beste Ausrede ist.
Da hast du ja...
Ja, das ist echt...
... das ist echt...
... ich glaube, dass das...
Also, ich weiß, es gibt genug Leute, die das haben, aber es gibt auch genug Leute, die das als Ausrede verwenden.
Da wäre noch was im Hinterkopf gewesen, was ich noch zeigen wollte oder konnte.
Es fiel mir nicht mehr ein und in den Kommentaren war es auch nicht dabei.
Beziehungsweise nicht irgendwas, was die Sachen aus dem ersten Teil betrifft.
Aber wir haben ja noch die Sachen, die quasi übrig sind, wie gerade schon gesagt.
Der Netzteil-Tester hatte gesagt, Power-Good-Signal.
Das ist ein Schakun-Netzteil, sogar was halbwegs Gutes.
Was Brauchbares, ja. Also kein LC-Power zumindest schon mal.
Allerdings sind die anderen Spannungen erstmal in Ordnung.
Ob das hiermit dann klappt oder Abstürze gibt oder so.
Weil ich hab Hunger as fuck. Es ist ja auch Zeitverzögerung.
Sprechen noch feststellen.
Umstellung gewesen.
Es war Zeitverzögerung.
Die Sachen drin, die noch übrig sind.
Das 775er-Board mit dem COD 2 Duo.
Moment. Sehe ich da zwei IDE-Anschlüsse?
Erkenne ich das richtig?
Zwei IDE und zwei Masata.
Okay, das muss aus so einer Übergangszeit sein.
Das sind ja auch noch normale PCI.
Guck mal, hier ist noch PCI-Express und normale PCI.
Das muss so eine Übergangsphase gewesen sein.
Bei Bedarf diese Grafikkarte, die wahrscheinlich schlechter ist als die grafische Lösung hier drin.
Ähm, ein Kühler, ein Floppy-Laufwerk, ein SATA-Kabel haben wir noch übrig.
Und, ach, das gehört dazu. Okay.
Und dann gab es noch die drei Festplatten.
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Was ist das für ein dickes Gerät bei der CPU?
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein Chipsatz-Kühler.
Und die andere, die hat, glaube ich...
Oder Onboard-Grafikkarte.
Ne, Smart-OK, Smart-OK.
Ja, nehmen wir diese hier.
Und wer sich noch zurück entsinnt, ich habe ja im ersten Part...
Hat jemand von euch jemals schon, äh, aus den Smart-Werten einer Festplatte
irgendwie...
nützlich gemacht?
Nützliche Informationen rausbekommen?
Ernst gemeinte Frage, ich noch nie.
Das ist zwar da, aber wirklich, bringen du das nix?
Ich glaube, es hat sich noch nie eine Platte bei mir über Smart-Werte angekündigt, wenn sie kaputt gehen.
Äh, die...
Ja...
Ne.
Oh, Exquisite-Gehäuse.
Nur vom Feinsten.
...sind immer noch, äh, irgend so ein Ranzzeug drin.
Das müssen wir jetzt erstmal ignorieren, leider.
Habe ich das Laufwerk? Wo ist das?
Ach, das habe ich in dem PC verwendet dann, ne?
Ja, OK, dann gibt's hier eben kein Laufwerk und wir haben ein hessisches Laufwerk drin.
Exzellentes Gehäuse.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht der Goal bei diesem PC, dass da noch irgendwas aussieht.
Ah, nicht das Goal, OK.
Dann würde ich sagen, verfrachte ich den Kram von da mal...
Das Goal wäre auch schwierig zu erreichen, dass da noch was ordentlichem aussieht.
Aber das ist ja nicht... Wie gesagt, es geht ja um 0 Euro.
...rein und dann schauen wir mal, wie und ob und was überhaupt funktioniert, irgendwie was oder wie oder was.
PepeCham
Bevor es nun einmal ganz weiter geht, wollte ich noch einmal zeigen und beweisen, dass das Mainboard tatsächlich funktioniert,
trotz der abgebrochenen, äh, Halterung hier für den Arbeitsspeicher.
Die kannst du so rausziehen und der Arbeitsspeicher bleibt drin und, äh, es läuft dann auch alles.
Allerdings funktioniert die Grafikkarte nicht hier drin.
Oh, vieles Batman.
Ich habe sogar so eingestellt, dass er automatisch die PC-Express-Grafikkarte nehmen soll.
Aber... Ob das wirklich das Problem ist?
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das ja die Grafikkarte, das hier ein normaler Chipsatz ist.
Vielleicht ist das...
Damals war ja noch nicht so viel in der CPU drin.
Heute hast du ja quasi alles, was früher auf dem Mainboard war, in der CPU.
Du hast SATA-Gedöns in der CPU, du hast alle die ganzen Chipsatz-Funktionen in der CPU, die Grafikkarte in der CPU.
Heute ist ja alles in der CPU drin.
Also eigentlich könntest du heute wahrscheinlich Mainboards bauen, die so groß sind.
Das Board an der Stelle ja auch kaputt.
Äh, besorge ich mir mal eben eine andere Karte, schieb sie da rein und melde mich sofort.
Nochmal, bevor es da wirklich ans eigentliche Zusammenbauen geht.
Und ein Test mit einer anderen Grafikkarte beweist, das Mainboard ist an der Stelle nicht kaputt, sondern die Grafikkarte.
Das ist übrigens eine ATE Radeon X300 SE mit 128 MB Speicher.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, das ist wahrscheinlich schlecht.
Wenn wir den Speicher-Chip sehen, dann... Ich weiß nicht genau, welche Spezifikation das ist, aber die sind wirklich verdammt langsam.
Aber das kann doch nicht sein, dass die kaputt ist.
Also, ja eigentlich schon, aber...
Tatsächlich, okay.
Weil ich habe mit Smart-Werten noch nie irgendwas Sinnvolles rausbekommen.
Na?
Es ist ja generell so, zumindest in meiner Erinnerung, irgendwelche High-End-Karten, die gehen sehr viel schneller kaputt, weil sie eben thermisch und leistungstechnisch belastet werden.
Bei solchen Karten, die halten eigentlich ewig.
Ich versuche nochmal was, wenn das, was ich...
Es kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass in manchen Server-Hardwares noch ATI Rage Pro und sowas verbaut ist.
Onboard.
Das sind Sachen von 1998.
...geklappt hat, dann...
Der Kram funzt!
...nochmal.
Nein.
Die Karte läuft wieder.
Was habe ich getan?
Ich habe dieses hart gewordene Heatpad einmal beseitigt und gemerkt, dass sich das um verschiedene Bauteile neben dem eigentlichen GPU-Chip auf dem Chip gesammelt hat.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Das habe ich eben sauber gemacht und jetzt kriegen wir auf jeden Fall wieder ein Bild.
Ich habe auch diesen Jumper gewechselt.
Ich weiß nicht, was er tut.
Da steht einfach nur MPEG-3 daneben in Klammern.
Kann aber auch sein, dass das für irgendein anderes Bauteil zutrifft.
Also, nun endlich bauen wir den Kram zu.
Moment, was hat der denn da?
Ist das so eine Wärmebildkamera, wo man erkennt, wie warm was ist?
Gibt es da irgendwas günstiges?
Ich habe mir das auch schon überlegt, ob ich mir sowas holen soll, aber der Kram kostet dann gleich 500 Euro oder so und das war es mir nicht wert.
Guck mal, sieht richtig ordentlich aus, das Gehäuse mittlerweile.
Macht doch was her.
Excellent.
Erstmal gleich Copyright-Strike.
So, ich habe jetzt mal gedacht, weil ich die ganze Zeit immer nur Windows benutze und ja beim Mining-Rig irgendwie mal Linux verwenden wollte, probiere ich es mal mit Sorin OS.
Das wollte ich einfach mal irgendwie gezeigt haben.
Hat mir null gefallen.
Hatten wir mal irgendwann im Stream.
Ganz cool fand, irgendwie so beim täglichen Nutzen.
Das war so eines der Linux-Dinger, die voll auf Windows macht.
Oh.
Das kann man machen, aber guckst du zwei Icon, zwei Buttons tiefer, erkennst du halt sofort, das ist kein Windows.
Deswegen, ich bin der Meinung, es bringt überhaupt nichts, wenn man so tut, als wäre man Windows und quasi, wenn man nur ein bisschen an der Oberfläche kratzt, es schon wieder kein Windows ist.
Das heißt, man sollte ganz klar von Anfang an gleich das machen, dass es eben kein Windows ist.
Dann sind die Leute auch nicht enttäuscht und denken, oh, das geht alles wie unter Windows, weil geht es halt nun mal nicht.
Und bis jetzt läuft es noch.
Das ist gut, auch mit diesem total ranzigen USB-Stick, der schon zweimal umgebogen wurde, wo vorher Windows 7 als Installation drauf war.
Aber, ja, können wir mal warten.
Oh, schau mal.
Schau mal.
Hier ist übrigens immer noch der Laptop von...
Warum steht da schau mal?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie er heißt.
Da habe ich auf jeden Fall mal ein Video zu gemacht.
Braucht man das zum Mainboards sauber machen oder so?
Hier aus der Umgebung.
Hier, das Ding musst du mal abholen.
Ansonsten, ich kann das ja nicht hier liegen lassen und verstauben lassen.
Und der Tatbestand ist nun folgender, dass sich dieses Video...
Ne, wir haben noch kein Ubuntu 2010 ausprobiert.
Da gibt es, glaube ich, nichts großartig Spannendes drin.
Das einzig Spannende in 2010 ist, glaube ich, der ZFS-Installer.
Und da habe ich irgendwo gelesen, dass die nicht alle Module drin haben, sodass Encryption abgrundtief langsam ist.
Wenn nicht, das probieren wir vielleicht mal.
Ich muss mir das gerade mal aufschreiben.
Angeblich haben die jetzt nämlich einen ZFS-Installer und auch eingebaute ZFS-Encryption.
Aber ich habe im Vorfeld irgendwo gelesen, dass die irgendwelche Module nicht drin haben, sodass es halt extrem langsam ist.
...vor meinem Kranksein aufgenommen habe und mich deswegen noch nicht mit dem Acer Laptop beschäftigt habe.
Aber das hat sich geändert. Manche von euch haben es bestimmt schon gesehen.
Und wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, kann oben rechts einmal an den Bildschirm ran schauen.
Dort gibt es dann eine Verlinkung, entweder für jetzt oder für später oder für im neuen Tab öffnen oder sonst irgendwas in der Art.
Ich verwende jetzt hier Zorin.
Läuft eigentlich so ganz in Ordnung.
Und dann habe ich mir jetzt gerade gedacht, während der Updates...
Gut, der Vorteil ist, wenn du da Linux drauf installierst, du musst keine 20.000 Treiber nachinstallieren, die schwierig zu bekommen sind für den Oldschool-Kram.
Darum macht Google ich einfach mal ein bisschen, um zu schauen, wie die...
Taugt ZFS oder lieber BTFS?
Auf jeden Fall ZFS.
Also ZFS ist das deutlich bewährtere von beiden.
Experience da ist und da habe ich einfach mal die Grafikkarte gegoogelt.
Und da steht jetzt dabei, dass sie Hyper-Memory unterstützt.
Ich habe irgendwann mal ein PC-Games-Hardware-Retro-Video gemacht, vor drei Jahren oder so.
Das waren, glaube ich, keine ATI-Karten, aber es waren Grafikkarten, die sich dann einfach am Arbeitsspeicher mit dem Grafikspeicher bedient haben.
Ja, das gab's.
Und ich finde es gerade kurios, dass diese Karte das auch macht.
Ich werde gleich mal schauen, ob es mit der internen Grafikeinheit...
Das gab's, ja.
Ich hatte mal so einen Wohnzimmer-PC, so, frag mich nicht, 2004 rum oder so.
Der hatte eine Onboard-Grafikkarte, die hatte kein eigenes RAM, der musstest du quasi normal, also Betriebssystem-RAM hier abzwacken.
Hier vielleicht besser laufen kann.
Ziemliches Kacksystem.
Oder könnte, man weiß es noch nicht.
Aber natürlich muss er erst mal Updates nachreichen.
Sind die langsam mal fertig?
Ah, ne, der macht noch was, okay.
So, und dann schalten wir das Ding ein paar Tage später nochmal ein.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nochmal ein bisschen...
Die...
Oh, RIP.
Das war ein Karton hinter mir.
Das zweite Mal.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob er noch hochfährt oder...
Was man halt auch wieder schön daran sieht, dass so bei diesen PCs...
Von wann wird denn der PC sein? 2008? 2009?
So rum, will ich zu sagen.
Da hat keiner auf Optik geachtet, ne.
Wie gesagt, hier bunte Kabel, halb zusammengebundene Kabel, weiße Kabel, schwarze Kabel, rote, gelbe, orangene.
Und die Boards sahen halt einfach auch total billig aus.
Heute hast du dann irgendwelche Hochglanz-Boards mit Metall-Shields drauf und alles mögliche.
Und damals hier so nach dem Motto, alles draufgequetscht, was irgendwie geht, bam, zu, in Karton, fertig.
Oh, Kaltstart.
Wieso machst du keine YouTube-Videos mehr?
Weil mich YouTube nicht sonderlich motiviert gerade.
Aber vielleicht kommt im Dezember was komplett Unerwartetes, wenn ich das wirklich auf die Reihe bekomme.
Na?
Und dann nicht nur ein Video.
Ich bin beeindruckt.
Also, man möchte jetzt ja, glaube ich, wissen, was das Ding kann oder wie sich das Teil im Alltag schlägt.
Also...
Schlecht.
YouTube-Videos laufen tatsächlich in 720p und 30 FPS, so wie ich das gesehen habe.
Okay, das ist wirklich Müll, wenn das nicht 1080p hinbekommt.
Aber der sollte doch eigentlich 1080p hinbekommen.
Was ist denn das für eine CPU? Hat das jemand mitbekommen?
Also, 1080p-CPU decoden müsste doch eigentlich auch eine alte CPU hinkriegen.
V2 Duo sollte doch 1080p decoded bekommen.
Und 4K, ja, das nicht.
Aber unter Linux hast du immer noch das Problem, dass allgemein Video-Decoding im Browser so ein schwieriges Szenario ist.
Alles drüber funktioniert so überhaupt nicht.
Also, nicht von der Bildschirmauflösung her, sondern es geht einfach nicht.
Weder mit der internen Grafikeinheit noch mit dieser komischen ATI-Karte, die da drin verbaut ist.
Surfen so an sich ist...
Oh, es ruckelt.
Ich wollte ursprünglich aufgeschrieben haben, dass es okay ist.
Aber ich habe an dem Abend ein, zwei Bierchen getrunken.
Also, dass es okay ist.
Was?
Ah, den Schwanz bei Finanzen einzuziehen.
Ich habe an dem Abend ein, zwei Bierchen getrunken.
Also, habe ich das noch mal revidiert.
Und nein, das ist nicht ganz so toll.
Oh, das ist eklig.
Nee, das kannst du vergessen.
Es gibt aber Leute, soll ich mal sagen, es gibt genug Leute, die merken nicht, dass es laggt.
Die sagen, ich sehe das nicht.
Ist doch schnell genug.
Ich merke das nicht.
Nö, nö, passt doch alles.
Gibt es ganz viele so Leute.
Und dann kam ich irgendwie, während der Browser noch geöffnet war, auf die Idee,
mir mal das CPU-Modell und den Arbeitsspeicher und so weiter anzeigen zu lassen.
Also habe ich die Einstellungen geöffnet.
Und dann ist der PC tatsächlich eingefroren, so quasi.
Die Maus konnte ich noch bewegen.
Habe ein bisschen gewartet.
Das hat sich immer noch nicht gebessert.
Ist sogar ein paar Mal aufgetreten, später noch.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, komm, machst du einen Neustart.
Ich würde es mal interessieren, wie es unter Windows läuft, hier bei der Kiste.
Aber, apropos Neustart.
90 Sekunden waren das irgendwie, oder 100 Sekunden, falls das nicht ganz richtig war.
Ich werde später nochmal nachmessen an der Videolänge.
Dann werde ich das jetzt korrigieren.
Das ist manchmal ein wenig zeitraubend.
Und dann habe ich natürlich die Einstellungen irgendwann noch öffnen können.
Und mir ist dann aufgefallen, ja, 1,9 GB RAM.
Müssten eigentlich zwei sein, okay.
Der müsste doch, der müsste doch ein 1080p-Video decoded kriegen.
Jetzt vielleicht kein 60 FPS.
Aber da haben wir ja noch bei der Grafikkarte die Besonderheit,
dass sie sich tatsächlich,
Arbeitsspeicher vom Haupt-PC ziehen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern der Arbeitsspeicher davon betroffen wird.
Ich weiß nur, dass es sein kann, weil Hyper Memory oder so hieß das.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, aber das gibt es auf jeden Fall.
Also dann dachte ich noch, komm, so als letzten Test,
könnten wir doch mal Minecraft probieren.
Und dann fingen die richtigen Probleme an.
Ich habe nämlich mein Passwort vergessen.
Das kommt davon, dass man das Ding fertig macht, dann eine Woche nichts macht.
Ja, das ist kein Problem.
Oh, oh, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Kriegt er den Trick hin zum Booten?
Das Passwort gefragt wird.
Ich wollte es erst zurücksetzen, da gibt es ja so ein paar Methoden.
Ja, genau, zum Beispiel.
Das ist eine der Methoden, die funktioniert.
Ja, das ist richtig gut.
Richtig, ja.
Aber irgendwie hat das nicht geklappt eigentlich.
Ich glaube, man muss es, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was ist denn das hier für ein...
Wobei, das ist...
Eigentlich richtig.
Da gibt es ja so ein paar Methoden.
Das ist eigentlich richtig.
Methoden.
Das müsste eigentlich funktionieren.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, was da alles an der richtigen Stelle eigentlich ist,
aber das müsste eigentlich klappen.
Ich würde es mit binsh probieren, nicht gerade binbash.
Wer weiß, aber bash ist eigentlich auch überall drauf.
Das müsste eigentlich gehen.
Man kann es noch mit s probieren oder mit 1 hintendran.
Single User, das geht auch bei manchen.
Aber irgendwie hat das nicht geklappt.
Ein Root-Passwort wurde vorher nicht vergeben und als ich es vergeben habe, konnte ich es auch benutzen,
aber trotzdem konnte ich keine Sachen installieren und dann habe ich noch tausende Passwörter geraten und so weiter.
Jetzt hat er Windows drauf gemacht.
Super, Philipp.
Und dann ist mir noch aufgefallen, dass es bei dieser Linux-Version sehr, sehr komisch ist,
wenn man etwas installieren möchte und das falsch schreibt zum Beispiel.
MC, Midnight Commander zum Beispiel.
Dann schlägt er dir sogar vor, einzutippen apt install mc.
Gibst du das ein, sagt er, konnte nicht gefunden werden.
Das heißt, habe ich nachgeschaut.
Das ist halt das Problem, dass viele Dinger halt übelst unpolished sind.
Sources.conf heißt sie, glaube ich.
Sieh mal beim Thema, ich habe doch eben gerade noch gesagt, das sieht aus wie Windows,
aber sobald du ein bisschen an der Oberfläche kratzt, merkt man halt,
es ist kein Windows.
Deswegen hat es, finde ich, auch überhaupt keinen Sinn, den Leuten irgendwie vorzugaukeln,
es wäre wie Windows.
War einfach nichts drin.
Also musste ich das auch noch eben nachrüsten, kurioserweise,
damit ich auch mal so ein paar Sachen installieren konnte, wirklich im Terminal
und nicht nur über irgendwelche .deb-Dateien oder diesen run-Installer hier,
der, naja, nicht ganz funktioniert.
Aber dann war es endlich soweit.
Ich wollte Minecraft starten.
Ich weiß nämlich nicht, warum er das zweimal installiert hat.
Ich habe mich angemeldet.
Er wollte noch Java haben.
Dann habe ich das nachinstalliert.
Und dann gab es Fehler null.
Da dachte ich mir, gut, Grafiktreiber könnten es vielleicht sein.
Fehler null, exzellent.
Und das ist auch das, was ich jetzt gerade seit gefühlt 10 Minuten versuche hier laufen zu lassen
und es passiert einfach nichts.
Der soll nichts laden.
Dann probier es mal unter Windows.
Also die Chancen, dass es da funktioniert, sind deutlich besser.
Weil du hast gerade genug Zeit gehabt zum Laden.
Du könntest langsam mal anfangen.
Und wenn das hier nicht fertig wird, dann wird das auch nichts mit Minecraft.
Da kannst du dir sicher sein.
Es steht nun Moment der Wahrheit vor der Tür.
Ich habe gerade extra den Treiber runtergeladen und er sagte mir, er ist nicht supported.
Dann google ich und dann sagt mir die Internetseite von Sorin,
alle Karten Neujahrs 2013 laufen automatisch.
Gut, das lasse ich jetzt mal so dahingestellt.
Ach ja.
Und ich habe mal hier eine RX 570 reingepackt.
Passt super, ich weiß.
1 Euro PC.
Und habe den Arbeitsplatz auf 2x2 GB aufgestockt.
Mehr kann das Ding nicht.
Ach ja, und ich habe das Passwort aufgeschrieben.
Sorin12 und der Benutzer heißt Carlos.
Das war vorher auch so.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was das sollte.
Das dauert immer so lange.
Aber apropos lange.
Ich habe hier vorne einen WLAN-Stick drin.
Die gab es bei Paulin für 99 Euro.
Ich weiß noch genau, warum.
Qualitativ bestimmt absolut wahnsinnig dick.
So Standard-Treiber von Windows damit nicht gehen.
Und der DVD-Treiber auch irgendwie nicht läuft.
Das heißt, man benötigt wahrscheinlich irgendwas anderes.
Oder einen umgeschriebenen Treiber oder so.
Weil das Ding dann einfach nicht läuft.
Aber hier hat es tatsächlich funktioniert.
Ist aber trotzdem langsamer als LAN.
So.
Und geht es?
Ja.
Das machst du gut.
Okay, das ist ja nicht zu ertragen langsam.
Aha.
Und eine Minute zehn später haben wir dann fertig geladen hier.
Und 59 FPS passt vermutlich nicht so ganz.
Sieht flüssig aus.
Ja.
Also ist jetzt schwierig so zu spielen.
Ja, 30 FPS vielleicht gerade so eben.
Vollscreen?
Hier haben wir nochmal die CPU.
E6850.
Vollscreen?
Und den Treiber.
Hm.
Aber schön zu sehen, dass es zumindest irgendwie funktioniert.
Nur wahrscheinlich mit der uralten Karte nicht.
Ist aber auch verständlich.
Und wen es interessiert, wenn man jetzt in diesem Zustand YouTube-Videos gucken möchte,
funktioniert 1080p zwar ruckelfrei,
allerdings nicht in 60 FPS.
Ja, das ist okay.
Nur in diesem Fenster so ab und zu mal kommen dann so 30
und dann mal wieder 50 oder 60 und dann immer vor und zurück.
Aber Internetbrowsen an sich, vor allem bei eBay Kleinanzeigen,
wo ich es ja einmal gerade gezeigt habe,
sieht es eine ganze Menge besser aus.
Aber, na, also jetzt kann man sagen,
okay, Web Experience ist okay.
Nicht mehr und nicht weniger.
Aber das liegt höchstwahrscheinlich nicht nur an der Grafikkarte.
Oder was ich damit sagen will.
Pack da irgendeine Grafikkarte rein.
Ich würde es mal unter Windows probieren.
Die Chancen, dass es besser läuft, sind gar nicht mal so übel.
Ich bin Zehner, finde es irgendwie eine,
weiß ich nicht, eine 9500 GT oder, ne,
GT 220, irgendwas anderes, außer dieses hässliche Ding da vorne.
Arbeitsspeicher ist auf jeden Fall wichtig,
dass der größer wird.
Was fein ist, ist es dann nicht.
Aber man kann es auf jeden Fall benutzen.
Ja, und es gibt genug Leute, die nicht merken, dass es lahm ist.
Das erste, was ich jetzt tun werde,
ist die Grafikkarte hier wieder rausnehmen.
Das passt überhaupt nicht.
Aber ich hatte ja auch noch gesagt,
Netzteil müssen wir testen.
Und bis jetzt, also gab es da so keine Probleme.
Also entweder gibt es bei diesem Teil kein Power-Good-Signal
oder das Power-Good-Signal ist fälschlicherweise
ausgefallen.
Kann sein, kann auch nicht sein.
Solange sich raucht, ist alles gut.
Ist ja auch keine schlechte Marke.
Also von daher habe ich das schon gezeigt,
wenn man den PC ausmacht, habt ihr gehört,
Festplatte geht aus, dann laufen die Lüfter hier noch
ein paar Sekunden weiter.
Das ist nicht unbedingt notwendig.
Ja, aber das machen viele Netzteile.
Irgendwie cool und vielleicht auch ganz gut,
wenn das System stark belastet wurde.
Also ich finde, man kann ja nicht unbedingt von
starker Belastung sprechen oder andere Architektur.
Knackst weg, weil Zeitstempel.
Ja, okay, wirklich null Euro war das jetzt auch nicht.
Da wurde ja viel Zeug dazu gebastelt noch.
Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich bin schon viereinhalb Stunden on.
Ich gehe jetzt off, ich gehe jetzt was futtern
und mal aufs Klo Döner bestellen.
Nee, nee, ich habe von gestern noch was.
Dann noch Bratkartoffeln und ein bisschen Kram.
So, das passt schon.
Ich habe noch ziemlich viel, ziemlich viel Zeug hier offen.
Irgendwas, was wir nächste Woche gucken.
Speichere das einfach mal.
Ich mache einfach mal alles hier.
Zack.
Bookmark all tabs.
Session.
Heute ist der 25.10.
Zack, save.
Exzellent.
Nein, meine Toilette ist nicht smart.
Die hat zwar Spülung von Bobbes und einen Föhn
und alle möglichen abgedrehten Sachen drin.
Aber die kann man nicht über Smartphone steuern.
Clean App.
Mal gucken, ob es da eine App mittlerweile für gibt.
Mal gucken, was supported wird.
Vielleicht wird ja mein Klo supported.
Das Icon.
Ich habe einen.
Ja, das da.
Das ist übrigens das Video von mir,
was irgendein russischer Klo Channel geklaut hat.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels.
Hier ist der Max.
Das bin ich jetzt tatsächlich so weit, dass ich.
Das ist mein Klo Video und das ist jetzt hochgeladen worden auf Bidet24.
Aber der Chat hat schon hat schon gefunden.
Bidet24.
Gekommnet.
Der hat einfach einfach das Klo Video von mir hochgeladen.
Smartphone.
Gibt es da irgendeine Möglichkeit,
das an Smartphone zu bekommen?
Ist da irgendeine App für?
Das ist leider noch ein bisschen alt.
Da gab es noch keine Apps.
Nee.
Smartphone.
Oh, warum hat das so schlechte Ratings?
Reservable Qualität.
Was?
Fünften WC Sitz?
What the fuck?
Ich habe echt keine Schmerzen damit.
Das funktioniert wunderbar.
Leider gibt es keine App,
die mein Klo supportet.
Tja.
Pech gehabt.
Da muss ich weiter Knöpfe drücken.
Was?
Erster Link gerade?
Was für ein erster Link?
Apps und Tools.
Da ist nichts für mein Klo dabei.
Leider.
Ja.
Leider gibt es da nichts.
Warum braucht man fürs Klo eine App?
Warum nicht?
Ist da die eigentliche Frage.
Ich glaube, mein Klo hat ja auch kein WLAN oder sowas.
Ich könnte sowas selber basteln.
Da müsste ich halt irgendwie gucken,
wie ich die Fernbedienung
vielleicht mit einem ESP32 nachmachen kann.
Das würde funktionieren.
Ich könnte die Fernbedienung nachmachen.
Also die Infrarotbefehle lernen.
Und dann könnte ich über die App auch auslösen,
dass das Klo spült und sowas.
Okay.
Warum brauchst du dann noch
zusätzlich 72 Rollen Klopapier?
Ja, weil man sich trotzdem den Hintern abputzen muss
mit Klopapier.
Zwar, du brauchst jetzt nicht mehr so viel,
aber mal drüberputzen musst du trotzdem noch.
Einfach, dass das ganze Wasser auch abgeht,
weil ich verwende den eingebauten Föhn nicht.
Mag ich irgendwie nicht.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir die wichtigsten Sachen ja nochmal geklärt.
Also, wir sehen uns.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Und dann gehe ich aufs Klo.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.